MORNING WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY WE WILL BEGIN AS
A SUB COMMITTEE UNTIL WE GET A
QUORUM AS USUAL WILL BE AGAIN
OUR ORDER BUSINESS WITH THE
USUAL- A COVERT RELATED
ANNOUNCEMENT. GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
HEARING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AT H. H. H. T. T. P. S. A. P.
S. F. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND MAYBE READ
INTO THE RECORD ARE REPRINTED
ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO WATCH. TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM ITS LIVE
STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE-
AGAIN AT W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV SLASH TODAY'S EVENT
ANY MEMBER REPUBLIC ATTENDING A
HEARING IN THE CAPITOL WHERE
WILL NEED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES. WHILE IN THE BUILDING WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
UPDATES OUR GOAL IS TO GO
THROUGH THE AGENDA IN
ALPHABETICAL. ORDER ACCEPT READ
TODAY- WE HAVE TO SPECIAL
ORDER. S. B. TO BRADFORD OF
PEACE OFFICER CERTIFICATION
CIVIL RIGHTS- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE MAIN WITNESSES
WILL HAVE A COMBINED TIED. UP
FIVE MINUTES PER SIDE AS IS OUR
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE- TWO
WITNESSES PER SIDE PLEASE. SO
MISTER BRADFORD YOU'RE HERE
YOU'RE HERE ON TIME. YOU PLEASE
COME TO THE PODIUM FOR S. B.
WELL YOU TAKE REPORT S. B. A
TWO. AND THEN IMMEDIATELY AFTER
WE CAN TAKE UP YOUR OTHER. YOUR
OTHER CHEN DIED ITEM. EARLY
DURING THE REMOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRUCE. THREE TO
CONTROL. ONLY ONE SOLVERS ZERO
OR TO THE. ONE BILL OF OUR
RESIDENTS WERE DOING WHAT WE
ARE. SO FOR EXCLUDES.
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL MAYNARD
PROBLEM UNIQUE STUDENT OF MINE
WE WERE VIA SCHAGEN ABOUT OUR.
THREE THOUSAND EIGHTEEN- WRONG
FOR. THE MORE THE. I OFTEN VIA
THEN OFFICER IF THE
CERTIFICATION EVENT PLACE YOUR
ONE BECAUSE THIS OFFICER WAS
INVOLVED IN THREE OTHER
QUESTIONABLE SHOOTINGS IN
ANOTHER PART REMEMBER. TO THE
CITY OF GARDENA UNFORTUNATELY
CAN THE FROST UP WAS NOT UNIQUE.
BUT IT'S REFLECTIVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND
HAPPENED ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON
A REGULAR BASIS. THESE ARE
PROBLEMATIC OFFICERS THAT
COMMITMENTS CONDUCT. AND ONE
DEPARTMENT. AND ARE YOU ARE NOT
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR CONTINUE
TO BE A PROBLEMFOR THAT
COMMUNITY OR THEY ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BUT THEY'RE ABLE TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT AT ANOTHER
APARTMENT IN ANOTHER CITY.
USUALLY THESE PROBLEM OFFICERS
FIND THEMSELVES IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. AND THE POOR
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE NEVER IN A
FLUENT COMMUNITIES OR AT LEAST
YOU DON'T SEE THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR AND THOSE COMMUNITIES.
DURCH OFTEN IS AN EXAMPLE ONE
OF THESE OFFICERS WHO. LONG
BEFORE HE MURDERED GEORGE
FLOYD. ADDED EXTENSIVE HISTORY
OF COMPLAINTS OF MISCONDUCT
FILED AGAINST HIM. THIS
INCLUDED HOLDING A FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD BLACK CHILD DOWN. WHAT
IS NAY SOUNDS FAMILIAR. NOW FOR
NINE MINUTES AND THIRTY NINE
SECONDS FOR SEVENTEEN MINUTES
IGNORING COMPLAINTS BY THAT
TEENAGER THAT PRODUCTS THE-
DATED THE PHRASE I CAN'T
BREATHE I'M PRETTY SURE YOU
HEARD THAT BEFORE. ALTHOUGH HE
WASN'T ULTIMATELY HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS PRIOR
MISCONDUCT MINNESOTA DOES HAVE
A MECHANISM AVAILABLE. IN THE
STATE TO DECERTIFY. OFFICERS
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DIDN'T USE
IT HERE. BUT CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT WE'RE ONE OF ONLY FOUR
STATES IN THE NATION THAT
DOESN'T HAVE THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. SB TWO WILL DO TWO
THINGS. THE BILL MAKES CHANGES
TO STRENGTHEN THE TOM BANKS SO
WE'RE RIGHTS ACT IT CLARIFIES
THAT THREE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS IMMUNITIES CALMLY
ASSERTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
NOT APPLICABLES TO CLAIMS
BROUGHT UNDER THE BAN ACT. AND
THAT'S FOLLOWING A FOST OF OUR
FALSIFYING ARRESTS. GOING TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE ARE
CAUSING INJURY TO A PRISONER
SECOND THE BILL CREATES A
STATEWIDE PROCESS TO REVOKE THE
CERTIFICATION OF OFFICER AFTER
THE CONVICTION OF SERIOUS
CRIMES FOR TERMINATION FROM
EMPLOYMENT DUE TO MISCONDUCT
CALIFORNIA'S ABLE TO REVOKE THE
CERTIFICATION AND THE LICENSE
ABOUT DOCTORS LAWYERS TEACHERS
NURSES. BARBERS COSMETOLOGISTS
WE CAN EVEN RECALL ELECTED
OFFICIALS BUT WERE UNABLE TO
DECERTIFY POLICE OFFICERS WHO
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW AND
VIOLATED PUBLIC TRUST AND THIS
IS WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT NOT
ABOUT A RADICAL EATING POLICE
ARE DE FUNDING THE POLICE IT'S
ABOUT GETTING RID OF THOSE BAD
APPLES THAT WE KNOW EXIST AN
ALL OF SOCIETY. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A FAIR AND EFFECTIVE
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO BREAK
THE PUBLIC TRUST ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
AND NOT ALLOW THE SIMPLY MOVED
TO ANOTHER DEPARTMENT AS I
STATED THE WASHED RINSE AND
REPEAT CYCLE THAT WE'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THIS NATION
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER.
STANDERTON TRAINING TO
INVESTIGATE GROUNDS FOR
OFFICERS MISCONDUCT LET ME SAY
THIS AGAIN IT ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING
COMMISSION THAT IS PRIMARILY
MADE UP LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO
INVESTIGATE THE GROUNDS FOR
OFFERS MISCONDUCT THIS IS
STORIES IMPORTANT IN ENSURING
THAT WE ARE CREATING AN
EFFECTIVE. THE CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM. WOULD ALSO BE CREATING
ADVISORY BOARD WITH THE IMPULSE
THAT WOULD MAKE INITIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHETHER POLL
SHOULD DECERTIFY AN OFFICER.
AND FIND THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION TO DEFINE BY
REGULATIONS THE SPECIFIC
GROUNDS OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR
DECERTIFICATION. SEVERAL
SEVERAL THESE EGREGIOUS GROUNDS
ARE LAID OUT IN THE BILL SUCH
AS SEXUAL ASSAULT. THIS HONESTY
AND ABUSE OF POWER AMONG OTHERS
ALSO MADE THE COMMISSION HAS
AUTHORITY AND DEFINING WHAT
EXACTLY MISCONDUCT- CAN LEAD TO
WHAT EXACT MISCONDUCT CAN LEAD
TO DO CERTIFICATION. WE FEEL
THIS IS A FAIR APPROACH. IS
NOTHING RADICAL ABOUT THIS MANY
OTHER STATES AS I STATED ARE
CURRENTLY DOING THIS. WE
RECENTLY MADE AMENDMENTS AFTER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND MANY OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND MAJOR
CHANGE FOLLOWING THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WAS TO BE
MOVED ABILITY TO FILE A
WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIM UNDER
THOMAS PAINE ACT WILL ALSO MADE
SEVERAL CHANGES RELATED TO THE
TORY. OF THE ADVISORY BOARD.
REMOVE THE LICENSING FEE. AND
LIMIT THE EXTENT. TO WHICH
POLLS CONDUCTED OWN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS THESE CHANGES
WERE NOT EASY FOR US TO MAKE.
BUT I THINK WE LEFT THE BILL
THAT IS FAIR AND STRONG AND
WILL ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO. ACHIEVE
HERE. IT WILL BE A PROCESS THAT
IS EFFECTIVE IN REDDING
DEPARTMENTS OF BAD OFFICERS.
BUT STE STILL WORKABLE FOR THE
POST COMMISSION. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL
WITH AN ADMINISTRATION WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WE HAVE
WORKED WITH THIS COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. THE TIME IS NOW
TO CREATE A POLICE TO
CERTIFICATION SYSTEM AND
CALIFORNIA. IF NOT NOW THEN
WHEN IT MUST BE STRONG IT MUST
BE A SYSTEM THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN TRUST
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE THE
LEADER WE LEAD AND ENVIRONMENT
WE LEADING TECHNOLOGY WE LEAD
AND A COPY OF THE ECONOMY. AND
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. BUT WE FILLED THE
LEAD WHEN WE TALK ABOUT REAL
POLICE REFORM HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE DAY I'M HAPPY
TO HAVE TWO AMAZING INDIVIDUALS
TESTIFYING ON OUR BEHALF. FOR
USE THAT. I'M A ROUTE YOU
CHOOSE THE MOTHER OF KENNETH
ROSS JUNIOR. AND DYING
GOLDSTINE EXACT DIRECTOR OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION. PARTNERSHIP
AND WILL ALSO HAVE PETER BY
BRING- FROM THE ACLU HERE TO
ASK ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT BE A ROCK-
MIGHT COME UP. AND I WILL IN
THEIR AND OUR WHICH BERKELEY US
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TO
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD WAS LISTEN TO
MISS ALMA RUTH FIRST AND THEN-
DI<c.cyan> GHOSTING FROM BLACK</c>
LIVES MATTER. YOU HAVE TWO AND
A HALF MINUTES A PIECE OR
WHATEVER WAY YOU WANT TO SPLIT
IT UP. YES MY NAME IS MELINA
ABSOLUTE ONBLACK LIVES MATTER
AND I'M REPRESENTING MY SCHOOL
VIA ARMBAR RULE WHO IS HAVING
AN URGENT MATTER WITH HER OTHER
CHILDREN THIS MORNING BUT SHE
ASKED ME TO READ HER STATEMENT
IN HER STEAD- SO HERE'S YOUR
STATEMENT. ROCKY JUNIOR WITH MY
FIRSTBORN. HE WAS MY ROCK IN
THIS WORLD ON APRIL ELEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SERGEANT
MICHAEL WRAPPING OF THE GARDENA
POLICE DEPARTMENT. WHICH USED
TO BE CAN I SET MY SON AS A
LOVING FATHER TO HIS SON. AS
THE OLDER SIBLING IS A TALENTED
YOUNG BLACK MAN YOU HAVE A
GREAT POTENTIAL AND EVERY
POSSIBILITY IN THIS WORLD.
MICHAEL ROBBINS PUT IT TARGET
ON MY SON'S BACK HE HUNTED IM
LIKE CRAZY. AND SHOT HIM IN
COLD BLOOD. HE TOLD HER ME AND
STOLE FROM MY FAMILY SOMETHING
THAT IS IRREPLACEABLE. YOU
CAN'T BEGIN TO IMAGINE THE PAIN
THAT I. WRESTLE WITH EVERY
SINGLE DAY. WHAT I LEARN THAT
IT WHAT I'M- IS THAT IT IS
TRULY A GAME FOR TARGET MICHAEL
WRAPPING. WELL FOR SURE
SHOOTING KENNETH ROBIN SHOT
SHOT THREE OTHER PEOPLE AND
SEPARATE INCIDENTS IN A
PREVIOUS POLICE FOR. BUT HE WAS
STILL HIRED BY GARDENA POLICE
DEPARTMENT YOU NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ON THE FORCE IN THE
FIRST PLACE HE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE HAD A BADGE AND A GUN.
AFTER THE FIRST SHOOTING HE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN BARRED FROM
BEING AN OFFICER ANYWHERE. THIS
IS WHAT SB TWO WILL GET. THE
CANNOT BROUGHT YOUNGER POLICE
DECERTIFICATION BILL NAMED IN
HONOR OF MY- WILL PREVENT OTHER
MOTHERS FROM HAVING TO LIVE
WITH THE PAIN AND RAGE THAT
IDEA. IT WILL REMOVE OFFICER TO
ALREADY PROVEN TO BE DANGEROUS.
WE MUST PASS THIS BILL AND THE
NAME OF MY SON. KENNETH ROCK
JUNIOR. AND WE ALSO OFFER A
BLACK LIVES MATTER THAT DAY IS
THAT EACH ANNIVERSARY OF BLACK
LIVES MATTER IN THE APPROPRIATE
DAY IS SO MANY OF YOU HAVE
LISTED THE WORD INSTEAD THE
WORD. BLACK LIVES MATTER THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO BUILD
COMMITTEE CAN MAKE BLACK LIVES
MATTER NOT JUST SAY THE WORD SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING
ON AND- WE OFFER PRAYER OR-
YEAH I'M A REAL AND THE FAMILY
OF CANNOCK. JUNIOR PROPONENTS
STILL LISTENING THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO THE AUTHOR HE BRADFORD
FOR HONORING CANISTERS. IN THIS
WAY. THANK YOU DR. BED
DISTINGUISHED OF THE MY NAME
STAND I'M A RICH LEE AND THE
EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
A GROUP OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROFESSIONALS WHO SPEAK FROM
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE. WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO AS
AMENDED WHICH WOULD INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OFFICERS WHO
COMMIT SERIOUS MISCONDUCT AND
VIOLATE A PERSON CIVIL RIGHTS
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
CREATE A MULTI LAYER SYSTEM OF
DUE PROCESS TO REVOKE
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING ISSUE
TWO OFFICERS FOR MISCONDUCT.
ASIAN WIDE FORTY SIX STATES
ALREADY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DECERTIFY THEIR COPS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE. UNDER
PRESSURE FROM POLICE LOBBYIST
THE LEGISLATURE REMOVE POSTS
THE FORTY TO DENY OR CANCEL AN
OFFICER CERTIFICATION. THIS
LEFT THE DISCIPLINE OF OFFICERS
ACCUSED OF MISCONDUCT TO LOCAL
AGENCIES ALLOWING THE POLICE TO
POLICE THEMSELVES. FOLLOWING
THE ENACTMENT OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE THERE'S BEEN
NUMEROUS STORIES OF OFFICERS
COMMITTEE MISCONDUCT. THESE
OFFICERS REMAIN EMPLOYED AFTER
PLEADING DOWN TO LESSER CRIME
IF THEY'RE PROSECUTED AND
CONVICTED AT ALL OTHER TIMES
THESE OFFICERS RESIGN OR ARE
FIRED ONLY TO GET RE HIRED AT
ANOTHER AGENCY WHERE THE
MISCONDUCT CONTINUES. THE
INABILITY TO REMOVE THESE
OFFICERS UNDERMINES POLICE
LEGITIMACY AND COMPROMISES
PUBLIC SAFETY. I SERVED IN BOTH
THE SUPERVISORY CAPACITY AS
WELL AS COMMANDING MULTIPLE
DIVISIONS THE SHOW ME EXACTLY
WHY COMMUNITIES FEEL UNSAFE
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ARE NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
VIOLATING OUR OATH TO PROTECT
AND SERVE. SB TWO IS A SIMPLE
AND OBVIOUS SOLUTION BY
PROVIDING ROBUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPRESENTATION IT
ENSURES THE PROCESS FOLLOWS THE
MODEL OF OTHER LICENSING BOARD
IN THE STATE AND CREATES A
THOROUGH SYSTEM OF REVIEW THAT
PROTECTS BOTH THE COMMUNITY AND
POLICE OFFICERS RIGHTS. IN A
RECENT EDITORIAL WRITTEN BY THE
PRESIDENTS OF THE LAPD
PROTECTIVELY THE SAN JOSE IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. THEY
STATED ENACT POLICE REFORM STOP
STUDYING. AND FRUSTRATION WITH
THE LACK OF FEDERAL LEADERSHIP
THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE POLICING
PROFESSION. I WAS I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THEIR WORDS MATTER
IN THIS CONTEXT AS WELL WHEN IT
COMES TO IMPROVING POLICING
IT'S TIME TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING. SB TWO WILL NOT FIX
EVERYTHING THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED IN POLICING BUT IT IS
A NECESSARY STEP THAT WILL
SHORT CONSTITUENTS WE ARE
LISTENING TO THEIR CONCERNS AND
THAT THEY ARE INTEGRAL IN
DEFINING WHAT COMMUNITY SAFETY
MEANS. WE URGE YOU TO PASS SB
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NOW WE'LL GO INTO THE
ROOM- THERE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO
OH TWO. IN FAVOR OF SB TWO MAY
COME TO THE TO MIKE RIGHT NOW
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
GOOD MORNING GLENN BACKUS FOR
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
BREATH GOAL PEELING ON SPEAKING
ABOUT HALF OF THE- RICHARD
PEREZ AND FAMILY LOST THEIR SON
P. PRESS AND DEVELOP A BECCLES
EIGHTY TRANSIT DIRECTOR AND
FORMER RICHMOND VICE MAYOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS KEVIN MCCARTY I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US ARE NONE.
WE SENT IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SHANINA SHAIK. WAS THE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. AND AS A BLACK MOTHER
AND THE MEMBER OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MOST NOT THE WORLD THAT
I AND I AM HERE- ON BEHALF OF
THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE AT UC BERKELEY AND
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A GOOD
MORNING A CHOI WILLIAMS
COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER FOR
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN A MEMBER OF ALL
OF US AND NONE. STANDING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF- SB TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HELLO GOOD
MORNING HONEY MARULA- ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US ARE NOT SACRAMENTO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING KELLY
WALTERS STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO. THANK YOU. SHE
IN NO MORE WITNESSES WITHIN
FORTY. TWO TO ONE OUT TO GO TO
TELECONFERENCING. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND TELECONFERENCING
ROOM. OR OUTSIDE. SHARE YOUR
CHAIR WE HAVE BUT. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE TWENTY PEOPLE TO W.
WISHING THIS EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS PLANK THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY ONE. HI MY
NAME IS ELLIE I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STOCK
WILL DO SOME CROWDS COSPONSORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FINE EIGHTY. SAGA MORNING
DIDN'T CARE MORTON COMMITTEE ON
ON BEHALF OF PAUL DOING CAN BE
APPLIED TO BOTH MEN OF COLOR WE
ARE COAST MARKET AND A STRONG
SUPPORTER SB TWO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHY IN. TWENTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING OF COOKING
ON IS ON BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN
FOR GUN SAFETY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY EIGHT.
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS MALIBU
SHEA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO. THANK YOU.
AT. SIXTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
LIVING ECONOMIC HAPPENED A
SALIENT CALIFORNIA ACTION CO
SPONSORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE WITH THE CHAIRS PERMISSION
I'D LIKE TO READ OFF A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE MADE-
VOICED THEIR SUPPORT IN THIS
COMMITTEE. YES YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AS FAR JUST THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE NEXTGEN
CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE FOR
PROGRESS. OF THE CALIFORNIA.
COALITION PROSECUTORS A LINE TO
CALIFORNIA THEN THE ARK JEWISH
ACTION CALIFORNIA EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES NORTHRIDGE
INDIVISIBLE PRESS NOBODY ALSO
NEEDLES. LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION CONSUMER
WATCHDOG SAN DIEGO PRIDE WE THE
PEOPLE AT THE COLORS OF THE
COMMUNITY S. B. THINK THINK
MANY. ASIAN SOLIDARITY
COLLECTIVE SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE ESTEY AND NORTH
COUNTY AT THE- UPRIGHTS THEATER.
CAN YOU GO TO Z. COLLECT.
MISSION IMPACT PHILANTHROPY THE
SETTLE BE A- SOCIAL WORKERS FOR
AT IN THE- HEALTH PRESIDENT OF
THE- BY AT SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO
PROGRESS DEMOCRATIC PLAN
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF NEW AMERICAN DEMOCRATIC CLUB
THE VASA. RACIAL DOESN'T
COALITION AT THE CHANGE BEGINS
WITH ME INDIVISIBLE DEMOCRATIC
WOMAN'S CLUB THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER INITIATE JUSTICE
EMPOWERING PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES. NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES PROJECT
MORE GOVERNANCE GROUPS HAVE
CHANGED ORANGE COUNTY QUALITY
COALITION FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION JUST WITHIN THE
NETWORK AND NATIONAL LAWYERS.
GUILD AT THAT AREA THANK YOU.
THEY YOU. LINE SEVENTY FOUR.
MORNING MY NAME IS A BEST GUESS
AND ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS AND A
STRONG SUPPORT- SB TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. LINE. THIRTY
SEVEN. THE MORNING CARE MEMBER
POSTED UP ON THE HAVE ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY TWO.
ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE ALL THIS IS A PIZZA
WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION AND CO SPONSORS BUT
I'D BE TO IT WHICH STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWO EIGHTY
SIX. ANYWAY LOOK AT THE END
CALIFORNIA IS SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. I AM. TWENTY
SEVEN. ALSO WITH YOU TO ASSIST
COALITION BASE IN SOUTH CENTRAL
COM SOFTWARE AT SOME POINT TO.
WHY DO YOU SEE. THE COALITION.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY TWO. SH
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SHEILA
MEREDITH WITH ACLU NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT SB
TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. LINE. EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN WE FIND
WHAT YOU NEED IF YOU ASK ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. G.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO WE
ALSO HAVE A CO SPONSORSHIP
RECOMMENDATION UNTIL ALLEGE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. THIRTY THREE. THE MONEY
NECESSARY MEMBERS WILLIAM UP
THE BIRD ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BY. FIFTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
EMILY THIS UP IN WITH YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION PROBLEMS ONCE
IN THE BILL CALLING FROM VALLEY
PARK YOU GARDENA SOLIDARITY
WITH THE SENATE CANNOT TRUST
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
FIVE AND. HELLO MY NAME IS
BECKY WHITE I AM A MEMBER OF
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
SAN DIEGO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A G.
SUGAR AARON I AM THE MOTHER OF
MARIE SPARING DEALER BERNARD
BUYING UP WITH THEIR AGENCY H.
P. DIVISION IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN CALLING WOULD STOP
COALITION PROUD CO SPONSOR I
HEARD YOU PLEASE PASSED SB TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
NINETY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MOLLY CRITICAL IN MANTA FOR
NEW BEEN TO BALANCE THAT WITH
CHOKING TWENTY FIFTH MAY HELP
PACKED THE CHUCKLE BILL I NEED
SUPPORT OF S. B. DO YOU. I'M
WITH- TACKLE THIS. THANK YOU.
BY. SEVENTY MY NAME IS HELD UP
A LITTLE BY AND I AM THE SISTER
OF DAVID ROBUST JUNIOR WHO WAS
MURDERED MARCH FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY ONLY SB
SHOT AT SEVENTEEN TIME MY
FAMILY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX EIGHT THREE. PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT. ONE SIXTY THREE
OH WHAT OPEN. THE MORNING CARE
MEMBER THIS IS ERIC HARRIS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CONNECTED
WITH ADVANCEMENT PROJECT
CALIFORNIA WITH MY SUPPORT FOR
SB TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWO OR ONE
NO TWO. WHAT MIGHT BETTER
CALIFORNIA WE ARE COLD BOB
HERTZBERG CAN GET CAN'T GET.
YEAH SB IT EIGHT THANK YOU.
SOME LINE FOR TWO. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL OF THE LOTTO
AND THE VOLUNTEER. AND FOR GUN
SENSE SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SLYNT. SIXTY TWO. HI MY
NAME IS AMERICAN MODEL RECENT
THAT I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CHIEF- WHICH COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HEY LINE. FORTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CATHERINE MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE ENDING QUALIFIED MEANING
PROJECT- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
IT THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS CARLA CAN BE ARMED WITH
GUN VIOLENCE SURVIVOR IN SPEND
TIME A FEDERAL WITNESS
PROTECTION PROGRAM I AM WITH
EVERYTOWN AND MOMS DEMAND THAT
WE AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT SB IT.
THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTEEN LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DR ALY
ANDERSON CALLING WITH ENDING
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY PROJECT
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THAT THE TWO. THANK YOU. WHY NO
ONE NO. FOR HELLO INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG
REPRESENTING MORE THAN EIGHTY
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA COMMON STOCK
ACQUIRED. LINE. NINETY FIVE.
READ AN EMAIL WITH COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHT
CHEERS CALLING IN SUPPORT- LINE.
NINETY THREE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS TIFFANY TO BIRTH I'M
CALLING FOR MY SON GOING TO
BARS JUST GONE DOWN BY A POLICE
OFFICER AND AN EIGHT THE
CALLING THAT STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND. ELEVEN AS CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ISN'T AS FUNDING IS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND SOCIAL CHANGE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN. GOOD MORNING JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE GIFFORDS
LAW CENTER TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE AS WELL AS SALES FORCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND.
FOURTEEN THAT'S ME CORRECT.
FIND ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU A GOOD
MORNING I EIGHT- MY NAME IS
THAT THE SAME LAST KISS AND I
AM STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB TWO
OF BEING A MOTHER WHO WITNESSED
HER SON'S MURDER I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS ACT AS NONE OF US
SHOULD HAVE TO FACE THAT KIND
OF SUFFERING MY FAMILY THIRTEEN
TIMES. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GINA VIOLA
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
WHITE PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES IN
ABSOLUTE STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE.
WHAT ARE MY LIMITS ARE APPLIED
JUSTICE COALITION I'M FROM THE
OUTSIDE THE COUNTY- I LIVE ON
THE POP CLOSE FULLER PROFILE
COSPONSORED HOME OF WHICH HELP
SUPPORT AFFECT YOU. TO THANK
YOU. BY. ONE TWENTY FOUR. ONE
ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ARE YOU GOING TO LINE.
THIRTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
VALERIE WHAT SAID CUT THE
NUMBER YOU GO BEARING JUNIOR
MEMBER OF. EAT STOP PROBATION
AND TRONG SUPPORT. LINE. ONE
THIRTY THREE. ATTP THE EXACTLY
CARE KRAWCHECK OUTPUT FONG THE
BILL WE ARE CALLING IN. A
FAMILY KILLED IN OAK EXACTLY
AND URGENT I THOUGHT. THANK YOU.
AGAIN- JUST A MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE ONE LAST PERSON
AND KILL. WANT. TO ONE THIRTY
FOUR. HELLO I'M DARWIN FISHMAN
WITH THE RACIAL JUSTICE
COALITION OF SAN DIEGO AND
WE'RE FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TERRY
APOLOGIZE WE DO WE DO HAVE- TO
ADDITIONAL OF PEOPLE WHO QUEUED
UP JUST A MOMENT PLACE. LINE.
TWENTY SEVEN. THIS IS A
STARTLING PATRICK FROM
INDIVISIBLE STANISLAUS CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SPEECHES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN. HI
THIS IS ANGELICA CORTEZ THE
VICE PRESIDENT BUSH JUST
CONNECT YOU WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
STAND WITH THE COMMUNITY HERE
TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
PRESS EACH YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIS YEAR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUES WISH TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU AND I'M SORRY BRADFORD IF
YOU JUST AND DOES THE COMMITTEE
OR LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND THEN- GO THROUGH TO
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR I'M
DOING WELL HERE OPPOSITION.
MAGICTR CALL THE ROLL. JONES
SAWYER HERE. LACKEY BARAKAT
HAND. LI CORK HERE SANTIAGO.
THEY ARE TO HAVE HERE WICKS.
REQUIREMENTS FOR. THOSE CONSENT
CALENDAR I NUMBER FOUR S. B.
TWO FIVE EIGHT BATES SENTENCING
RECENTLY REMOVED SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SB FOUR SEVEN TWO CABALLERO-
SOCIAL INNOVATION FINANCING
PROGRAM I DON'T NUMBER EIGHT S.
B. EIGHT TO SEVEN FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE PUBLIC
SAFETY OMNIBUS BILL ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB FOUR FOUR SIX GLAZIER
FACTUAL INNOCENCE I DON'T
NUMBER ELEVEN SB EIGHT OH FOUR
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
ITS FORESTRY TRAINING CENTRE.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS REPORTING ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN SB FOUR NINE ONE
NIELSEN- CIGARETTES AND TOBACCO
PRODUCTS LICENSING ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND THREE AND ITE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN SB FOUR TWO ZERO I'M
BURKE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
INTEGRITY ENFORCEMENT ACT
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE PROPOSED SECOND. MESSAGE
CALLED. JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER A LACKEY LACKEY I
BARRICADE HAVE. LEE LI I COURT
BY CORK THANKS. SAN DIEGO I SEE
OUR THE ARTS I WICKS. THE CHECK
IS ADOPTED THANK YOU CENTER FOR
YOUR PATIENCE NOW THE UPPER
WITH. I HAVE A HAMPTON
PRESIDENT ANA HOW OF P. O. A.
M. IS ACTIVE CA MEMBER BE A
TELL AND JONATHAN FELDMAN FROM
DEEPLY SEEKS ASSOCIATION VIA
TELEPHONE. WHENEVER THEY ARE
READY TO SPEAK FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL WHERE WHERE YOU WANT TO
SPLIT IT UP. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS THAT COULD HAPPEN AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE AND I
AM PLEASED SITUATION AND AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF THE
STATE WIDE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. OF
CALIFORNIA- PORAC ESTABLISHING
THE LICENSURE PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA IS A PRIORITY FOR
POOR ACT NO ONE WANTS TO SEE
THAT OPPOSITION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT MORE THAN GOOD
OFFICERS DO. WHEN I ALSO ACT IN
A WAY THAT IS GROSSLY
INCONSISTENT WITH THE MISSION
AND GOALS OF OUR PROFESSION
GIVES ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT A BAD
NAME. ONLY HARMS OUR ABILITY TO
BUILD BACK THE COMMUNITY TRUST
ME TO CARRY OUT OUR SERVICE
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY. HAVING
SAID THAT HOWEVER. YES TWO
THAT'S CURRENTLY RIGHT IS NOW
THE RIGHT OF. WILL CREATE BIAS
AND I'M PRICE WILL YOU KNOW.
LIE FIRST. SB TWO INCLUDES
WEAPON. TO OVER BROAD GET THE
OF RISK. BUT OF PARTY. AND OPEN
FOR INTERPRETATION. SECOND SB
TO. PROVIDE THE COMMISSION WITH
THE AUTHORITY TO INVESTIGATE AN
OFFICER WHILE IGNORING THE
OFFICERS CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS. AFFORDED BY THE
PEACE OFFICERS PROCEDURAL BILL
OF RIGHTS. THIRD SB TWO
ESTABLISHES AN INHERENTLY
BIASED 9% OVERSIGHT PANEL. THAT
INCLUDES SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CORE REQUIRED I REPEAT
REQUIRED. TO HAVE A
PREDETERMINED BIAS. AGAINST THE
OFFICER. AND ONLY TO MEMBERS
WHO. HAVE PRIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXPERIENCE. WE CANNOT ALLOW OFF
TO DEMONSTRATE MISCONDUCT TO BE
MEMBERS OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEIR LIVES MUST BE WITH. ON AS
WRITTEN SB TWO WOULD OVERRIDE
PROCESS AND IGNORE THE BASIC
TEN IN THE THIRD SUPPORTED TO
ALL CITIZENS. IN CONCLUSION WE
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S OFFICE AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF BOTH HOUSES TO
IMPROVE SENATE BILL TWO. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO COMPLETING OUR
GOAL OF ESTABLISHING A FAIR AND
EFFECTIVE PEACE OFFICER LICENSE
PROGRAM. THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NOT
JONATHON FELDMAN. IT SURE
MEMBERS THE MORNING JOHNSON
SULEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO FIRST
THANK LEADERSHIP BOTH HOUSES
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRMAN
AUTHORS OFFICE AND GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THE DISCUSSION
BEGAN ON THIS MEASURE LEADING
TO THIS POINT. IT'S CLEAR FROM
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH
EVERYONE TO SEE A
DECERTIFICATION TESTAMENT OPTED
INCLUDING EACH OF CALIFORNIA'S
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
POLICE CHIEFS. THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE RAISED AN EXECUTION NOT BE
MISCONSTRUED AS ANYTHING MORE
THAN ISSUES WE'VE IDENTIFIED
WITH A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL NOT IN
A VERSION OR OPPOSITION TO
PERMANENTLY REMOVING OFFICERS.
WERE FOUND GUILTY OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT. WELL APPRECIATE
THEM TAKE AHEAD OF THE HEARING-
SEVERAL CRITICAL ISSUES
REMAINING THAT WE BELIEVE NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED INCLUDING. A
FAIR AND JUDICIOUS PROCESS FOR
INSTANCES WHERE POST ME TO SIDE
TO DECERTIFY AN OFFICER WHO HAD
BEEN EXONERATED. OR WHO HAS HAD
A COMPLAINT NOT SUSTAIN TO AN
INTERNAL AFFAIRS INVESTIGATION.
IF POST IS GOING TO CHALLENGE A
LOCAL AGENCY THE STANDARD
SHOULD BE HIGH ON THE PROCESS
SHOULD CONCLUDE WITH THE COURTS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE PRO SHOULD BE
PRESENTED ALL THE FACTS BE
ALLOWED TO MAKE AN INDEPENDENT
DETERMINATION EACH CASE. NOT
FORCED TO ADOPT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE CIVILIAN
REVIEW BOARD IN AN INSTANT. I
BELIEVE THE DEFINITION OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT OUTLINED IN
THE BILL NEEDS TO BE MORE
FOCUSED WELL WE UNDERSTAND POST
WILL DEVELOP THE FULL
DEFINITION DEREGULATION SB TWO
REQUIRES QUOTE. WITHOUT
LIMITATION. MANY BROAD AND
SUBJECTIVE CATEGORIES. AND
FINALLY THE MAKE UP OF THE
CIVILIAN REVIEW BOARD NEEDS
BALLOTING WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE INCLUDING THE
MAJORITY CIVILIAN BOARD IN
TERMS OF CREATING INTEGRITY
WITHIN THE SYSTEM. WOULD MAKE
IT CURRENTLY NOT SPEAK TO
INCLUDE THOSE WHO WOULD BE
FOUND IMPARTIAL AND CORPORATE.
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING AN AGREEMENT ON
DECERTIFICATION THIS YEAR AND
WILL REMAIN FOCUSED ON THAT
GOAL. UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE NOT
THERE YET AND THEREFORE MUCH
SPORTS ARE CONCERNED YOU CAN
ASK FOR NOTEBOOK TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE NOW MOVE TO
THE TO THE ROOM AND FORTY TWO
OH TWO. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. CNN LET'S GO TO
THE TELECONFERENCING ROOM ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO. C. NONE
WILL NOW GO TO THE TELEPHONE
LINES OR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OPERATE YOU MAY OPEN
UP THE LINES PRESS B. TO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AND AGAIN ONLY IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS. ONE
NINE ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE A.
ONE OH EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS HERE AND READ
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN WE WANT TO IDENTIFY
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY FOR
AND THE CHIEFS WE WANT TO WORK
ON A DECERTIFICATION BILL JUST
EAST BE FAIR AND BALANCED AB
SIXTY WAS NOT HURTING YOUR
COMMITTEE BUT IT WAS A BILL
THAT DEALT WITH THE SERVER. IF
IT HAD I'M SORRY IT'S JUST FOR
ORGANIZATION ASK YOU. NAME ONLY
THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY NINE.
HI THIS IS MATTHEW WITH THE
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE. ONE OH
SEVEN. MISTER KAREN MEMBERS NOT
DECIDE RULING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
FORTY TWO. GEN NUMBERS RUNNING
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION NUMBER OF
LOCAL POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SO IN CALIFORNIA-
IN OPPOSITION I THANK YOU THANK
YOU WHY NO ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY SELLS A LITTLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE.
EIGHTEEN I NEED YOUR LINE IS
WHAT ARE THE A MOM LINE.
FINALLY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
MORE CHEN MEMBERS AT LEAST R.
C. IKANA WITH THE LEAGUE HEALTH
CITIES IN OPPOSITION. LINE
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN FOR SHANE LEVINE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION CESSATION
CALIFORNIA DEPUTY SHERIFFS. THE
LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SACRAMENTO DEPUTY
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION THE
SHARES WERE GOING BENEFIT
ASSOCIATION. OF SAN BENITO
COUNTY AND THE FRATERNAL ORDER
OF POLICE CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
TO OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE FORTY NINE. FIND ONE FORTY
NINE YOU'RE LYING SAID. KRATON
HERE LUCIEN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION A
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OF
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ONE OF TRAINED CALL
BY. ONE FIFTY. HI THIS IS
DOMINIQUE WILLIAMS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY YOUNG DEMOCRATS I DO NOT
GET TO VOICE MY SUPPORT IN THE
SUPPORT LINE BUT I WE ARE
EXPECTING SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS ERICA- I'M FROM SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND RENT
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND AGAIN THE STRESS THE
SYSTEM FOR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE
THIRTY NINE. I'D BE JUST A
MOMENT. FINE ONE THIRTY NINE.
LINE FIVE MAY NINE ONE THIRTY
NINE. YES MY NAME IS ACTUALLY
AND THEN A COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
FOR POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS
IS YOUR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
WHOSE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU WE NOW BRING IT TO TOO MANY
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MR LACKEY. YES FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD LIKE TO- SAY THAT WE SURE
DO- SHARE A COMMON INTEREST.
AND TRYING TO- ESTABLISH A
DECERTIFICATION PROBLEM PROCESS
THAT- WILL REMOVE TOXIC
OFFICERS WE HAVE SEEN. THAT THE
TRUST BETRAYED OVER AND OVER
AND WE NEED A PROCESS GIVEN
THAT WILL- FAIRLY ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM. HOWEVER I DO BELIEVE
AS- MANY WE JUST HEARD FROM- IN
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSION.
THAT- IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL
THERE ARE TOO MANY OVERBROAD
DEFINITIONS- AND THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THIS BILL. THE
LESSON OBJECTIVE LET ME GIVE
YOU ONE OF THE MOST GLARING
EXAMPLES. AND THIS IS THAT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS
ACCOUNTABILITY ADVISORY BOARD.
LET ME JUST A JUST REAL QUICKLY
FIND OUT WHY I BELIEVE THERE'S
AN INEQUITY HERE. SIX OR SEVEN
OF NINE MEMBERS WILL PROBABLY
OR DEFINITELY BE BIASED AGAINST
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. NOR
THE REGULATORY AGENCY
CALIFORNIA. NO OTHER STATES DO
CERTIFICATION LAW REQUIRES SUCH
A SIMILAR COMPOSITION THE
INCLUSION OF TWO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO SHALL NOT BE FORMER
PEACE OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT. TO RUN FOR USE OF
FORCE TO CAUSE DEATH OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY TO A PEACE
OFFICER OR WHO ARE SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS. ARE PERSECUTED
BY THE WRONGFUL USE OF DEADLY
FORCE IS ESPECIALLY EGREGIOUS.
WE DON'T REQUIRE VICTIMS OF
MALPRACTICE. TO HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL REPRESENTATION ON
ANY KIND OF MEDICAL BOARD. THIS
IS THIS IS CLEARLY. UNFAIR IN
MY OPINION AND THIS ADVISORY
BOARD HAS SIGNIFICANT POWER IN
THIS PROCESS IT'S NOT JUST A
SUGGESTIVE- PERSPECTIVE THEY
HAVE BINDING INFLUENCE ON THIS
DETERMINATION AND SUCH AN
ADVISORY BOARD SHOULD HAVE
THAT. BUT IT SHOULD BE AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT OBJECTIVE AND I I'VE I
FEEL THAT. THIS IS MORE FOCUSED
ON AN ANTI LAW ENFORCEMENT
SENTIMENT. AND NON OBJECTIVE
AND THEREFORE I CAN'T SUPPORT
IT. THANK YOU MR CLARK. FIRST
I'LL MOVE THE BELL. NOT HAVING
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IS THE
SMARTEST THING YOU'VE GOT.
EVERY BOARD EVERY BOARD SHOULD
NOT HAVE A MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A. JUST POSITION TO
SUPPORT OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
SAME PROFESSION THIS IS A
FEATURE OF FEATURE THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE OUGHT TO DO
IT ON EVERY SINGLE BEFORE WE
OUGHT TO HAVE ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD.
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE CLAIMS AND
HUSSEIN HOW AWFUL THINGS CAN BE
WHEN EVERYONE TRIES TO PROTECT
THE DOCTOR. THE SAME THING HERE.
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS IN THIS. NOW I
DO SUGGEST SO IN THE COMMENTS
SECTION FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT NINE. THERE ARE
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT- ESSENTIALLY
REFINING YOUR BILL FOR EXAMPLE
CONFLICTS WITH CURRENT
TEMPERATURES CENTER PROBAR DO
YOU MEAN TO- YOU KNOW CHANGE
THE LAW IN THAT AREA OR NOT-
THURMOND WHICH YOU COULD TAKE-
I KNOW THE COMMITTEE IS WORK
WITH YOU- I'D SUGGEST THAT YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT SCALI
HEARINGS. THERE'S A PROCEDURE
WHERE AFTER THE FIRST GOLLY
HEARING- YOU CAN APPEAL THE
DETERMINATION TO SUPERIOR
COURT. THEN AFTER YOU GO
THROUGH THE POPE ARE PROCESS
YOU CAN APPEAL AGAINST THE
SUPERIOR COURT. IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE WOULD BE
DIFFERENCES HERE SO THESE ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS POINTED OUT
THE ANALYSIS AND I THINK THAT
THESE COULD BE- SIMPLY- TO FIND
BETTER- JUST THOUGHT THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT MORE YOU CAN DATE
DRESS THESE IN YOUR CLOTHES IF
YOU LIKE BUT OF COURSE I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT I CONSIDER THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND-
SOMETHING THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO DO AND PARTICULARLY THE
WAY THAT PORT IS CONSTRUCTED. I
THINK IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
FEATURE WE HAVE. THANK YOU OF.
MR LEE THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD- OBVIOUSLY I'M A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL ANY
SPORT TODAY I DID HAVE A
QUESTION THOUGH BUT WHEN THE
ASPECTS I KNOW YOU TOOK A
SERIES OF MOMENTS IS WHEN WOULD
THIS- BOARD COMMISSION BE
INITIATE WOULD BE AFTER
CONCURRENTLY OR BEFORE SAY AN
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION TO SAY
THERE'S INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED
MY HOME TOWN SATURDAY WITH THIS
OCCURRED BEFORE INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION OR THIS. OCCUR
AFTER THEIR INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION BY THE LOCAL
AGENCY WE HAVE THE FIRST BITE
AT THE APPLE THERE THE
DETERMINING FACTOR ON WHETHER
EIGHT- SERVICE DECERTIFICATION
SHOULD MOVE FOR TILL THE
BROUHAHA ABOUT GIVING THIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. OVER
REACHING AUTHORITIES JUST. FOOD
FOOD AT BEST- THE LOW AGENCY
HAS THE FIRST BITE AT IT THEN
IT GOES TO THE POLLS COMMISSION
THE POST COMMISSION THEN.
DETERMINES ITS SIX STEPS THAT
ONE HAS TO GO THROUGH BEFORE
YOU EVEN GET TO THE CITING OF A
OFFICER IS DECERTIFIED AND THEN
AFTER THAT. HE STILL HAS THE
RIGHT TO APPEAL BE- BEFORE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE I WISH
THE GENERAL PUBLIC AT THAT MANY
BITES AT THE APPLE BEFORE THEY
WERE FOUND GUILTY OF ANYTHING
SO. THIS IS A FAIR TRANSPARENT
PROCESS SO ITS FIRST STARTS
WITH A LOCAL AIDS IF I'VE
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ANSWER MY
QUESTION AND I JUST WANNA ALSO
SAY YOU KNOW IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT. WE VIEW THIS NOT AS THAT
CONCLUSION OF EFFORT TO
POTENTIALLY MORE MORE TO COME I
THINK THERE WILL BE THAT-
HOPEFULLY WHEN WE PASS IT
THROUGH OUR HOUSES THERE WILL
BE THAT AFTER WHERE PEOPLE SAY
WELL WE DID IT WE DON'T HAVE TO
REVISIT IT. AND FRANKLY YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'VE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS I THOUGHT WE
WOULD TACKLE POLICE'S FIRST
BEAT PLEASE THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS BEFORE I EVEN GOT HERE
LAST SUMMER WHEN I THINK THERE
WAS A GREAT MOMENTUM. AND GREAT
INTEREST IN THE PUBLIC AND NOW
PEOPLE ARE ASKING WHY DID WE DO
LAST YEAR SO NOW WE'RE BACK AT
IT AGAIN AND I REALLY DO HOPE
THAT WE MAKE THE STRONGER AND
MAKE SURE THAT THIS PROCESS
DOES WORK. IT'S GOT SIX STEP SO
WE HAVE SOME TIME TO SEE IF IT
REALLY WORKS OUT AND WE CAN
WORK AND WORK IT OUT AND IRON
IT OUT. BUT I DO ALSO HERE YOU
KNOW THE CONCERNS OPPOSITION
WAS IT'S TOO BROAD ISN'T WHAT
WE WANT THAT IS ALWAYS WHAT WE
ALWAYS HEAR RIGHT THE CITY
SUPPORT THE GOAL IS FOR THE
PRINCIPLE BUT NEVER BRING US
ANYTHING SUBSTANTIAL. AND IF
THE ACT OF THE BRING US
ANYTHING IT'S ALWAYS MORE THE
SAME POLICE POLICING THEMSELVES
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SMART TO
HAVE THIS BOARD AND I'M GLAD TO
SEE THAT IS PRESERVED IN THIS
BILL- THAT IT HAS PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE AND SO
CALLED. SUPPORTED THANKS AND
REFERENCE THANK YOU. BRITISH
ACTOR. THANK YOU. SO A COUPLE
OF THINGS ON THE ISSUE IT'S OF
WHETHER WE NEED THIS OR NOT- WE
OBVIOUSLY DO I THINK THERE IS
NO- NO DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
ON THAT- ONE OF THE REASONS WE
NEED THIS IS BECAUSE THE
CURRENT EMPLOYMENT LAWS THAT WE
HAVE CREATED- MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU'RE HIRING
SOMEBODY TO FIND OUT MORE ABOUT
THEIR PAST AND FIND OUT IF THEY
HAVE CHARACTER ISSUES. DIRECT
CONFLICT WITH THE
ORGANIZATIONAL VALUES THAT YOU
HAVE. AND IT YOU CAN ASK
CERTAIN QUESTIONS YOU CAN'T ASK
OTHER QUESTIONS FORMER
EMPLOYERS AREN'T ALLOWED TO
GIVE BAD INFORMATION ABOUT TO
GIVE NEGATIVE INFORMATION.
ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES-
OTHERWISE THEY CAN BE SUED. AND
THIS CREATES THIS ENVIRONMENT
WHERE- IT ONCE YOU'VE OFFLOADED
AN EMPLOYEE THAT YOU FEEL IS
GONE SOUTH. THEY'RE NOT YOUR
PROBLEM ANYMORE THEY BECOME
SOMEBODY ELSE'S. AND SO
ESPECIALLY WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE.
A MECHANISM TO IDENTIFY
SOMEBODY THAT CAN NO LONGER
UPHOLD THOSE VALUES. AND ON
THAT SUBJECT IF YOU GUYS WANT
TOLD ME JUST A LITTLE BIT- YOU
KNOW I'VE HAD THE HONOR OF
WORKING. WITH PEOPLE FROM THE
BEGINNINGS OF THEIR CAREER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ALL THE WAY TO
THE END AND THEN EVEN KNOWING
THEM PASS THAT. WHAT HAPPENS IS
THEY START OUT AND THEY'RE NOT
BAD APPLES IN THAT
CHARACTERIZATION KIND OF HURTS.
BECAUSE THEY AREN'T BAD APPLES.
BUT ALONG THE WAY DEPENDING
UPON THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY'RE WORKING IN. THEY BECOME
TAINTED AND SOMETIMES BY THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR CAREERS YOU CAN
TELL THAT THEY'RE NOT THE SAME
PERSON THAT GOT HIRED WAY BACK
WHEN. THEY'VE SEEN THINGS THAT
WE SHOULDN'T SEE. OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF. LIKE WHEN I WENT
TO WORK FOR THE COUNTY WHERE I
WENT FROM ONE ENVIRONMENT TO AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT ONE. TO HELP
REESTABLISH. THE GOOD THAT'S IN
THE WORLD. AND SO BY THE END OF
THEIR CAREERS YOU CAN TELL THAT
THEY'RE BURNED OUT. AND SOME OF
THOSE CAREERS ENDED TWENTY
YEARS AND SOME OF THOSE CAREERS
GO TO THIRTY AND SOME PEOPLE
ACTUALLY MANAGED TO GET THROUGH
THEIR ENTIRE CAREERS. AND THERE
ARE TAINTED. AND NERVE THERE
YOU CAN TELL THEY'RE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY DAMAGED. AND
THEY'VE GOT PTSD. AND YET. ONCE
THEY RETIRE A FEW YEARS LATER.
I I'VE RUN INTO PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING GREAT ONE OF THEM IS THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY IN THE AREA
OUR CITY OF INGLEWOOD. SO YOU
KNOW THAT DID TO MAKE IT SOUND
LIKE THESE GUYS GET ON BECAUSE
THEY DON'T- THE PROCESS DOESN'T
ALLOW THEM INITIALLY TO GET IN
THERE. THAT THEY'RE JUST BAD
APPLES WITH BAD INTENT FROM THE
START I THINK IT'S A BAD
CHARACTERIZATION OF WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THIS ISSUE. AND
ONE OTHER THING. A LOT OF TIMES
I'VE SEEN ALONG THE WAY. THAT
THE OFFICERS THAT YOU THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. THEY
DON'T EVEN LIKE THEMSELVES. AND
THEY USUALLY FIX THAT
THEMSELVES. AND THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT YOU DON'T READ ABOUT
THOSE IN THE PAPER YOU JUST
KNOW THEY DIED AND WERE HAVING
A FUNERAL AND IT'S USUALLY A
QUIET ONE BECAUSE THEY KILL
THEMSELVES. SO THIS ISSUE IS A
BIG ISSUE. AND HOW WE HANDLE IT
IT IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND WE HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT.
NOW I AM HEARD FROM I'VE HEARD
FROM LABOR I'VE HEARD FROM
MANAGEMENT I'VE HEARD FROM THE
PUBLIC I'VE HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE. THEY ALL AGREED THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A PROCESS. BUT WE
HAVE STAUNCH OPPOSITION TO THIS.
NOT JUST FROM OTHER OFFICERS
NOT JUST FROM THEM WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CITY'S LEAGUE
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONCERNED WITH
HOW SOME OF THE LANGUAGE CAN
CREATE. ISSUES THAT WILL WIND
UP IN COURT AND COSTING THE
TAXPAYERS MONEY. BECAUSE IT'S
NOT THEIR ORGANIZATIONS TO GET
STUDENTS TO TAXPAYERS WHO GET
SUED. AND SO THIS IS SO CLOSE.
TO BEING THAT BILL. IT JUST
NEEDS SOME MORE TWEAKING AND
THOSE TWO TWEAKS ARE. THE THAT
ONE THE ONE PART WHERE WE'RE
LIKE AXE DEMONSTRATING BIAS ON
RACE NATIONAL ORIGIN SEXUAL
THAT IS SO BROAD IT HAS TO BE
NARROWED DOWN IN ORDER TO GET.
SUPPORT FOR THAT. THE OTHER ONE
IS THE MAKEUP OF THE BOARD AND
WHILE I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES. THAT THE MAKEUP OF
THE BOARD NEEDS TO HAVE PEOPLE.
FROM WITHOUT IN ORDER YOU KNOW
FROM OUTSIDE THE ORGANIZATION.
YOU CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
BIASED. WHEN YOU GO THROUGH A
JURY SELECTION. THAT JURY
SELECTION ISN'T IT YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE IN A RAPE TRIAL THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO PUT SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BEEN GREAT ON THE TRIAL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEBODY
BECAUSE THAT BIAS. NOW BIAS
WILL TAKE THEIR OPINION ABOUT
THIS SITUATION THEY'RE DEALING
WITH. NOT NECESSARILY THE WHAT
HAS HAPPENED TO THEM IN THE
PAST WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
PEOPLE IN THE PAST IS
IMPORTANT. WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IN THE BOARD THAT WE MAKE
UP. THAT'S WHERE THE OPPOSITION
IS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO
FIX BECAUSE RIGHT NOW ALTHOUGH
YOU SAID IT WAS PRIMARILY
FORMED OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. IT'S
TWO TO NINE IN THOSE TO OUR
GOVERNOR APPOINTED. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE FOR YOU IS
ONCE THE GOVERNOR MAKES AN
APPOINTMENT. AND THEN SAY THE
GOVERNOR CHANGES DOES THE NEW
GOVERNOR COME IN AND CHANGE THE
BOARD ACCORDING THOSE
APPOINTMENTS DIZZY. HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DECOMMISSION PEOPLE
AND THEN APPOINT PEOPLE HE
WANTS WOMEN TO TERMINAL LEVEL
TERMS OF ONE. WOULD SURVIVE I'M
I'M HOPING THAT WE WOULD HONOR
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER COMMISSIONS
YOU HAVE A TERM IN WHICH YOU
SERVE. SERVICE DURING THAT TERM
IN THE END THAT GOVERNOR OR-
PERSON OR- GET THE SPEAKER THE
PROTEOME ALSO WANTED TERM
EXPIRES THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
APPOINT. THEIR OWN DESIGNATED
INDIVIDUAL TO SERVE ON THE
SPORTS BECAUSE THAT ALSO OPENS
IT UP TO OBVIOUSLY POLITICS.
WHICH A LOT OF THINGS.
EVERYTHING ALLOWED I'M POLITICS
EVERY POLITICS SENATOR CHARLES
YEAH I HEAR YOU. SO. SO ANYWAY
THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL. AND IF YOU'RE THOSE
THINGS CAN BE A TO. I WOULD BE.
TO PUT MY NAME ON IT- GET TO
ADD MY SUPPORT TO IT. EVERYBODY
WANTS THIS TO HAPPEN. WE NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE CAUSING IT NOT TO. SO THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE I ALSO WANT TO
APPROVE I TELL YOU THAT I JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR YEARS
OF ADVOCACY IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THESE ARE DIFFICULT
ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE WORKING SO HARD TO DO TO
ADDRESS THEM. IF WE CAN JUST GO
A LITTLE BIT FURTHER ON THIS WE
CAN PUT SOMETHING IN PLACE STOP
TALKING ABOUT OF A PUT
SOMETHING IN PLACE. THAT WILL
ACTUALLY WORK. AND WORK INTO
THE FUTURE AND I APPRECIATE
ALSO THAT INTHE FUTURE WHEN WE
DO HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
THAT IT CONTINUALLY GETS RE
EVALUATED. TO ENSURE ITS
EFFECTIVENESS IT'S FAIRNESS TO
ALL OF THE PEOPLE NOT JUST THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE POTENTIALLY THE
VICTIMS. BUT ALSO THE POLICE
OFFICERS INVOLVED. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR INDULGING AREA
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BRING IN
THE BILL FOR. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- CENTER I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GREAT WORK IN THE SPACE THIS IS
IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE BUT IT'S AN
OBVIOUS ONE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED THESE ARE HARD
CONVERSATIONS- YOU'VE BEEN A
TRUE CHAMPION I'M A CO AUTHOR
OF PROUD SUPPORTER I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
ALREADY I JUST LET MY SUPPORT
AND BE AN ALLY FOR YOU AND
WHATEVER AS THIS PROCESS GOES
THROUGH THANK YOU. RICHARD
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY MORE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SENATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AND LET
ME SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO IS LENT THEIR VOICE TO THIS
MEASURE WHETHER YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION. BUT I
GUESS THE ONE THING THAT
TROUBLES ME THE MOST IS THE
CONSTANT. CORES OF WE ALL WANT
TO CERTIFICATION BUT NOT THIS
BILL. AND WE HAVE WORKED FOR
YEARS ON WHAT THAT B. O. SHOULD
LOOK LIKE AND THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THIS OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND YOU CAN SAY
WHAT YOU WANT ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I SERVED ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE LIABILITIES. I
SUIT A CITY. FOR FALSE ARREST A
POLICE DEPARTMENT. SO WELL
BEFORE THERE WAS THE S. B. TWO
W. LISTS SIOUX CITY A GOOD
LOCAL ENTITY OF- COUNTY FOR THE
MISS ABUSE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS IN PLACE NOW FOR THIS BILL
DOES NOT CREATE THAT. WE KEEP
ONCE AND WE WANT TO WHAT WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE I'VE SAT
DOWN WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. SOME
OF MY BEST FRIENDS WHILE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SPENT THIRTY FIVE
YEARS WITH LAPD WE WENT OVER
THIS BILL ALL LAST YEAR ON HOW
DO WE MAKE THIS. BILL BETTER
HOW DO WE MAKE IT FAIR IF YOU
SAW THE L. A. TIMES THIS
WEEKEND IT WAS A AMAZING OP ED.
BY CHERYL DORSEY FORMER
SERGEANT LAPD TWENTY YEARS ON
THE DEPARTMENT SHEET WHOLLY
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AND SHE'S
MMHM CAN'T FIND NO MORE MORE
POLICE PER PERSON THAN SHE IS
SHE'S NOT ANTI POLICE. SHE PUT
HER LIFE ON THE LINE FOR TWENTY
YEARS TO PROTECT AND SERVE
PEOPLE AND SHE SAYS THIS IS A
FAIR AND TRANSPARENT. WAY OF
DEALING WITH. BAD OFFICERS AND
I'M GONNA DISAGREE WITH YOU
THERE ARE BAD APPLES. THERE ARE
BAD INDIVIDUALS. AND WHETHER
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS WHETHER
THEIR TEACHERS WHETHER THEIR
PRIEST THERE ARE BAD
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT TAINTED
BY THE PROCESS THEY'RE JUST BAD
INDIVIDUALS. AND WE SEE THAT
THE F. B. I.'S EVEN DID A-
REPORT A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF RECRUITS A
BAD INDIVIDUALS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FAR MORE THAN ANY
OTHER. AGENCY OR EMPLOYMENT.
GROUP IN THE STATE ARE IN THE
COUNTRY SO THE REALITY IS THAT.
AND WE'RE NOT HERE TO TARNISH
LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE I SAID
I HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
SERVED AS POLICE OFFICERS I
HAVE FRIENDS WHO ARE SERVING
NOW. MY CHILDHOOD FRIEND
MICHAEL BROCK'S HOW THE BOOK
OUT BEING BLACK AND BLUE THIRTY
FIVE YEARS LAPD. HE'LL TELL YOU
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IN THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE
DONE. BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT
GIVEN THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ALWAYS GIVEN
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT SO TO
BE AFRAID OF SEVEN INDIVIDUALS.
BEFORE YOU FEEL THAT THEY WOULD
BE ANYMORE BIAS THAN IF THIS.
COULD GO. OR BY REPORT WAS
COMPRISED OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. I
HAVE A NEIGHBOR WHEN A TOP
CRIMINAL TO. OF ATTORNEYS IN
THE COUNTY OF NOT IN THE STATE
WAS APPOINTED TO THE BENCH A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. AFTER TWO
YEARS SITTING ON THE BENCH HE
RESIGN. HE RESIGNED BECAUSE OF
THE INCESTUOUS RELATIONSHIP
THAT EXISTED BETWEEN THE DA THE
INVESTIGATING AGENCIES AND THE
JUDGES MOSTLY ALL JUDGES. ARE
FORMER DA'S AND MOST EVERYBODY
MY BEST TO GET FOR THE DA'S OR-
FORMER POLICE OFFICERS AND HE
SAYS TO GET AN INDICTMENT. ON A
POLICE OFFICER LET ALONE. A
CONVICTION IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. IT IS TWO YEARS ON
THE BENCH NOT ONE OFFICER WAS
EVER IN DIED. SO THIS PROCESS
IS NEEDED. THERE WERE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED POLICE SHOOTINGS OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS. MOST
THIRTEEN HUNDRED POLICE
SHOOTINGS THIRTEEN OFFICERS
WERE CHARGE. OF THOSE THIRTEEN
ONE WAS CONVICTED. YOU TELL ME
THAT'S NOT A BIASED STACKED. A
REVIEW OF BY SOMEONE. COME ON
WE WOULD GO TO VEGAS IN A HEART
BEAT WE HAVE THOSE KIND OFF.
THE ISSUE IS BEFORE US FOLKS
IT'S CLEAR WE'VE DONE POLICING
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS
THE SAME WAY. AND WE KEEP
GETTING THE SAME RESULTS
NOTHING. THIS IS A FAIR PROCESS
IT'S A PROCESS IT'S LONG
OVERDUE IT'S TIME HAS COME. AND
WE MUST TRUST THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO TRUST US TO COME HERE TO
SACRAMENTO AND MAKE DECISIONS
ON ALL ASPECTS OF THEIR LIFE
THE BE UNBIASED AND BE FAIR WHY
CAN'T WE GIVE THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT OF THOSE SAME
CIVILIAN PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
APPOINTED TO THIS BOARD. TO BE
UNBIASED AND FAIR FOR THE
SECTOR BIASES ASIDE WERE ASKED
TO DO THAT EVERY DAY BUT SOME
OF US CAN'T. SOME OF US COME
HERE WHAT OUR MINDS MADE UP NO
MATTER WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND
WE'RE WHETHER TO THAT ISSUE.
I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO BE OPEN TO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. I'VE
LISTENED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE ONLY SUGGESTION I HAVE
IS NOT THIS BILL MISTER
BRADFORD. THAT'S OKAY HOW DO WE
MAKE IT BETTER. NOT ALL.
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE SUCH A
SUGGESTED INPUT PORT KEELS THIS
MEASURE. I'M NOT IN THE OPTICS.
I'M NOT HERE TO PASS SOMETHING
JUST TO SAY I GOT A WIN AND IT
DOES NOT THAT FAR TOO OFTEN WE
PASS LEGISLATION. HERE IN THE
SOUTH IT DOES ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING AND WE WAVE OUR HANDS
SO WE GOT A VICTORY WE GOT IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE. YOU RUN
FOR OFFICE OR ONE OR TWO
REASONS. THE BE SOMETHING OR TO
DO SOMETHING. I'M HERE TO DO
SOMETHING. THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE AND I WILL CLOSE
WITH A QUOTE FROM DR GRANT
KING. HE SAYS. YOU MUST TAKE A
POSITION IN LIFE. THAT'S
NEITHER SAFE NO POLITICS NO
POPULAR YOU TAKE THE POSITION
BECAUSE YOU'RE CONSCIOUS TELL
YOU IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER BRADFORD- AND I KNOW HOW
HARD YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS- BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO COME
TO THE- TO THE UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE THIS
GOVERNOR THE REASON WHERE AT
THIS POINT. IS BECAUSE THE
INTERNAL MECHANISMS WHETHER
SAID INTERNAL AFFAIRS
DEPARTMENT THAT DOESN'T GIVE IT
ABOUT OFFICERS RESIDENTS
SPECTOR GENERAL BEST EITHER.
IGNORED WITH THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
GET RID OF BAD OFFICERS DISHER
TOURNEY HAS GRAND JURIES WHICH
THEY'VE GONE AND GRAND JURIES
AND THEY HAVE NOT CONVICTED BAD
OFFICERS. WE BEG. DEPARTMENTS
POLICE CHIEFS TO DO THE SAME WE
BACK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. TO
COME IN AND DO THE SAME BOTH
FEDERAL AND LOCAL. AND WE
DIDN'T GET. THE PUBLIC HAS
GOTTEN SATISFACTION. AND WHEN
IT COMES TO LIKE BACKGROUND
CHECKS JUST BASIC BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON BAD COPS BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS SMALL DEPARTMENTS
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY. AS
I'VE BEEN TOLD TO DO THAT SO
THEY CAN MOVE FROM DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT. AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE BEST PEOPLE TO POLICE
POLICE ARE POLICE AND THAT'S
NOT BEING DONE. THAT'S WHY WE
ARE FORCED. I MEAN I KNOW YOU
DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH ALL
THAT HEADACHE BUT WE WERE
FORCED. FORCED TO TAKE ACTION.
AS A LEGISLATURE BECAUSE-
ANYONE PAYING ATTENTION KNOWS
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A BREAKDOWN
OF TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THIS NATION TOO OFTEN IS
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE SUFFERED AT THE HANDS
OF POLICE VIOLENCE AND TOO
OFTEN POLICE OFFICERS SEEM TO
ESCAPE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
VIOLENCE THEY COMMIT. WHETHER
IT'S WITH A GUN WITH A
CHOKEHOLD OR WITH THE BATON.
THERE ARE ALSO OTHER MISCONDUCT
CONDUCT THAT DON'T SHOW UP IN
THE HEADLINES AS MUCH BUT THEY
ALSO HEARD A COMMUNITY. LIKE
LYING IN COURT. ADVOCATING
POLICE REPORTS. AND COVERING UP
EVIDENCE THESE ARE THINGS THAT
INFLICT PAIN AND SUFFERING ON
COMMUNITIES. WE CANNOT ALLOW
THESE THOSE THAT ARE MEANT TO
PROTECT THE SURPLUS TO CONTINUE
INSPECT INFLICT PAIN AND
SUFFERING. SO SENSIBLE
DECERTIFICATION LAW SOMETHING
THAT STANDS TO BENEFIT US ALL.
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO HELP
OUR COMMUNITIES HEAL AND REGAIN
CONFIDENCE IN THE POLICE. IT
ALSO SHOWED THAT THE OFFICE TO
DO THEIR JOB PROPERLY. AND WITH
RESPECT AND THAT THEY ARE THAT
THEY ARE VALUED MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY WILL HELP MOVE US ALONG.
CALIFORNIA QUITE FRANKLY WE'RE
LATE TO THE GAME ON
DECERTIFICATION. AND AS CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE- AND AS
CALIFORNIA'S WE SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED. BUT I WILL SAY
EMBARRASSED. FORTY SIX OTHER
STATES HAVE ALREADY PASSED US
DECERTIFICATION BILL WE BRAG
ABOUT BEING AHEAD OF THE GAME
ON POLICE REFORM. LOOK FORTY
SIX OTHER STATES HAVE DONE. AND
WE'RE HERE DEBATING IT RIGHT
NOW WE SHOULD BE TO LEADERS IN
THIS NOT TRYING TO CATCH UP. SO
I BELIEVE IT IS TIME TO DO
SOMETHING. THERE WAS ONCE A
TIME WHEN LAW FORCED MARRIAGES
ASIANS WOULD HAVE FOUGHT TOOTH
AND NAIL AGAINST ANY KIND OF
DESERTIFICATION BILL. BUT PER
PROBLEM HAS BECOME BAD ENOUGH
THAT I BELIEVE. THAT EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUP THAT I'VE
SPOKEN TO SEEM TO BELIEVE THAT
WE- WE DO IN FACT NEED SOME
KIND OF THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. THEY MAY NOT LIKE
EVERY ASPECT OF HIS BILL BUT ON
SOME LEVEL THEY KNOW THAT
APPEARED TO CERTIFICATION
PRODUCT BILL IS THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO GO IN. IT'S TIME
FOR US TO TAKE ACTION. AND WE
SAID IT AGAIN THIS TIME FOR US
TO TAKE ACTION WE HAVE SEEN IN
A VIOLENT TO DISMISS TRUST IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK CENTER BRADFORD FOR
BRING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION I WANT TO COMMEND
HIM FOR HIS PERSEVERANCE IN THE
FACE OF IMPASSIONED PLEAS. AND
CRITICISM FROM PEOPLE FROM BOTH
SIDES. LET ME REPEAT THAT ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS DEBATE. BUT
I ALSO HOPE THERE WILL BE
ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
BILL AND THAT NOT ONLY DO WE
VOTE ON IT THAT WE GET IT DONE.
THAT SB TWO- BEGINS THE
PROCESS. THAT WE GET RID OF.
OFFICERS WHO ARE GIVING
CALIFORNIA THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND JUST JUST MAKING
IT DIFFICULT FOR RESIDENTS OF
THIS OF THIS COMMUNITY- TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE TRUST IN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING AND IBOOK. THANK
MAY CALL THE ROLL. SB TWO BY
SENATE BRADFORD THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI
LACKEY NEL BARAKAT LEAKED LEE
HIGH COURT ALL RIGHT I SAN
DIEGO. SENT I ARE TOO NO THE
OUR TURN WICKS WICKS I. THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK THANK YOU
YOU NOW A ITEM TWO S. FIVE
EIGHT SIX BRADFORD CRIMINAL
FEES THANK YOU MISTER AWFULLY
THIS WON'T BE AS CONTROVERSIAL-
I'M HERE TO PRESENT PRESENT SB
FIVE EIGHT SIX WHICH ELIMINATES
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES.
FOR TOO LONG IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE HAVE MADE
PEOPLE WHO ARE INVOLVED. TO
BEAR THE COSTS CREATED BY
GOVERNMENT PROCESSES TO FEES
THAT CAN ADD UP TO BE THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS LEADING FOLKS IN
GREAT DEBT THESE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES CREATE DEBT SEEM COLD IT
MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE GET
CAUGHT UP IN IT SCAPE FROM.
THIS TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOTIONALLY IMPACT AGAIN
PEOPLE OF COLOR- AND 80% OF
THEM QUALIFY FOR ENDANGERED.
INDIGENT SERVICES FROM OUR
PUBLIC DEFENDERS WE NEED TO
GIVE PEOPLE THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES A CHANCE TO
CLEAN WITH A FOURTH CLEAN START
WITHOUT FIRST DROPPING THEM IN
DEBT THESE FEES ARE REGRESSIVE
TAXES THAT DO THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THEY WERE INTENDED FOR.
WELL WE CAN DO THIS WHILE STILL
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO SERVE TIME
ARE STILL REQUIRED TO DO THAT
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO PAY FINES
WILL STILL BE REQUIRED TO DO
THIS THIS BILL SIMPLY
ELIMINATES OR MODIFIES TWENTY
SIX ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. THIS
IS- NOT ON PRESIDENT AND LAST
YEAR WE PASSED AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THAT ELIMINATED TWENTY SIX
FROM FEES EFFECTIVE. JANUARY
ONE OF THIS YEAR. THIS YEAR'S
BY BILL. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS- IN THE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND SUBSEQUENT YEARS TO
ELIMINATE ADDITIONAL CRIMINAL
FEES THAT'S INCLUDING I MEAN
THAT FUNDING IS CONTINGENT UPON
FURTHER LEGISLATION- THE
COMMITTEE ACT ANALYSIS RAISES A
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER THIS
BILL IS NEEDED BATTERIES YES.
THUS FAR WE DO NOT HAVE A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL TO ADDRESS
WHAT FEES WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THOUGH WE ANTICIPATE SOMETHING
NOW WILL BE COMING ON HOPEFULLY
THIS IN THE NEAR FUTURE. THIS
BILL CREATES THE FOUNDATION FOR
THAT CONVERSATION AND I STAND
READY TO WORK. WITH THE BUDGET
CHAIRS AN APPROPRIATIONS YEARS
OF BOTH HOUSES TO HELP MOVE OUT
FORD AND ELIMINATING THESE
FEES. IN ADDITION EACH YEAR WE
HAVE CHIPPED MORE MORE OF THE
FEES AWAY USING- COMPLIMENT
JERRY- BUDGET AND POLICY TOOL
PROCESSES. AS IT IS THE
STRONGEST WAY TO MOVE ANYTHING
FORWARD INVOLVING A LOT OF
MONEY. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE TODAY ON TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT- FATIMA- MORE BOND- IS-
WHO'S AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S BEEN
IMPACTED BY FEES. AND THEN OUR
SECOND ONE I WOULD THIS WOULD
BE ASK YOUR WEIGHT JONES A
STAFF ATTORNEY AND CLINICAL
SUPERVISOR IS EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER. AND HE
WILL STAY ONLINE TO PROVIDE ANY
ATTACKS COSTA TO ASSISTANT SO I
WILL LET. MISS MARC BOLAN-
TESTIFY THE STOCK. BYE BYE. I
DIDN'T. YEAH HI MY NAME IS
PRETTY MEMORABLE I'M ASKING YOU
TO SUPPORT SB FIVE EIGHT SIX
I'M TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY DUE TO COURT DEBT
FROM YEARS AGO- IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I WAS PULLED OVER FOR
DRIVING WITH EXPIRED TAGS I WAS
GIVEN TWO CITATIONS ONE FOR THE
TAX IN THE OTHER CAR INSURANCE.
I WAS A FULL TIME COLLEGE
STUDENT PUTTING MYSELF THROUGH
SCHOOL BY WORKING MY FAMILY'S
GROCERY STORE I COULDN'T WRAP
MY TICKET IN PALM BEFORE LONG I
WAS HIT WITH TO CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS THE BALLOT ALREADY
HUGE BUT WHEN SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS OF CIVIL TECHNICAL
ADDED. THAT BECAME
INSURMOUNTABLE. OR MY DESK. BUT
THEY REFUSED AND BETTER WAS ON
WORK. WITH THE LOCAL SHARE
PHOTOS ENABLE TO DO BE. I LACK
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE OTHER DAY I
STILL OWE MONEY FOR THAT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OFFENSE
THERE'S PRIVATE COLLECTION
COMPANY PEOPLE COMING AFTER ME.
IT'S NOT THAT I'M TRYING TO
CATER TO PAY IT OFF I HAVE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I TOOK
AN ADDITIONAL JOB TO TRY TO GET
OUT OF DEBT BUT BECAUSE OF
THAT. I WOULD KICK OFF MEDIKAL
AND LOST MY MEDICATION AND
THERAPY. I ENDED UP DROPPING MY
CLASSES BECAUSE OF THE STRESS
AND LACK OF RESOURCES WHICH LED
TO A YEARS LONG ISSUE WITH
FINANCIAL AID. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I RECEIVED THE TRAFFIC
MISDEMEANOR WAS CHARGED
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN THE
CRIMINAL FEES INCLUDING IF YOU
TO GET ON A PAYMENT PLAN. FIFTY
WHICH WOULD BE ELIMINATED BY SB
FIVE EIGHT SIX SHOWS HOW
IRRATIONAL CRIMINAL FEES ARE. I
NEED A QUICK PAYMENT PLAN
BECAUSE I CANNOT AFFORD MY
BALANCE HOWIS IT FAIR OR
SENSIBLE TO BURDEN. ME WITH
MORE CHARGES. IN POVERTY WILL
NOT MAKE OUR CASE INFERNO WISH
I. FIVE SIX BEEN ON THE- INTO.
SIX IF HAD BEEN POLITICAL
DIFFERENTLY FROM A- I. WOULD
HAVE FACED CONFLICT. BUT ALL
THESE. LATER I WILL STILL BE IN
THAT MY WOULDN'T FEEL SO THE
MORE. BECAUSE THEY NEED MASSIVE.
EFFECT ON MY LIFE. I KNOW I'M
NOT THE ONLY ONE IN THIS IS A-
MANY OTHER PEOPLE LIKE ME. WELL
WHEN. PEOPLE OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS ARE DELAY WITH IT.
THE STEVEN CERTAIN TARGET. MORE
MOST. THE COLOR OF OUR SKIN PUT
THAT THE- RISK OF BEING SLOW.
BY THE CO. AND LOW INCOME
STATUS MAKERS. LIKE TO MAKE A
PAYMENT. EITHER PRACTICE THAT
HAVE NO PLACE IN STATE BUT
COMMITTED TO RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. IMPOSING
YEARS. THAT NO STRESS ON ME AND
PEOPLE LIKE ME IS NO WAY TO
RAISE MONEY FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
I URGE YOU ONCE AGAIN TO PASS
SB FIVE EIGHT SIX SO NO ONE
ELSE HAS TO GO THROUGH THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
MORNING MY NAME IS ASHER WE
JONES AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
IN CLINICAL SUPERVISOR AT THE
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
I'M TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE APEX. DESPITE OUR
PROGRESSIVE. REPUTATION
CALIFORNIA HAS CREATED TAX
LOOPHOLES FOR CORPORATIONS AND
THE WEALTHY. AND MOUNTAINS ITS
BUDGET THROUGH REGRESSIVE
TAXATION BY A CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES.
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS AND THEIR FAMILIES
PAY EXORBITANT FEES FOR
EVERYTHING FROM INCARCERATION
IN PRISONS AND JAILS THE LATE
FEES FOR MISSING COURT. RACIAL
PROFILING ON STREET AND
DISPARITIES IN IRAQ CHARGING IN
SENTENCES MEAN THAT THESE FEES
ARE PAID BY POOR BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE. CALIFORNIANS
HABEAS ADMINISTRATIVE FEES ON
TOP OF LENGTHY JAIL AND PRISON
SENTENCES AND NORMAN FINES AND
OVER FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF
CONVICTION. AND NUMBER TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA PASSED EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE ELIMINATING
AT TWENTY THREE COMMON CRIMINAL
AND MINISTRY TO FEES. SB FIVE
EIGHT SIX WITH A DRAFT AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SIX THE-
THESE ARE NORMALLY HARMFUL O
LOW INCOME PEOPLE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. ACCORDING VALID
BAKER FOUNDER THE AVERAGE COURT
THAT NEARLY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FAMILIES CONSISTENTLY
FACING IMPOSSIBLE CHOICES THAT
PAYING FOR BASIS. AT THE- FOR
PAYING OFF CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. BECAUSE
THE FEES ARE REGULARLY CHARGE
TO PEOPLE WHO CANNOT AFFORD
THEM COLLECTION RATES ARE
EXTREMELY LOW- CORKING COUNTIES
REGULARLY PAY AS MUCH OR MORE
TOWARDS COLLECTIONS AND THEY
BRING IN REVENUE THE FEES ARE
HIGH MEANS AND FAMILIES LOW
GAIN FOR GOVERNMENT. WE ARE
LIVING IN TIMES OF CRISIS
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE OUR
WORK TOWARDS STEP THREE JUSTICE
AND FINISH THE FEES FOR
FAMILIES ONCE AND FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW WILL
BRING IT TO THE ROOM ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. NAME AN ORGANIZATION
VETERANS FOR ABOUT HALF OF THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR ELLA
BAKER CENTER AND DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE- WITH THE- CARE
PERMISSION OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE ASKED BE READ INTO THE
RECORD SHARE. BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SELF
SUFFICIENCY. COMMUNITY WORKS
THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AT UC
BERKELEY CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. RESTORE JUSTICE SPUR
AN ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. DIANE GOLDSTEIN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU. KELLY WALTER STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KEVIN MCCARTY ALL OF THIS ARE
NOT OPEN IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING AGAIN
THE NOTHING WAS DONE- FROM THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
AT UC BERKELEY AND STRONG
SUPPORT A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS
AND- I THREE SEEN THESE AND
SIMILAR ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU
OF SORRY FOR. NO SORRY MY NAME
IS SHANTI SAY. WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN I PAID TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHILE WORKING AND I
HAVE CHILDREN AS MUCH AS YOU
CAN SAY THANK YOU YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE
LITERALLY LIVING OUR LIVES AND
MAKING IT I IN. DAYCARE AND
INCOMPATIBLE FOR US TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR FAMILY LIKE PLEASE.
THE MORNING MORNING MARGOLYES-
LEGAL SERVICES REPRESENT THE
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NOT
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROUGH OKAY YOUNG YOUNG BEGUN TO
HALF OF ALL THE VEHICLES AND
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THE EAST
BAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TROY
WILLIAMS COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER
FOR LEGAL SERVICES. CHILDREN
MEMBER OF ALL OF US IN THE ON
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK. THANK YOU WOULD NOT GO
TELECONFERENCING ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES. SHE NINE WERE NOT
GOOD TELEPHONE LINE. EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN
LOCKED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO STRESS
THAT- IF YOU DO WELL WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND AGAIN PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE. ONE
FORTY. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
NUMBERS CHRIS FORTY DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES THE
COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE SIXTY SIX. ORANGE TERM
NUMBERS FIRST RESPONSES WITH
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY BUT THE TRANSFORMATION
TO READ SEVEN ORGANIZATIONS
INTO THE RECORD YES. R. AND ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
YOU SEE I CONSUMER LAW CLINIC
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES IN
EAST PALO ALTO. OF THE COUNCIL
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE LOS ANGELES COURT
CONSERVATION CORPS AND EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU. GOING TO GO TO
LINE UP. ONE SIXTY ONE. THE
MORNING JANUARY TWENTY HOUSES
HOW CALIFORNIANS SPONSORED
SPORT THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING CHAIR NUMBER
THE ANTI DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTEEN. ONE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN THE MOOD
BONTA LINE FOURTEEN. GOOD
MORNING MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU.
LINE. THIRTY THREE. ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING AT THE TURN MEMBER
GLAMOC BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING BRENDAN GREENE FROM
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES INSIDE INTERPRETING
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
THANKS TO CALL BAY AREA BECAUSE
THIS WILL PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NINE.
THIRTY THE NON CALIFORNIA
POLICY LINKED DISCUSS FINANCIAL
JEFF PROJECT THE CAMPUS
DIFFICULT PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND THE YOUTH JUSTICE.
COALITION THANKS SO MUCH THANK
YOU. WHY ONE SEVEN SIX. SOMEONE
THIS IS THE LAST SAID HELLO AND
EVEN COLOR STATE STRONG
REPRESENTING EIGHTY ONE
POLITICAL TRIP ACROSS
CALIFORNIA STOCKPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY SO. LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOING
TO MOVE ON TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN R. LINE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KUMAR TOOK OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING SIR MEMBERS JOSHUA
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. BLIND. ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING SHERRY
COMMITTEE GREGORY SAID I WOULD
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN NINE ONE
ELEVEN. HELLO GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS AT THAT FUNDING
IS THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION WE ARE CRAP- PRODS CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX- TO SAVE THE
COMMITTEE TIME I'LL BE READING
NOT JUST A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS WHO GAVE US
PERMISSION. TO SAY THAT THERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG GROUP REBOUND
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE INITIATE JUSTICE-
REFORM UNDERGROUND GREAT. AND
RUBICON PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
LINE ONE. EIGHT ONE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WHO
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK OKAY WE WILL NOW I DON'T
SEE ANY OPPOSITION ARE THESE
ANY OPPOSITION IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO IN A ROW. CNN WILL GO TO
TELECONFERENCING IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE-
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO S.
B. FIVE EIGHT SIX BRADFORD
CRIMINAL FEES. TO CHAIR WE MAY
HAVE AT LEAST ONE PERSON WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT JUST
A MOMENT. WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO LINE TWENTY FIVE. JOSH
DUGGAR REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES WITH URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE OR THE UNDERLYING
POLICY BUT HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE FISCAL IMPACT ON COUNTIES
AND ARE GRATEFUL DOCTORS
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK OKAY. BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANYONE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
YES MISS WICKS JUST WHEN I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
BELOVED OF MYSELF AS A CO
AUTHOR AND HAVING TO MOVE THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
MEMBER IS BARKEVIOUS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU FATHER
FOR BRINGING THIS I THINK THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT STEP I
KNOW THAT FOR YEARS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE- IN BOTH
HOUSES TO ADDRESS THE
INEQUITABLE FEES THAT ARE IN
THE SYSTEM- I WANT TO REITERATE
WHAT THE ONE PERSON WHO CALLED
IN OPPOSITION THIS IS AN UNJUST
WAY TO GET VICTIMS RESTITUTION
AND THIS NEEDS TO CHANGE AND
I'M EXCITED TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
BUT I THINK WE AS A BODY NEED
TO ENSURE WE'RE PROTECTING
VICTIMS BY FUNDING THERE'S
RESTITUTION FINES I KNOW- I
THINK WE ALL AGREE ABOUT THAT
BUT I JUST WANT TO. PUT IT ON
THE RECORD THAT I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT WORK WE HAVE AHEAD OF
US THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY ONE
ELSE RESEARCHERS ARE THANK YOU.
START MY A- WITH THIS IS THERE
ARE. THAT HAVE THE- TO PAY. AND
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT- BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOOD
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED BY
THIS INCLUDING THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND. WHICH IS
RIGHT NOW SUFFERING BECAUSE
THEY DON'T COLLECT ENOUGH OF
THOSE FEES AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
AREN'T PAYING. BUT YEAH YOU
KNOW IT'S- A LIMITING FOR
EVERYBODY. SIMPLY FINANCIALLY
IMPACT THESE PROGRAMS- I THINK
WHERE WE SHOULD SPEND OUR TIME
IS ENSURING THAT PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY-
THAT LIMITATION SHOULD BE
RECOGNIZED. AND WE SHOULDN'T
WASTE OUR TIME TRYING TO
COLLECT FEES FROM PEOPLE LIKE
THAT. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY- IF I DECIDE TO
ZIP DOWN THE FREEWAY AT A
HUNDRED AND TEN MILES AN HOUR
AND I GET PULLED OVER AND THEN
I DON'T SHOW UP TO COURT.
EVERYTHING THAT EVERY EVERY
COST ALONG THE WAY. SHOULD BE
BORNE BY ME BECAUSE I'M THE ONE
WHO CREATED THAT THE NECESSITY
FOR EVEN HAVING TO. CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM- SO. I WOULD
RATHER SEE A BILL THAT. DEALS
WITH THE PART WHERE THE PEOPLE
THAT CAN'T PAY ARE NOT MADE TO
HAVE TO PAY RESTITUTION WHEN
THEY CAN'T AND IT DOESN'T
AFFECT THEM GOING ON DOWN INTO
THE FUTURE THE STARGATE YOU
KNOW TO CHASE AND- CHASING
SOMETHING THAT YOU NEED YOU
CAN'T GET YOUR SPEND MORE MONEY
CHASING IT THEN YOU CAN. RIGHT
TO JUST SIMPLY WIPE IT OUT SO
THAT EVERYBODY WHO. BY THEIR
OWN ACTIONS WINDS UP ACCESSING
A SYSTEM THAT IS MEANT TO
PROTECT US- YEAH LAW BIDING
CITIZENS. I IT TO ME IT'S DOING
MORE HARM THAN GOOD. SO I
STRUGGLE WITH THAT BECAUSE OF
THIS THANKS. THANK YOU ANYMORE
QUESTIONS CONCERNS. YOU MAY
CLOSE WAS BRADFORD. THANK YOU
IS SURE AND I WANT TO RESPOND
AND LET ME BE VERY CLEAR. THIS
BILL HAS NO IMPACT ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NO
IMPACT ON VICTIMS IN THE
RESTITUTION PROGRAM- AND IT HAS
NO NEGATIVE IMPACT. ON ANY OF
THE FUNDING OF VICTIMS PROGRAMS
THIS BILL DEALS WITH THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DESTITUTE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD WE WOULD HOPE
THAT THOSE ARE DOUBLE GOOD
PEOPLE THAT WE ALL KNOW OUT
THERE WHO COULD AFFORD TO PAY
WILL PAY. JUST LIKE THEY WILL
PAY THEIR SPEEDING TICKETS THEY
WILL PAY THEIR FEES AND FINE
JOB THAT WHOLE TO COURT BUT
RIGHT NOW THESE FEES ARE
ADDITIONAL WE'RE NOT SEEING
PEOPLE ARE. ABSOLVED FROM
PAYING THEIR FINE WE'RE SEEING
DO NOT TACK ON ADDITIONAL FEES
FOR POOR PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLED
TO PAY THE FINE. IF YOU'RE
GUILTY OF SPEEDING YOU STILL
HAVE TO PAY THAT SPEEDING
TICKET WERE SEEN IF YOU FAIL TO
APPEAR IN COURT YOU SHOULDN'T
BE TAPPED ON ADDITIONAL FEE FOR
FAILING TO SHOULD SHOW UP IN
COURT. YOUR PENALTY WILL BE YOU
WILL BE FOUND GUILTY AND HAVE
TO PAY THAT TICKET FOR FAILURE.
TO APPEAR SO THIS IS WHAT THIS
MEASURES TO COMMONSENSE MEASURE
IT'S NOT NEW TO THIS
LEGISLATURE AND WE'RE JUST
EXPANDING UPON WHAT WE ALL KNOW
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE. BALANCING OUR
GOVERNMENT- ON POOR PEOPLE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. BEEN PROPERLY MOVED AND
SECONDED THE- JUDGE RECOMMEND I
VOTE. CALL THE ROLL. ON SB
FIVE. EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HE- BARAKAT
BARAKAT HAD APPARENTLY. CORK
SANTIAGO SEE OUR TOWN SEATTLE
NOT VOTING WICKS WICKS I. IT'S
ON CALL NEEDS TO MARK TWAIN
MEMBERS SHOW UP WE APPRECIATE
NO GET OUT WHAT THANK YOU MR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER THANK YOU YOUR LEVERAGES
THANK YOU. AND DO WE HAVE TO
STE. SCARE UP SOME AUTHORS I
HAVE A- ALLEN. A NUMBER THREE
S. FOUR EIGHT THREE ALAN IF MR
BECKER'S READY HE CAN SNEAK IN
BEFORE MISTER ALAN WITH S. B.
FIVE OH FOUR SB. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. IF WE STILL DON'T SEE
ANYONE- SENATE DORADO CAN SNEAK
IN FRONT OF THOSE TWO. OR WE
CAN GO TO WICKS RIGHT NOW IF I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN ONE MINUTE.
GO FOR IT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SB THREE
FIVE SEVEN WIENER CRIMES
LOITERING FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENGAGING IN A PROSTITUTION
OFFENSE. WHILE WE WAIT FOR
SENATORS WILL GO AHEAD WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS IS
SUBSTITUTING FOR SENATOR WE. K.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY STEVEN COLLEAGUES
I'M OF A PROUD CO AUTHOR AND
I'M PRESENTING SP THREE FIFTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
SCOTT WIENER TODAY. SB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN IS A SYMBOL BILL
THAT WILL REPEAL PROVISIONS OF
THE LAW THAT CRIMINALIZED
LOITERING FOR THE INTENT TO
ENGAGE IN SEX WORK. THIS
LEGISLATION ALSO PERMITS THE
SEALING OF RECORDS FOR ANYONE
PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED OF THE
SLAUGHTERING OFFENSE. AND
PROVIDES RESENTENCING FOR
ANYONE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
FOR THESE OFFENSES. SINCE ITS
ENACTMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE THIS MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE
HAS FAILED TO PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ENFORCED
AGAINST BLACK AND BROWN
TRANSGENDER WOMEN. DUE TO THE
BROAD AND SUBJECTIVE NATURE OF
THIS OFFENSE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
PERMITTED TO PROFILE PEOPLE AND
STOP THEM FOR INHERENTLY
DISCRIMINATORY REASONS. SUCH AS
WEARING REVEALING CLOTHING
WHILE TAKING WHILE TALKING TO
PEOPLE IN AN AREA WHERE SEX
WORK HAS OCCURRED BEFORE.
CRIMINALIZING PEOPLE FOR
LOITERING WITH INTENT TO ENGAGE
IN SEX WORK SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES THE MISTRUST BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND TARGETED
COMMUNITIES. WHICH IS A TO
SAFETY BECAUSE IT RAINED. THE
LONG FOR IS NOT PROTECT
INCREASE UNSAFE. WERE SEXUAL
EXPLOITS VIA. OR MORE LIKELY TO
OCCUR. WE ALL HAVE AN INTEREST
IN PREVENTING HUMAN. BUT THE
LAWYER LAW NOT AN EFFECTIVE WAY
DO SO AND IS NOW USED TO
ADDRESS TRAFFICKING. LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD NOT BE USING
THE LOITERING STATUTE TO REST
PERSONS SELLING SEX INCLUDING
THOSE BEING TRAFFICKED AS A WAY
TO PROVIDE THEM SERVICES ARE
IDENTIFY HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS. THIS PRACTICE RE
VICTIMIZES PERSONS WHO'VE BEEN
TRAFFICKED AND LEAVES THEM WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS THAT CREATE
FURTHER BARRIERS TO SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OR
IMMIGRATION RELIEF. LEADING
TRAUMA INFORMED AN ANTI
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SEX
TRAFFICKING. ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGAL OUT REACH AND
JUSTICE AT LAST UNDERSTAND THAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS ARE
HARMED BY THE ENFORCEMENT OF
THIS LOITERING LAW WHICH IS WHY
THEY STRONGLY SUPPORT. SB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. THIS BILL DOES NOT
DECRIMINALIZE SOLICITATION OR
SOLICITING OR ENGAGING IN SEX
WORK. SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN
SIMPLY ELIMINATES AN ANTI
LITTERING OFFENCE THAT RESULTS
IN THE LEGAL HARASSMENT OF THE
L. G. B. T. Q. PLUS. BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES FOR SIMPLY
EXISTING AND LOOKING LIKE A SEX
WORKER TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN ARE. I
BELIEVE OUR WITNESSES HOPEFULLY
THEY'RE HERE ON TIME- INTO AN
EARLY- EFFORT TO MESH ABOUT AS
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FATIMA SPEAKS AND RUDY GARCIA-
TRANSLATING THAT COALITION.
STOP REMAIN OPEN UP THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIVE SEVEN WIENER. AND
FOR THOSE WITNESSES WHO ARE ON
THE LINE FOR THIS BILL YOU MAY
ON MUTE YOUR PHONE LINE AND
BEGAN SPEAKING. DO WE LOSE THE.
IN A LITTLE EARLY SO THEY MIGHT
AYE WE CAN AND MAYBE COME BACK
TO THEM IF THEY. I KEEP HEARING
A DOG. AT. HELLO. I'M HERE
THANK YOU AND YOU ARE. SOME
HYPERTENSION. WHO ARE YOU ARGUS
INSURERS- GO AHEAD. YOUMAY
TESTIFY YOU HAVE FINEST. TWO
AND A HALF MINUTES. KERN BILL
YOU MAY ALSO GET YOUR PHONE
LINE BECAUSE. HI MY NAME IS
GINGER BROWSE OUR- ZERO OO
BETWEEN THE SPEECH HELLO AND A
MEMBER THE DECURRENT CALIFORNIA
COALITION I'M JUST TRYING TO
DATE AND SUPPORT SHOULD BE
SEVENTY SHOWS THIS WORE HELLO
IN A- THE ABILITY FOR A POLICE
TO HAVE ALL OF OVER REACHING OF
FLORIDA. THAT THEY HAVE NOW. ED
IT WOULD ALLOW. FOR BECAUSE TO
BE ABLE TO SEGUE YOU REALLY
OFFICIALS IN- SHE BURKE
HARASSMENT FROM RAF- COLOR ANY
TIME TO WHATEVER THE SEE FIT
BECAUSE OF THE DURING THE BILL
WE HAVE WRITTEN IN THE BUDGET
OF THE WATER ALONG THE WAY
DISTRICTS NOW TO BE ABLE LOSE
DURING CALIFORNIA BURKE WARNED
OF A NUMBER DO THIS WITH. SHE
OLD COLD LOG JIM ERA- AFTER
REDUCED HERE WHERE SHE WOULD
WEAR ARE ARE THEM BIG SUPPORT
BACK IN JAIL THAN FOR IS NOT
WORK. FOR THE DRAMATIC
EXPERIMENTS AND WHAT HAPPENS IS
SHE DID HOMES PEOPLE IMPROPERLY
POLITICALLY EMOTIONALLY
SPIRITUALLY IN THE STORAGE IN
EVERY SINGLE WAY RIGHT
ANYTHING'S A CALCULATED ALL
ALONG THE BORDER SO FOR SOMEONE
TO SAY TO ME THAT- HAVING THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT MYSELF BY
NOT READING A RUSSIAN ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO DETERMINE WHO MAY
BE- MEANING IT WILL HARM AT AN-
END AND THAT WE ARE DOING IS WE
ARE PREVENTING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS FROM. INVESTIGATING
SOMETHING LIKE SUCH TROUBLING
IS SUCH ALL REGIONS OF THE FOR
STARTERS BEGINS YOU KNOW THESE
TWO THINGS ARE DESTRUCTIVE IN
THEMSELVES YOU KNOW SIX SEVEN
AND- WELCOME SUCH WORKS ARE NOT
ENTIRE WONDERFUL AND. ONE SO TO
SAY THAT TO ME AND TO LOOK. FOR
YOU PLAYED ALWAYS GO A LETTER
TWO SAY THAT WOULD YOU DOING
THIS AND BEFORE POLICE WAS THAT
IS RIDICULOUS THE INTERNET
THERE ARE. NO NEAR INCORRECT IN
A MANNER AT ALL WHAT HAPPENED
YOU KNOW IF HERE GOING LIKE
THERE ARE POLICE SUPPORT OR-
ALSO WORKERS. AS OUR- ALL
STRUCTURE OF THE- USER OSMAN
BASED PROSTITUTION ALL
CONSTITUTIONAL FOR ALL. THIS IS
ABOUT. RED CROSS IS. JUST BROKE
BUSINESS WRONG A SHORTAGE LOW
AND WE NEED TO GET THIS CREDIT
CARD RESPONSE AND SHE CLINTON'S.
GARCIA. ON THE LINE YEAH GO
AHEAD YEAH. YOU A. HELLO ON A
REAL MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
MY NAME IT TO REDECORATE THE-
AND I'M A SOCIAL NETWORK AND
OUTREACH COORDINATOR FOR THE
TRANSLATION ACCOMMODATION I AM
ATTENTION THE WOMAN UP COLOR
CURRENTLY LIVING IN LOS ANGELES
I HAVE EXPERIENCE A LACK OF
SUPPORT FOR BOTH MY FAMILY AND
SOCIETY. THIS LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY HAVE MAKE INCOME
PUSHED ME TO DO SEX WORK I
WANTED TO LEAVE THIS LIFESTYLE
AND CHANGE MY LIFE EVEN ALL
AFTER MOVING AWAY FROM SEX WORK
I WILL STILL BE A TARGET FOR
POLICE ARE BILLION AND BILANZ
ONE DAY I WOULD MEETING UP WITH
MY FRIEND THE POLICE ARMY AND
THEY PROFILE ME AFFECT WORKER
BECAUSE A BIT. DAY THOUGHT THEY
HAD THE RIGHT TO ARREST ME AND
THEY PUT ME IN HANDCUFFS AND
TAKE ME TO JAIL THIS WAS MY
FIRST CHARGE EVER I WAS SO
WORRIED THAT THIS WOULD IMPACT
IN MY BACKYARD AND COULDN'T
POTENTIALLY RUIN MY FUTURE ON
TOP OF THE ENTRANCE AND THE
ISSUE. THAT WE ALREADY FACE.
THE CHARGES WHEN TO OUR UP WITH
FOR OUR COMPANY. THIS IS WHY
MAKES AT THREE FIFTIES FOR
IMPORTANT WE NEED A PART. AND
THERE'S NOT COME ALIVE AND
STATE. BY REPEALING THIS LAW WE
ARE. PREVENTING MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
EXPERIENCE HARASSMENT AND
PROFILING BY THE POLICE LIKE I
DID. SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR US TO LIVE
BECAUSE HAVING A CRIMINAL
RECORD. MAKES IT THAT MUCH
HARDER I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I VOTE ON SB FIFTY THREE
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES. IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IN FAVOR. DETACHMENTS FROM
HALF OF THE- ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. GOING
BACK AS FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION CO SPONSOR AND DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE AN ELEVATOR
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE TELE.
CONFERENCING LINE. NONE OPERATE
YOU MAY OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
SB THREE FIVE SEVEN WINNER IN
SUPPORT. AT&T OPERATOR DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AT THE YES MISTER CHAIR AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO- THE BILL
BE STATING YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. WHEN I GO TO LINE. FIFTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING CANACCORD
ARM HALF OF THE CAMPING JUST A
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
EIGHTY NINE. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS ASHLEY BADNESS WITH
EXCELLENT OUTREACH PROJECT LOS
ANGELES WE ARE CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
ONE NINETEEN. HI KEVIN MENTION
WITH PLACES FOR PROGRESS IN.
UNSUPPORTED THEY CAN CREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. FIND
ONE NINETY THREE. HI MOLLY
ROBESON WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. THE MORNING
SHARING COMMITTEE GREGORY SAID
I WAS INITIATED JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
ONE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
NINETY FIVE. MARTEL GOT ON
BEHALF OF THE LAWCENTER COUNTY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND TOOK
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SURE THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE SIGNAL THEY WISH
WISH THIS. OKAY NOW GO TO
OPPOSITE. I HAVE A- DR BENNETT-
MADELINE- FOLK. WHO'S HERE IN
PERSON AND- MARIANNE JACKSON
RESTORATION RANCH WOMEN SHELTER
HERE IN PERSON BOTH IN PERSON
AND WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
WITNESS- BUT THEY'RE GONNA
SPLIT ALL BETWEEN THE FIVE
MINUTES THAT OKAY. THANK YOU
FOR HEARING ME I'M ANGIE
BENNETT- I'M A CALIFORNIA
INDIAN A TEACHER A LIBERAL A
FEMINIST A DEMOCRAT AND ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ADVOCATE THE
STRAIGHT GAY ALLIANCE ADVISER
AT MY SCHOOL. I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THE BILL DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
HARASSMENT OF ILLEGAL SEX
WORKERS BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
INSTEAD IT REPEALS A LAW
ORDERING ORDINANCE CIRCUM
NAVIGATING AND UNDERMINING THE
VALIDITY OF PENAL LAW AND
TAKING SOMETHING AWAY BUT
GETTING NOTHING BACK. WE HAVE A
REPORT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
OUR AREA BECAUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN KERN COUNTY IS
TRAINED IN VICTIM CENTERED
APPROACH TOWARDS PROSTITUTION.
I PERSONALLY WORK WITH AT LEAST
SEVEN WOMEN WHO ARE ABLE TO
CHANGE THEIR LIVES BECAUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DETAINED TO THEM
BUT THEN CALLED US INSTEAD OF
ARRESTING THEM WHY IS THE
BREACH OF TRUST BETWEEN COPS
AND SEX WORKERS NOT ADDRESSED
WHEN THIS IS THE FOUNDATION OF
THE ARGUMENT. AMENDMENTS TO
SECTION NINE ON PAGES ELEVEN
AND TWELVE OF THIS BILL
PROMISED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF EXPLOITED MINORS YET NOTHING
TO RETRAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
REGARDING PROFILING ARE HELPING
RACE BROWN OR- TGI ADULT.
PROSTITUTION ISN'T ONLY A RACE
OR GENDER ISSUE IT IS A POVERTY
ISSUE. IT'S DISPROPORTIONATE
STATISTICS REFLECT THE POOREST
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY THIS
BILL LEAVES THEM WITH NOTHING
WRITTEN INTO IT TO MAKE A
CHANGE IN CULTURE OR CLIMATE.
THE PROBLEMATIC SAFER STREETS
FOR ALL ACT CLAIMS TO END
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST AND
VIOLENCE TOWARDS SEX WORKERS
BUT THERE ARE NO SOLUTIONS IN
THE BILL THAT ACTUALLY DO THAT.
THERE ARE WAYS TO PROTECT SEX
WORKERS BUT AT THIS TIME I DO
NOT FEEL THAT THIS BILL IS YET
PLEASE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ABSTAIN OR VOTE NO ON SB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT. HI MY
NAME IS MARYANN JACKSON ON THE
FACILITY DIRECTOR OF
RESTORATION RANCH WOMAN
CHILDREN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA. I HELP SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
COMMERCIAL SEX INDUSTRY RESTORE
THEIR LIVES AND I'M SURVIVORS
MYSELF AS WELL. IT IS VERY
DANGEROUS FOR WOMEN WORKING ON
THE STREETS TO GET INTO A
STRANGER'S VEHICLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THE DRIVER OF THE VEHICLE
WILL BE TAKING THEM. AND
THERE'S LITTLE OR NO WITNESSES
AND I PERSONALLY HAVE HAD A
COLLEAGUE WHERE SHE WAS A
STREET WALKER. GOT INTO A
VEHICLE WITH THE DOOR DID NOT
OPEN SHE WAS TAKEN TO AN
UNKNOWN LOCATION. AND ROBBED
AND BEATEN AND RAPED. ACCORDING
TO. THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NEW
YORK TIMES ARTICLE IN THE U. S.
PROSECUTOR FIFTY ONE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE MURDERED. ON THE
JOB THAN LIQUOR STORE
EMPLOYEES. AT IT IS THE SECOND
DEADLIEST WORK ENVIRONMENT FOR
WOMEN AND FOR THAT REASON I
OPPOSE SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SIR. HELLO
MY NAME IS DR DIAGRAM. I AM THE
FOUNDER OF THE FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
MAGDELEINE HOPE WE FOUND THAT
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
ORGANIZATION IS CONDUCTED ST
OUR REACH TO OVER TEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMERCIAL
SEX INDUSTRY. AND I PERSONALLY
ASSISTED ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE WOMEN OUT OF SEX
TRAFFICKING. SADISTIC SHOW THE
AVERAGE AGE OF A CHILD. THAT
ENTERS IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS
ELEVEN TO FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY. OUR RESEARCH
WE HAVE COMPILED OVER LAST
TWELVE YEARS SHOWS THAT SEVEN
OUT OF TEN PROSTITUTES ARE NOT
WORKING BY CHOICE WITH THEIR
ACTUALLY. SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
AND SOMEONE IS PROFITING FROM
THEM BY FORCE FRAUD OR COERCION.
MAKING THEM A VICTIM OF SEX
TRAFFICKING. WHENEVER THERE IS
LEGALIZED PROSTITUTION THERE'S
AN INCREASE IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ACCORDING TO A
HARVARD LOS OUR SCHOOL STUDY.
WELL THERE'S RESEARCH THAT
SUGGESTS OF LEGALIZATION OF
PROSTITUTION CAN LOWER
INCIDENCE OF VIOLENCE AND
DISEASE. AFFLICTING CONSENTING
SEX WORKERS IT WOULD INCREASE
IN PREVALENCE OF SEX
TRAFFICKING IN FURTHER INHIBIT
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S EFFORTS TO
INTERVENE. THE SERVER WAS
MENTAL IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
OVER ONE WEEK PERIOD THE CARD
TO CALIFORNIA DOES NOT REFLECT
THE ISSUES AT LARGE IS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S EFFORTS OF
INDIVIDUALS WORKING THE STREETS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. DUE
TO OUR EFFORTS DAD AND FIRST
HAND KNOWLEDGE OF WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR INDUSTRY. I BELIEVE THAT
LEGALIZING LOITERING. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ENGAGING IN
PROSTITUTION WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC. I WOULD ALLOW
TRAFFICKERS THE ABILITY TO SELL
MORE MINORS AND ADULTS ON THE
STREETS OF CALIFORNIA. NOT
MAKING OUR STREETS SAFER FOR
ALL FOR THESE REASONS I'M
ASKING FOR A NO A NAY VOTE
QUARTER OF STAIN FROM PASSING.
SB THREE FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I NOW GO TO ANY
WITNESSES ON A TELECONFERENCING
LINE. WHO OKAY. AND NOW IT ARE
YOU ANOTHER. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION YEAH GREG BURKE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND YET ANYBODY ELSE
IN OPPOSITION NAME AN
ORGANIZATION WITHIN FORTY TWO.
OH TWO. MY NAME IS MARJORIE
SAILOR IN THE FOUNDER AND CEO
OF THE WELL PATH TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO SEX
WORKERS AND SEX TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS. ACROSS THE US. ALSO
THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF
ALABASTER JAR PROJECT A LOCAL-
IT'S A LOCAL LONG TERM SHELTER
PER PROGRAM FOR SURVIVORS OF
SEX WORK AND SEX TRAFFICKING IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. I'M ALSO THE
BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE SURVIVOR
LEADER NETWORK OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND ALSO I HAVE THE
CHAIR C. ON THE SURVIVOR VOICE
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND C. SACK
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN SAN DIEGO
AND I'M REPRESENTING ALL FOUR
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU NOW GO TO THE TELEPHONE
LINE SUTTER ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION AT&T OPERATOR COULD
YOU OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WILL BE IDENTIFYING YOURSELF BY
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS SB THREE FOR ONE TO GO.
TO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE.
TWO HUNDRED. I APOLOGIZE MISTER
SURE I WAS GOING TO EARLIER AND
WAS NOT CALLED BUT THIS IS
CONNIE MARTIN WITH EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE EIGHTY FIVE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON UP
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE NINETY FOUR. I WOULD
JUST TELL YOUR BALLOTS WITH
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE. ONE NINETY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING HELLO HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NAME
ORGANIZACIONES TIES THAT I EAT
LET. SORRY SMITH MARKEDET GOES
WITH THREE COLLECTIVE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE TWO
OH SIX. HELLO THIS IS JAMES
PERCH A POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
ANTI POLICE TERROR PROJECT IN
THE JUSTICE TEAMS NETWORK AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
LAWYERS GUILD SF BAY AREA ALL
ON ORDERS ALL ORGANISATIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE.
FOURTEEN THE. NINE HUNDRED
NINETY YES THIS IS. OUR GROUP
TO REACH MY APOLOGIES I WAS IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT BUT I ALSO
DID NOT GET CALLED MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WILL NOW HAVE A FINAL
CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ALL TO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
NOW BRING ABOUT TO ARE BEING
OUT. WE NOW BRING BETTER
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND- OR
ROUTE. DISMISSES HERE TO ALL
RIGHT SO M. I HAVE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL AND SAY THAT RIGHT
AWAY- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
KEEPS BEING BROUGHT UP IS BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES. AND IT
JUST BARELY AFFECTED BROCKTON
BROWN COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW
I HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING A
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITY FOR A
LONG MANY MANY MANY YEARS. AND
THE FAMILIES THAT LIVE IN BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES DON'T
WANT CRIME THEY DON'T WANT
THEIR KIDS EXPOSED TO CRIME
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR- KIDS
EXPOSED TO THE NEGATIVE
ELEMENTS THEY JUST WANT TO LIVE
THEIR LIVES JUST LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE DOES IN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY. AND YET WE'RE MAKING
EXCUSES WHY IT'S OKAY FOR THEM
TO HAVE TO TELL THEIR KID HEY
WHEN YOU WALK TO SCHOOL OR COME
HOME FROM SCHOOL. YOU NEED TO
TAKE THE SECURED AS ROUTE TO
GET HOME BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE GOING TO GO BY THE
CORNER. THAT HAS FOLKS THAT ARE
ENGAGE IN SEX WORK TRAFFIC AND
A LOT OF TIMES THOSE FOLKS ARE
ALSO HAVE DRUG PROBLEMS- AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO TO SUPPORT
THEIR DRUG HABITS. AND SO THEY
HAVE. YOU KNOW SHIFTY
CHARACTERS BETTER HANG AROUND.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE TYPE
OF BILLS THAT IS ACTUALLY
TAKING A TOOL AWAY. FROM PEOPLE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
HELP THESE FOLKS. THEY'RE
TRYING TO GIVE THEM THAT
OUTLET. AND ARE DIFFERENT TO BE
ABLE TO BE- ARE ARRESTED. AND
THEN GIVEN THE CHOICE OF DO
THEY WANT HELP AND THEY DON'T
SPEND MUCH TIME IN IN JAIL THEY
USUALLY GET CITED AND RELEASED.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS HELPS.
THOSE FOLKS THAT LIVE IN BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES I DON'T
KNOW HOW THIS HELPS FOLKS THAT
DON'T WANT TO BE HUMAN YOU KNOW
HUMAN A PART OF THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RINGS THAT ARE OUT
THERE- I DON'T THINK REMOVING
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS IS
GOING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES. I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE MORE MORE ACTIVITY
TO BE ABLE TO HELP THOSE FOLKS.
THAT ARE BEING THERE ARE BEING
HUMAN TRAFFICKED. AND THIS
ISN'T IT. THIS IS GOING EXACTLY
OPPOSITE DIRECTION THIS MAKING
COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE IT'S
EXPOSING KEEP FAMILIES THAT ARE
GOOD LAW ABIDING FAMILIES.
THIRD TO MORE OF THIS STUFF
THAT THEY DON'T WANT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO YEAH I HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT- AND YOU KNOW I'VE I
FOLKS BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HELP THEM. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR-
INPUT MISTER POWER K. THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SO I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW I'M TERRY
BILLS TO SUPPORT VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING I THINK HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
WITH EVERYTHING WE'VE GOT I
SPEAKS AT THE DAYS THAT I HAVE
A PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH AND
THEY SAY THAT THE PROBLEM JUST
CONTINUES TO EXACERBATE AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING ISN'T WORKING
AND SO. I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOWEVER HOW CRIMINALIZING THE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHICH IS WHAT THIS LAW
CURRENTLY DOES IT IS NOT A
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS WHO ARE
LOITERING IT IS THE VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT ARE
LOITERING HELPS THOSE VICTIMS
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO FIND
REAL WAYS TO HELP THOSE VICTIMS
RATHER THAN CRIMINALIZING THEM.
ENSURING THEY GET THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED. AND I WANT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO. THIS BILL
DOES NOT LEGALIZE PROSTITUTION
THE AFTER PROSTITUTION ITSELF
WILL STILL BE A CRIME. IT IS
MERELY THE PRECURSOR LOITERING
THAT IS BEING DEALT WITH IN
THIS LEGISLATION. AND SO AGAIN
IF SOMEBODY ACTUALLY.
COMMITTING THE ACTS OF
PROSTITUTION THAT MADE OUT WITH
UNDER THE RELEVANT SECTIONS-
EVEN AFTER THIS BILL. IS
ENACTED INTO LAW IF IT SO DOES
SO I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
POINTS BUT I THINK THAT THERE
ARE BETTER WAYS TO HELP VICTIMS
THAN CRIMINALIZING THAT I PUSH
IT THIS AND I. WILL MOVE THE
BILL IF IT IS NOT ALREADY BEEN
MOVED. OKAY ANY MORE COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY
CLOSE WITH WICKS FOR THE
WINNER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THE DYESS YOU KNOW. I CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THE BLACK OR BROWN
COMMUNITY BECAUSE I'M NOT BLACK
OR BROWN- AND I HAVE NOT HAD
THOSE EXPERIENCES AND MY
UPBRINGING- BUT I CAN LOOK AT
THE DATA. AND THE DATA SHOWS
THAT BLACK ADULTS ACCOUNT FOR
LOS ANGELES FIFTY SIX POINT 1%
OF THE CHARGES DESPITE MAKING
UP ONLY EIGHT POINT 9% OF THE
CITY. CITY'S POPULATION. AND
WHAT I VENTURE TO GUESS IS THAT
THE BLACK AMERICAN DOES NOT
LIKE TO BE SUBJECT TO
DISCRIMINATORY POLICING
POLICIES. AND THAT IS WHAT THIS
BILL AIMS TO DO IS TO ADDRESS
THOSE. AND BY ARRESTING THOSE
THAT ARE FOR THESE LITTERING
CHARGES THIS RE VICTIMIZE THE
REMIX RE VICTIMIZES PERSONS WHO.
ARE BEING TRAFFICKED AND LEAVES
THEM WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS SO
WHILE THEY MAY NOT SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN JAIL THEY DO HAVE
CRIMINAL RECORDS TO. DEAL WITH-
WHICH LEAD TO FURTHER BARRIERS
FOR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING AND
MANY OTHER SERVICES SO AS A
SURPRISE A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL I'M IN A SUPPORTER OF IT I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS HERE HOW TO REALLY GET
TO THIS. AND THAT'S WHY- THIRD
NUMBER OF BOTH LGBTQ
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS WELL AS
ORGANIZATIONS THE WORKDAY NIGHT
TO END HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND SO
WE STAND WITH THEM AND I STAND
WITH THEM AND I WOULD ASK YOU
ALL DO AS WELL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
UP WE HAVE A FIRST AND A SECOND.
AND SO MANAGER MAY CALL THE
ROLL CHEERS RECOMMENDED AND I
BASED ON THE COMMENTS FROM MS
POWER K. SB THREE FIVE SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY NOW
BARRICADE HIM BACK HE HAD I
BELIEVE. QARK SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I SEE OUR TOWN NO C.
R. TEN NO WICKES WICKES I. THE
MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS ONE
MORE MISTER ALAN AND- YOU CAME
IN EARLIER. MISTER BECKER
YOU'RE RIGHT AFTER MR ALLEN.
THAT'S SB FOUR EIGHT THREE
ALLEN'S SENTENCING RESENTENCING
TO REMOVES SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO
TALK DETAILS ABOUT THIS BILL
THAT- AND I ALSO JUST WANT TO
EXPAND EXPLICITLY ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT SUGGESTED ANNOUNCES-
BUT I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT ON
YOUR IDENTITY SO WOULD BE WITH
ME IN SUPPORTER CENTER JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF THE- LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALSO THE
TESTAMENTS CARE IS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
WHICH OF COURSE IS THE
COMMITTEE. THAT RECOMMENDED
THIS BILL WHICH BASICALLY JUST
RETROACTIVELY APPLIES CURRENT
LAW- THE IDEA BEING THAT WE
SHOULDN'T. I'D BE A SITUATION
WHERE SOMEONE HAS A LONGER- SET
OF SENTENCING HAS WAS JUST
BECAUSE THEY WERE CONVICTED AND-
TWENTY SIXTEEN INSTEAD OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO WITH THAT
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM OUR
WITNESSES. OKAY WE HAVE A-
SANDRA JOHNSON LEGAL SERVICES.
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN VIA
TELEPHONE IN A CASKET MINSKY-
CONSULTED COMMITTEE ON REVISION
OF THE PENAL CODE WHO'S HERE IN
PERSON SO MISTER MISTER YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING
ATTACHMENTS- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
SPEAKING AT INVITATION OF THE
AUTHOR. THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE ON
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO.
RATIONALIZED OUR PENAL CODE AND
PROMOTE RACIAL EQUITY. SB FORTY
THREE IS IMPORTANT REFORM TO
ACHIEVE BOTH OF THOSE GOALS.
THE COMMITTEE RECOGNIZED BUT IS
SIMPLY UNJUST TO HAVE PEOPLE
SERVING TIME IN JAIL AND PRISON
BASED ON ENHANCEMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN REPEALED BY THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. HE'LL BASED
SPECIFICALLY ON EVIDENCE A
SIGNIFICANT RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN THE APPLICATION. SB FORTY
THREE IT SIMPLY CORRECT THIS
INJUSTICE AS AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE IT WILL ENSURE THAT
FAIR SENTENCING HEARINGS ARE
HELD WHEN NECESSARY. IT WILL
PROMOTE JUSTICE RATIONALITY
UNIFORMITY IN SENTENCING AND
CRITICALLY PROMOTE RACIAL
JUSTICE IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF NEEDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS JOHNSON. BE A
TELEPHONE. OPERATOR AT&T YOU
HAVE MISSED JOHNSON. SURE JUST
A MOMENT PLACE. HE SAID YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN I NEEDED OKAY
OKAY GOOD MORNING EVERYONE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY MY NAME
IS SANDRA JOHNSON AND I WORK
FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AT
THEIR IN CUSTODY PROGRAM
COORDINATOR. LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
ORGANIZES COMMUNITY IMPACTED BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
WE ADVOCATE TO RELEASE AND COST
THREE PEOPLERESTORE HUMAN AND
CIVIL RIGHTS AND WE WORK TO
REUNIFY FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY.
I AM ALSO FOR ME INCARCERATED
AND HAVE DONE ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS IN AND OUT. I USED TO BE
A VICTIM OF THESE ENHANCEMENTS
BECAUSE OF MY PAST DRUG
ADDICTION. I WOULD ALWAYS GIVE
EMPIRE DRUG ENHANCEMENTS ON TOP
WITH ADDITIONAL TIME. ON TOP OF
THAT ADDITIONAL TIME WHICH WAS
SO UNFAIR X. SPECIALLY SINCE
THESE ENHANCEMENTS ALLOW
EXTREMELY LONG AND UNNECESSARY
SENTENCE THAT DID NOT. DID
NOTHING FOR MY HEALTH FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. THESE
ENHANCEMENTS DID NOT HELP ME
BEAT MY DRUG ADDICTION OR DO
ANYTHING TO HELP HOLD MY FAMILY
WHEN I WAS FORCED TO SERVE
EXTRA TIME. THE THING THAT
SHRINK PRISON DID NOT DO THAT
THE THING IS PRISON DID NOT
ONLY TRAUMATIZED ME. BUT IT
HURT MY CHILDREN AND MY
YOUNGEST SON. WHO I AM STILL
HAVING RELATIONSHIP PROBLEMS
WITH BECAUSE OF THEIR LONG
SEPARATION DUE TO UNNECESSARY
ENHANCEMENTS I WAS GIVEN. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I SPOKE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE EIGHTY TO BE
PEELED THAT ENHANCEMENT BECAUSE
OF THAT BECAUSE IT WAS APPLIED
TO TARGET AND HARM FAMILIES
RESIDENT GIVE US SUPPORT THAT
WE NEED. CALIFORNIA DID THE
RIGHT THING WHEN WE REPEAL DOES
ENHANCEMENTS AND WE AND WE CAN
DO IT RIGHT AGAIN. FOR ALL THE
FAMILY STILL NEED NEEDLESSLY
HURTING BECAUSE OF THE- SO WHAT
WAS SO WEIRD BRECHT TO ACTIVELY
ACTIVELY APPLYING THE
ELIMINATION OF THE THREE YEAR
AND ONE AND HE YEAR
ENHANCEMENTS WILL STOP OTHER
FAMILIES FROM GOING THROUGH.
THE HARDSHIP AND PAIN THAT ME
AND MY SON STILL EXPERIENCE TO
THIS DAY. YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE REST OF
THE WORK. AND TO IMPROVE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FOR ALL
TO AND TO ALLOW ALL FAMILY TO
BE BRIEF- TO BE REBUILT. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THE RIGHTS ACT. THANK
YOU. OTHER ANY ONE IN THE FORTY
TWO OH TO NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
CO SPONSOR ORGANIZATION ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
WITH YOUR PERMISSION SIR I'D
LIKE TO BE A SHORT LIST OF
OTHER SUPPORTING ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ASKED ME REPRESENTED. BY
ALL MEANS YES. MOORLACH IS A CO
SPONSOR THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE. IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. ALSO
IN SUPPORT HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNERS DIGNITY AND POWER NOW
RESTORED JUSTICE SURGE OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
BEND THE ARC JEWISH ACTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE NO WE'LL GO TO
TELECONFERENCING LINE. ANYONE
NO OPERATOR YOU MAY OPEN UP SB.
FOUR EIGHT THREE EIGHTY ONE. IN
SUPPORT. THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO BEGAN TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. GOING TO GO TO
LINE FOURTEEN. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF KAMAL CORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GREGORY FELT MISSION
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. TO TWENTY TWO. KATHY
SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN SUPPORT. LINE. ONE NINETEEN.
JIM WEINBERG- BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. LINE
TWO SEVENTEEN. MARTEL CAUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHINE WHINE. TO
THIRTEEN. GOOD MORNING ARE
MODELING YOUR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT CO
SPONSOR ALONG WITH FUTURE
JUSTICE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
LINES WOULD YOU CAN COMMUNITY
JUSTICE CAN YOU PAT SEARCH
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
BAY AREA SEARCH MORAN SEARCH
NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND
FRESNO WATERS VEHICLES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LYING. TO
TWENTY. JOSH IT TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK OKAY I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
REGISTERED SO GO TO ROOM ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN FORTY
TWO OLD. TO IN OPPOSITION C. N.
NINE NE A TELECONFERENCING. SHE
NONE WE NOW OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR OPPOSITION TO ALLEN SB FOUR
EIGHT THREE. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATE OPEN UP THE LINE. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO DO NOT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME THIS TIME
IS FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO SURE NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. WE NOW
BRING YOU BACK TO COMMITTEE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS OR
COMMENTS. C. NONE MISTER ALLEN
YOU MAY CLOSE. DEPRECIATE THEM
THE WITNESS IS A PERSON TO WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE AND RESPECT S.
RIVAL THANK YOU MMHM I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A MOTION AND- A SECOND
THIRD AND A THIRD- HAD A SURE
YOU MAKE CALDERON CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR WORKINGWITH THE COMMITTEE
AND IT JUDICIAL COUNCIL
PENSION. YEP SB FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. GENSER IRAQI. LATINO
BARAKAT BARAKAT HI LEE. WORK HI
CORRECT I SAN DIEGO. THEY ARE
TELL NO THEY ARE TURNING WHERE.
WICKS I. MEASURES ARE CALLED TO
JOIN ACCURATE YOU. MISTER
BECKER PATIENTLY WAITING YOU
HAVE TO. S. FIVE OR FOUR. SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE YOU CAN TAKE
THEM IN ANY ORDER YOU WISH I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR START
WITH FIVE OH FOUR. A GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUE TO SHOW A DESIRE TO
ENFRANCHISE JUSTICE INVOLVED
AND FOR. THANK YOU. FOR MY
COUNTRY VOTERS BUT INCOMPLETE
OR ACT INFORMATION THE
SELECTION OFFICIALS MAKING
EDUCATED GUESSES AS A TEMP TO
KEEP VOTER REGISTRATION RECORDS
UP TO DATE THIS WILL ENSURE
BETTER MANAGEMENT OF JUSTICE
INVOLVED CALIFORNIA VOTER ROLLS
FOR MORE AFTER COMPLETING A
SENTENCE THE COUNTY ELECTION
WILL OFFER. THAT WILL CONTACT
FROM INCARCERATED PERSONS THEY
KNOW THEY'RE ELIGIBLE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE. AT B. THIS
CRITICAL STEP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR VOTE AND I HAVE A
WITNESS STANDING ON- BY RYAN
RONCO FROM PLASTER COUNTY
CLERK'S OFFICE. K. A. T. T.
OPERATOR IF WE COULD PLEASE-
LISTEN TO OTHER SUPPORT READ
WITNESS AWRY AND RUNKLE. AND
GOOD MORNING- CHURCHGOING SIR
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEARING. OKAY VERY GOOD THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CARE MEMBERS
I'M RYAN ROCCO PLASTIC AND
CLERK RECORDER REGISTERED
VOTERS AND CULTURE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB FIVE OH
FOUR I LIKE TO THINK CENTER
BACKER TO STAFF FOR THEIR VERY
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL SB FIVE
BEFORE- SEEKS TO FIX A DESIGN
FLAW IN CURRENT LAW WITH
RESPECT TO CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION RIGHT NOW OVERSEE
CITIZENS MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY DEPLOYED DOMESTICALLY
AND ABROAD AND HOMEBOUND
DISABLED CITIZENS ARE OUT OF
LUCK IF THEY WISH TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF LATE VOTER
REGISTRATION AND VOTING.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT AT THE
OFFICE OF THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL OR THEIR POLLING PLACE
OR VOTE CENTER IN ORDER TO
REGISTER AND VOTE SB FIVE
BEFORE SOLVE THIS PROBLEM BY
ALLOWING MILITARY OVERSEAS
CITIZENS AND DISABLED CITIZENS
TO ACCESS THAT CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND HAVE THEIR
BALLOTS DELIVERED TO THEM
THROUGH THE COUNTY'S REMOTE
ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEM.
THAT'S PLACING THEM ON EQUAL
FOOTING WITH THEIR STATE SIDE
OR DIFFERENTLY ABLED
COUNTERPARTS SB FIVE BEFORE
ALSO IMPROVES VOTER FILE NEED
MAINTENANCE BY HAVING THAT DATA
FOR THOSE IMPRISONED- FOR THE
CONVICTION OF A FELONY FLOW
DIRECTLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS A REAL BIT
REHABILITATION INTERVOCALIC
WHICH IS OUR STATEWIDE VOTER
DATABASE. CURRENTLY REGISTERED
ACROSS THE STATE RECEIVED DATA
ON JUSTICE INVOLVED PERSONS
FROM THEIR COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT BUT ONLY ON A PERIODIC
BASIS FOUNDER STATIC AND LACK
IMPORTANT MATCHING CRITERIA.
LIKE SOCIAL SECURITY OR
DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBERS. THESE
ARE ITEMS WE USED TO DO. THE
INTO. WITH NAMES AND SIMILAR
BIRTH. THIS BILL WILL. THAT
MATCHING IN FOR. AUTOMATE THE
PROCESS AND INCREASE THE
FREQUENCY OF DATA SUBMISSION
WHICH WILL IMPROVE VOTER
REGISTRATION FILE MAINTENANCE.
THANK YOU WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. OKAY THANK
YOU WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OKAY AT&T OPERATOR WE
HAVE ANY OTHER- PEOPLE ONLINE I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING AGAIN
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE TO TWENTY
TELL. BE SURE ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN COURT.
THANK YOU FIVE ONE. LINE ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. GREGORY PUT UP
WITH INITIATE JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. Q. ONE TWO
TWENTY THREE. YEAH DEREK
CRESSMAN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE TO TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICK
GROH CAUGHT ON BEHALF OF
MICROSOFT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN TO
SPEAK. A. ALL OF THAT. STUFF
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES I DON'T
SEE ANY IN OPPOSITION. R. A.
WITNESSES IN A ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. CNN ANY WITNESSES
ON TELECONFERENCING. C. NINE F.
OPERATOR MAY OPEN UP THE LINES
INTO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AT&T OPERATOR. ON SB FIVE OH
pTO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. THIS FEATURE THERE
IS NO ONE WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO BRING A DROUGHT
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. ON SB FIVE OH FOUR
SEEN NONE YOU MAY CLOSE MR
ESPECIALLY REQUEST AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU M. I BELIEVE IT'S
BEEN PROPERLY MOVED TO SECOND
IT- CHURCH RECOMMEND I VOTE MAY
CALL THE ROLE ON SB FIVE OH
FOUR BY SENATOR BECKER THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AKKI.
BLACKIE BARAKAT BARAKAT I LEAKY
CORK HI CORRECT AT A SAN DIEGO.
C. TELL C. R. TWO I WICKS WICKS
I. SENATE DEBT MEASURE PASSES.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU MAY
GO ON TO WRITE SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
AUTHORED BY CENTER SKINNER WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WHICH CHANGE
THE LONG HELD AN UNJUST FELONY
MURDER RULE. THAT WAS OVERLY
PUNITIVE TO THOSE WHO DID NOT
KILL OR INTENT TO KILL A LOT OF
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE WHO TOOK
PLEA DEALS TO LESSER CHARGES
SUCH AS MANSLAUGHTER SUPPLIED
RESENTENCING. AND WAS A
LANDMARK PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
HOWEVER WHAT IS OCCURRED SINCE
THEN IS THAT SOME COURTS
INCORRECTLY REASON THAT ONLY
APPLIED TO MURDER AND NOT
ATTEMPTED MURDER THIS- THESE
COURTS HAVE BARRED PEOPLE FROM
APPLYING FOR RESENTENCING WHICH
LED AN ABSURD AND- UNFAIR
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR RESENTENCING IF
THE VICTIM DIED. BUT AN
ELIGIBLE IF THE VICTIM DID NOT
DIE THIS MEANS AT LEAST COUPLE
PEOPLE ARE STILL SERVING
DECADES IN PRISON EVEN THOUGH
THEY SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE. FOR
RELIEF. THIS BILL BUILDS ON
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
CLARIFYING EXISTING LAW TO
INCLUDE VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER
AND ATTEMPTED MURDER
CONVICTIONS. AS ELIGIBLE FOR
RELIEF UNDER SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR
COUNSEL BE APPOINTED IN
PETITIONS FOR RESENTENCING. AND
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR THOSE
WHOSE MURDER ATTEMPTED MURDER
OR MANSLAUGHTER CONVICTIONS HIS
FINAL TO IN TO APPEAL. THIS
WILL ASSIST HUNDREDS OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE THAT TELL
COURSE TEAM HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
BY THE TECHNICAL LANGUAGE OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. AND
THOUSANDS OF SIMILAR PEOPLE WHO
DID NOT PROPOSITIONS YET
BECAUSE OF THE COURT RULINGS
IT'S CO SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER
ASSOCIATION. AND CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
I HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLEONLINE
TESTIFYING RESPECTFULLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE. SECOND. OKAY AND NOW
WE HEAR FROM YOUR WITNESS IS AV
THE ERROR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION VIA
TELEPHONE R. A. J. KITCHEN'S
OFFICE OF STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER
VIA TELEPHONE. YOUR FIVE
MINUTES TOTAL BOTH. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN OPERATOR
OPEN UP THE LINE. THIS IS AJ
CONNECTIONS FROM- THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER- GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS- TO- AMPLIFY
SOME WHAT WOULD THAT CENTER
BACKERS SAID THE PURPOSE OF
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WAS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUNISHMENT INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
IS IN PROPORTION TO THE BLAME
WORTHINESS OF THAT INDIVIDUAL'S
OWN ACTIONS BUT SOME JUDICIAL
INTERPRETATIONS HAVE CREATED-
GAPS IN THE LAW AS SENATOR
BAKER SAID THIS IS LED TO SOME
UNFAIR IN TRULY ABSURD RESULTS-
THE SENATOR INDICATED SOME
COURTS ARE EXCLUDING FROM. SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN ANYONE
CONVICTED OF ATTEMPTED MURDER
WHICH MEANS THAT A NON SHOOTER
WHO CAN NOT BE LIABLE FOR
MURDER IF THE VICTIM IS SHOT
AND KILLED WILL FACE HARSH
PUNISHMENT IF THE SAME VICTIM
SURVIVES SO I'D LIKE TO GIVE
YOU A REAL LIFE EXAMPLE A CASE
THAT IS. IN FACT IN THE COURTS
A VERY YOUNG WOMAN WENT ALONG
WITH A WOMAN FRIEND IN A MANNER
TO PAINT GRAFFITI- WHEN PEOPLE
TRIED TO STOP HER FROM TAGGING
A BUILDING. THE MAN GOT OUT OF
THE CAR THEY THEY WERE IN AND
SHOT TWO PEOPLE. ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE DIED THE OTHER SURVIVED.
THE YOUNG WOMAN. WITH THE DOING
THE GRAFFITI DID NOT INTEND FOR
EITHER VICTIM TO BE SHOT. MUCH
LESS KILLED AND UNDER IT SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN SHE CAN
NO LONGER BE CONVICTED OF THE
MURDER OF THE ONE WHO DIED. BUT
THE- TRIAL COURT SAID TAT AS
TO THE VICTIM WHO SURVIVED SHE
WAS PROPERLY CONVICTED OF
ATTEMPTED MURDER. AND THE COURT
OF APPEAL- CONFIRM THIS- AND
THAT SHE CAN SPEND DECADES IN
PRISON AS A RESULT SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE CLARIFIES WHAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN OBVIOUS AT
DEFENDANT SHOULD NOT BE IN A
WORSE POSITION BECAUSE THE
SHOOTER'S VICTIMS SURVIVE- THE
OTHER POINT- IT IS SENATOR
TOUCHED ON MANY MINOR
PARTICIPANTS IN CRIMES. THE
WENT BAD WERE ALLOWED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO MANSLAUGHTER IN ORDER
TO AVOID BEING PROSECUTED FOR A
MURDER THEY DIDN'T COMMIT. IF
HE HAD PLED GUILTY TO MURDER.
WRITTEN CURRENT VERSION OF SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THEY'D BE
ALLOWED TO FILE A PETITION TO
GET THAT CONVICTION SET ASIDE
BUT BECAUSE THEY PLAYED TO A
LESSER CRIME. OF MANSLAUGHTER
THEY CAN'T FILE A PETITION AND
THEY'RE PUNISHED FOR THE
KILLING. EXCUSE ME AND OFTEN-
AS A SENATOR INDICATED THESE
ARE- THE LEAST CULPABLE
CULPABLE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN THE
CASE- THAT'S ANOTHER INJUSTICE
THE- SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE WILL REMEDY AND- OF. WE
URGE YOU TO PASS IT. AND IT HAS
AMY BE ERA BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND A LIFETIME
PUBLIC DEFENDER. THANK YOU FOR
WIDELY PASSING SENATORS
SCANNERS SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BUILT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE NEEDLESSLY SERVING
LENGTHY PRISON TERMS WHEN THEY
WERE NOT THE KILLER AND DID NOT
SHARE INTENT TO KILL THE
DECEASED. SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE COURTS HAS CHOSEN TO
STRICTLY INTERPRET FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN TO LEAVE THE LEAST
CULPABLE PEOPLE IN PRISON.
WHILE FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
DESCRIBED PEOPLE WHO SETTLED
THEIR CASES WHAT THEY WERE
FACING A FELONY MURDER OR
NATURAL AND PROBABLE
CONSEQUENCES PROSECUTION. IT
DID NOT SPECIFICALLY STATE BOTH
LESS CULPABLE PEOPLE WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR RESENTENCING THE
COURT'S RULINGS. MEAN THAT.
HAVE BEEN THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MEANT TO INCLUDE. THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT IT SETS OUT
MORE CLEARLY SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR WERE ASKING
FOR IT I JUST CLARIFICATION
BILL TO MAKE A FEW SMALL FIXES
TO FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THOSE WHO
WERE CONVICTED OF LESSER
INCLUDED MANSLAUGHTER CHARGES
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR RESENTENCING.
ALSO FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
NARROWED HOMICIDE LAW RELATED
TO NATURAL PROBABLE
CONSEQUENCES AND YET THE COURTS
HAVE DECIDED THOSE CHANGES IN
THE HOMICIDE LIFE DO NOT APPLY
TO THOSE ALREADY CONVICTED OF
ATTEMPTED MURDER. SO WE NEED TO
SPELL IT OUT CLEARLY THAT THESE
LAST COUPLE PEOPLE READ THE
VICTIM DID NOT DIE ARE ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR RESENTENCING JUST
LIKE THE MORE SERIOUS HOMICIDE
CASES. SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE ALSO
CLARIFIED WITH STRONGER
LANGUAGE THAT A PERSON HAS A
RIGHT TO A FULL HEARING OF
THEIR PETITION WITH COUNSEL
APPOINTED TO REPRESENT THEM IN
THOSE INITIAL HEARINGS. NO
SHORT CUTS THAT YOU KNOW AVOID
COUNCIL BEING APPOINTED. WE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE READY AND
WAITING PLEASE IT IS NOT
CONNECTIONS CASES. AND THESE
FEW SMALL CHANGES WILL LEAD TO
HUGE BENEFITS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS NOT JUST A HUNDRED
TWO PETITIONS WERE DENIED BY
THE COURTS OR THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG. BUT THE THOUSANDS WHO
DID NOT YET APPLY FOR A
POSITION BASED ON THE COURTS
ARE RUNNING ITS RULINGS AND
ALSO THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO NEED TO CLEAN UP THEIR
RECORDS TO HELP THEM
REINTEGRATE SUCCESSFULLY WITH
SOCIETY AND THEIR FAMILIES. SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL BOOST
RACIAL JUSTICE REFORMS NATURAL
PROBABLE CONSEQUENCES AND
FELONY MURDER THEORIES WERE
USED DISPROPORTIONATELY
PROSECUTE TO GROUPS OF BLACK.
LET'S NOT NEXT AND AGING YOU
AND WE'RE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY USED AGAINST
WOMEN WHO ARE OFTEN LOVED ONES
WRAPPED UP. INTO THE CRIME OF
ANOTHER PERSON. THE FUNDING
FAIRNESS OUR COULD LEGAL. WILL
BE. OUR RESULT. BECAUSE WHAT
IMPROVE EQUAL. NOT LEAVING OUT
THE LESS CULPABLE PEOPLE DUE
PROCESS AND MORE DEEPER
SERRATION- BY ALLOWING A FAIR
APPLICATION OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN TWO ARE LESS CULPABLE
PEOPLE. CURRENTLY THOSE PEOPLE%
WHO SETTLED EARLY IN THEIR CASE
AND ACCEPTED RESPONSIBILITY
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT IN THE COLD
WITHOUT THE RIGHT TO PETITION
WELL THE BOLD PEOPLE WHO WENT
TO TRIAL AND LYFT HAVE BEEN
RESENTENCED AND RELEASED. ALL
CALIFORNIANS WILL SEE A BUDGET
SAVINGS OF AROUND EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR PER
PERSON HIS RELEASED ACCORDING
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE MATH. I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
NEEDLESS BECAUSE OF THE DEATHS
IN THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
WITNESSED DEATH PENALTY BY
NEGLECT. ACCORDING TO CDC OURS
NUMBERS WE HAD TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DEATHS OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AND TWENTY SIX STAFF
MEMBER DEATHS THAT'S TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX LOST
LIVES DUE TO NEGLECT DID YOU
WRAP UP NOW CDA. YOUR CERTAINLY
CITY A IS WRITTEN IN. THAT
MURDER WILL NOT HELD AT. THAT
AS FALSE THE KILLERS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE UNDER FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN AND NOT ELIGIBLE UNDER
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. AND THE
PROSECUTORS THEY REACH THE
SETTLEMENTS FOR MANSLAUGHTER
LEICESTER'S ARE NOW TRYING TO
DECIDE THAT THE DEFENDANTS THAT
ARE LESS CULPABLE SHOULD STAY
IN JAIL. NOW OBVIOUSLY THIS
VIOLATE ALL CONTENTS OF
FAIRNESS DUE PROCESS AND EQUAL
PROTECTION THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
ROOM WHICH SHE SUBMITS KERR
VETERANS FROM BEHALF OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. SEEING NO
NO TO THE TELECONFERENCE. SHE
NONE PROPERTY MAY OPEN UP LINE
FOR SUPPORT. FOUR S. B. E. E.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO. BUT THE FIRST
LINE OF LINE. TWENTY SIX. AB DE
MARTINO ON THE APPLE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WANT. TO TWENTY
FOUR. SURE THE MORE BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE HOW
COSPONSORED A BILL. FIND TO
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING JIM
LINDBERG- BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BYE. TWO TWENTY TWO.
KATHY SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTIONS SUPPORT. LINE. FIFTY
THREE. ARNON THE HAPPEN TO SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FOURTEEN MARCO
GEORGE PUT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD BECAUSE
CONCERT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIXTY EIGHT. THE
MORNING WITH THE DRIVERS BUT I
WOULD COMMISSIONER JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY
TWO TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
APOLOGIES I WANTED TO TESTIFY
FOR SB FIVE BEFORE BUT I WAS
NOT PLEASED TO KEEP BUT I'M
INTO PORT I'M- THANK YOU. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY FROM
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. LORI HOUGH ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION AND SAN
DIEGANS AGAINST CRIME VIA
TELEPHONE. MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT NAME AGAIN- LAURIE
H. A. U. F. MAY NOT A
PRONOUNCED IT CORRECTLY HOFF.
YEAH FROM THE SAN DIEGO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
ENDED DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. AND SAN DIEGANS
AGAINST CRIME TAKESHI
REPRESENTING ALL THREE. NOT
SHOWING THAT PERSON- THAT
THAT'S AVAILABLE AT THE PRESENT
TIME KATE THERE WILL GO TO THE
ROOM AND MAYBE SHE'LL JUST
CHECKED HIMSELF. SHE'S ON. OKAY
JUST A MINUTE HERE FOR YOU HAVE
A LIFE FIFTY FOUR. JUST A
MOMENT. I FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
TO SHARE I
APOLOGIZE I'M AFRAID I'M NOT
IDENTIFYING THAT LINE- AS HE ON
NO OR ANYONE WITH THAT NAME-
PARDON ME WE MAY HAVE THAT LINE
JUST A MOMENT. OKAY HOPEFULLY
THIS IS THE WITNESS I'M GOING
TO GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY IF YOU
ARE THE WITNESS IN FACT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR RIGHT NOW PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU DON'T APPLY THAT
RIGHT AWAY. LINE. ONE EIGHTY.
ONE ONE EIGHTY ARE YOU THE-
WITNESS THAT WE WERE LOOKING
FOR. OKAY NOT A RELEASED
OUTLINED AS WELL. OKAY THEN
WE'LL GO TO LAURIE HOP I LOVE A
LEVEL GO AHEAD THIS IS LAURIE
HOPS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU CHAIR SAWYER JONES JOINS
JONES SAWYER APOLOGIZE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LAURIE HOUGH I AM A PROSECUTOR
WITH THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AND I AM
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEPHAN OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MEMBERS OF OUR SAN DIEGO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S.
ASSOCIATION AND THE SAN DIEGANS
AGAINST CRIME OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CONTINUES TO PUT FORTH
AN SUPPORT SMART REASONABLE
REFORM EFFORTS WITHOUT
SACRIFICING THE RIGHTS OF
VICTIMS. AND TO THAT END WE
REMAIN AVAILABLE READY AND
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES WHICH
YOU. SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE WILL FURTHER EXPAND THE
ELIMINATION OF CRIMINAL
LIABILITY FOR THOSE CONVICTED
OF ATTEMPTED MURDER UNDER A
NATURAL AND PROBABLE
CONSEQUENCES DOCTRINE AND
MANSLAUGHTER UNDER EITHER A
FELONY MURDER THEORY. OR UNDER
THE NATURAL AND PROBABLE
CONSEQUENCES DOCTRINES. IT IS
SIMPLY THE RESULT OF THIS BILL
WILL BE EXTENSIVE RE LITIGATION
OF ALREADY RESOLVED CASES AND
IT WILL INEVITABLY TRAMPLE ON
VICTIMS RIGHT. PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WILL BE
NOTIFIED THAT THEIR CASES ARE
NOT OVER. BUT THEY WILL BE
FORCED TO COME BACK TO COURT
FOR ADDITIONAL HEARINGS AND
THAT THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
KILLER OR THE PERSON WHO
ATTEMPTED TO KILL THEM. MAY GET
OUT OF PRISON AND THE AGREED
UPON SENTENCE OR THE SENTENCE
DETERMINED BY A JUDGE BASED ON
THE FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THAT PARTICULAR CASE. IS NO
LONGER VALID THIS FLIES IN THE
FACE OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AFFORDED TO ALL VICTIMS
BUT ESPECIALLY TO VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIME. IT WILL ALSO BE
PROBLEMATIC TO SAY THE LEAST TO
DETERMINE WHO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
RELEASE. YOU SEE MANY ATTEMPTED
MURDERS FOR EXAMPLE ARE DONE BY
CHANGE OF PLEA. AND THERE'S NO
WAY TO TELL ON A CHANGE OF PLEA
FORM WHETHER AS A MATTER OF LAW
THE ATTEMPTED MURDER WAS
COMMITTEDUNDER AND AIDING AND
ABETTING TERRY. OR UNNATURAL
PROBABLE CONSEQUENCES. THIS
WILL REQUIRE FURTHER
LITIGATION. IN ORDER FOR THE
PEOPLE TO TRACK DOWN AND
SUBPOENA VICTIMS AND WITNESSES
SOMETIMES YEARS LATER. IN ORDER
TO PROVE WHAT THE DEFENDANT
PLED TO IN THE FIRST PLACE FOR
MANSLAUGHTER CONVICTIONS KEEP
IN MIND THAT THESE ARE LESSER.
CRIMES OF MURDER THAT DO NOT
REQUIRE MALICE. IN OTHER WORDS
WHEN A JURY CONVICTS SOMEONE OF
MANSLAUGHTER OR A DEFENDANT
PLEADS GUILTY TO MANSLAUGHTER
WE ARE ALREADY. ACKNOWLEDGING
THEIR REDUCED PARTICIPATION IN
A KILLING OR MALICE IS NEGATED
AND THE DEFENDANT IS SENTENCED
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR
REDUCED LEVEL OF INVOLVEMENT.
AGAIN IN A MANSLAUGHTER CHANGE
OF PLEA FORM THERE IS OFTEN NO
WAY TO TELL IF THE UNDERLYING
THEORY WAS A NATURAL AND
PROBABLE CONSEQUENCES FELONY
MURDER OR EATING AND ABETTING
JERRY. FINALLY THE SENTENCING.
FOR VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AND
ATTEMPTED MURDER. ARE ALREADY
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED.
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER IT THAT
LESSER FORM OF MURDER WHERE
THERE IS NO MALICE. HAS A
SENTENCING TRY OUT OF THREE SIX
OR ELEVEN YEARS AND ATTEMPTED
MURDER HAS A SENTENCING TRIAL
OUT OF FIVE SEVEN OR NINE
YEARS. BOTH ARE DETERMINANT
NONLIFE TERMS. SO ANY RELIEF
PROVIDED TWO ATTEMPTED MURDERS
AND MANSLAUGHTER UNDER S. B.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WILL RESULT IN
THEIR IMMEDIATE RELEASE. BACK
INTO THE SAME COMMUNITIES WITH
THEIR VICTIMS AND WITHOUT ANY
MANDATORY SUPERVISION PERIOD.
THIS DOES NOT SERVE WHAT SHOULD
BE ALL OF OUR STATED GOALS OF
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND
PROTECTING VICTIMS OF CRIME. WE
ARE MORE THAN CONCERNED THAT
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS BILL FALLS SQUARELY ON
VICTIMS IN THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WILL HAVE TO PROVE.
AFTER THE FACT IT WHAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN PLAYED TO OR
PRESENT TO A JURY. WE WILL BE
RE TRAUMATIZING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND A ROUTING
VICTIMS TRUST AND CONFIDENCE IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WE
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO ROOM ARE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF-
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE. C. NONE
WILL GO TO THE- TELECONFERENCE
FROM ERNIE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. C. NONE OPERATOR
YOU MAY OPEN UP LINES FOR SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE DO HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE
OF SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK
JUST A MOMENT. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE TWO THIRTY TILL. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION AS DRAFTED.
YOU. FIND TO TWENTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING JIM KERR BURKE
PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGANS
AGAINST CRIME IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOW GONNA GO TO LINE. TWO
TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS DAN OWENS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN
CHU WHOSE SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU- WE NOW BRING
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE
CENTER BECKER. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CHEERS
RECOMMENDING AND I WE PROBABLY
MOVED CALDERON. SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE AYE SENATOR BAKER THE
MOTION IS G. PASSED TO BE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER CANCER IRAQI NO LACKING
NO BARRICADE CAN BARRICADE HAD
A LEAK. QUIRK CORK I SANTIAGO.
CIERTA NO THE R. TO KNOW WHICH
WICKS I. MEASURES ARE CALLED
THE ONE MORE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BACK. WE NOW WILL GO WITH
SENATOR ROGER. SB. THREE THREE
FOUR. BE GIVEN A YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MA'AM- S. B. THREE FOUR WILL
PRIVATE FOR PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES TO DO ONE
AND HERE TO ALL APPROPRIATE
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH SAFETY
FIRE AND JAIL STANDARDS TO
MAINTAIN COMPREHENSIVE
INSURANCE COVERAGE INCLUDING
GENERAL LIABILITY AUTOMOBILE
WORKERS COMP AN UMBRELLA
LIABILITY. THREE REQUIRED
DETENTION FACILITIES TO SUBMIT
ANNUAL COMPLIANCE REPORTS TO
BOTH INSURANCE PROVIDER- AND
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE. AND FOURTH IS TO
REQUIRE INSURANCE COMPANIES
PROVIDING COVERAGE TO DETENTION
FACILITIES. BE AN ADMITTED
INSURER RECOGNIZED BY THE
STATE. THERE ARE NOW SEVERAL
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT AND
DETENTION FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING SIX MAJOR
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES. THE
FOR PROFIT DETENTION FACILITIES
HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF POOR
CONDITIONS AND ABUSIVE
TREATMENT IN VARIOUS FORMS
INCLUDING CASES OF PHYSICAL
ABUSE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL TORTURE. THERE
ARE NUMEROUS REPORTS DETAILING
ABUSE OF TREATMENT INCLUDING A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN US DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY REPORT
FINDING THAT THE ADELANTO
DETENTION FACILITY FAILED TO
MEET MANY OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
OWN STANDARDS. AND THE
OPERATORS DID NOT ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS DESPITE REPEATED
WARNINGS. IN FACT THERE ARE
REPORTS DURING THE CALL BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC INCLUDED
ACCOUNTS OF NOT HAVING ACCESS
TO SANITATION AND PP RESOURCES.
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
APPLY EQUALLY TO FOR PROFIT
FACILITIES ENGAGE IN CIVIL
DETENTION AND CRIMINAL
DETENTION BECAUSE WE EXPECT ALL
FACILITIES OPERATING IN THE
STATE TO ADHERE TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AND GUIDELINES- WITH
ME THE- IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. I HAVE
MICHAEL MARTINEZ LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND ALSO SAYS A TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT ABIGAIL- BUT AS THE
SUMMER LEGISLATIVE FELLOW FOR
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU- FROM THE BOTTOM UP
MISTER MARTINEZ- MISS ALVAREZ
WHOEVER WANTS BEGIN FIRST YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES TOTAL. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL MARTINEZ
HERE ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. COMMISSIONER LOT IS
VERY PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SENATE
BILL THREE THREE FOUR AND WE
THANK SENATOR ALSO FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
MEASURE. AS THE AUTHOR JUST
MENTIONS IS WELL DOCUMENTED BY
FEDERAL AND STATE AUTHORITIES
NEWS REPORTS AND EVEN
CALIFORNIA'S. STATE AUDITOR
THAT THESE FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES HAVE VIOLATED AND
CONTINUE TO DISREGARD EXISTING
HEALTH SAFETY JAIL LABOR AND
CARE STANDARDS. FOR DETAINEES
IN THEIR CUSTODY STANDARDS ARE
CURRENTLY FOLLOWED BY
CALIFORNIA'S OWN STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLICLY MANAGE PRISONS
LOCAL JAILS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES TODAY. THIS BILL
OFFERS A CRITICAL PIECE TO THE
NEEDED OVERSIGHT OF THE FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES BY
EXPRESSLY MANDATING. THESE
FACILITIES MEET THE STRINGENT
STANDARDS AS WELL AS MAINTAIN
BASIC INSURANCE COVERAGES FOR
LIABILITY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION OBTAINED BY THE
ADMITTED MARKET. WE BELIEVE
THAT MANDATING BE CERTAIN
INSURANCE COVERAGES ON THESE
PERSONS AND FACILITIES IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE TEN PERSON PER
PERSON SEND WORKING PERSONNEL.
AS WELL AS REQUIRING THESE
PRISONS AND FACILITIES TO SEND
PERIODIC REPORTS ON THEM
COMPLYING WITH THE STANDARDS TO
BOTH THEIR INSURANCE COMPANY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. WILL CREATE A
STRONGER FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
FOR THESEPRESENTS AND
FACILITIES TO ADHERE TO THESE
PROP PUBLIC SAFETY STANDARDS.
WE BELIEVE IN SENATE BILL THREE
THREE FOUR IS A REASONABLE WAY
TO FURTHER REGULATE FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES IN OUR STATE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY ENSURE THAT
BASIC HEALTH SAFETY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ARE AFFORDED TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS DETAINED
IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ABIGAIL
ALBANY LEGISLATIVE FELL OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER A PRODUCT OF BOXER AND
SB THREE THREE FOUR. SB THREE
THREE FOUR WILL ENSURE THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND HUMAN RIGHTS
ABOMINABLE IMMIGRANT DETAINEES
BUT CAN A CONDITION LIKE THE
FACILITIES AND AT MINIMUM
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS ARE
REGULARLY VIOLATED. THE BLATANT
FAILURE A FOR PROFIT PRISON
CORPORATION GEO GROUP
CORRECTIONS CORPORATION OF
AMERICA STOP HOLD EVEN BASIC
STANDARDS OF CARE IS WELL
DOCUMENTED. NUMEROUS REPORTS
YOU TELL DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS
AND DELIBERATE VIOLATIONS OF
DETAINEES TO PROFIT PREDICTIONS
AS MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR.
THESE CONDITIONS ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED OVER THE PAST YEAR
BY THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
OR IMMIGRANT BLOCKED ACCESS SO
ANTI THEIR MEDICAL SUPPLIES IN
PP. THE NUMBER OF DEATHS IN
IMMIGRATION DETENTION CENTER
CONTINUE TO RISE. ACCORDING TO
I WAS VERY OWN CULVERT NINETEEN
TRACKER AT THE JULY EIGHTH ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR
PEOPLE HAVE TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COKE AT NINETEEN AND CALIFORNIA
SEVEN IMMIGRATION DETENTION
CENTER. IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE
FOR PROFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND COMPLY
WITH STRICT REGULATIONS. AND
CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS
RELATED HEALTH WELFARE AND
SAFETY. SB THREE THREE FOUR
PROVIDE POWERFUL FINANCIAL.
MOTIVATION FOR PROFIT. HI
PRISONS AND FACILITIES TO HEAR
TO STATE AND FEDERAL STANDARD
WELL. INSURING THAT THE
FACILITY MAINTAIN. INSURANCE
MOST IMPORTANTLY AS THREE THREE
ONE THAT THE HEALTH. AND HUMAN
RIGHTS REPORTED FONG TALK.
THREE THREE YEAH STEVENS THEY
WERE YOUR I. THANK. THANK YOU.
NOT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
INSIDE. FORTY THREE FORTY TWO
OH THREE AT IN FAVOR. SHE NONE
DID CUT TELECONFERENCING LINE.
SHE NONE NOW TO THE OPERATOR TO
OPEN THE LINES FOR SUPPORT. FOR
SB THREE THREE FOR TORONTO. YOU
MAY OPEN UP THE LINES EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT A
MIXTURE MEMBERS TRYING CHILDREN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO PRIVATE PRISONS
IN STRONG EXPORT. GROWTH WAS
BUILT THANK YOU THANK YOU. FINE.
TWO TWENTY TWO. KATHY SURE FOR
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE.
TWO TWENTY THREE. YES ERIC
HARRIS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FIND. TWO THIRTY
FIVE. MONITOR COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
FOURTEEN. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY THREE. YEAH
CORRECT ARE NOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CAMPUSES GO PUBLIC DEFENDER
IN SUPPORT. NINETY TWO OH FIVE.
SWEDEN NINETEEN THAT COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CHIRLA CO SPONSOR. BY. TWO
THIRTY SEVEN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JOSH YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
SUSAN CHU WHO SIGNALED THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU ARE
LOOKING. FOR PROPOSITIONS FOR
PROGRAM. WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
LISTED PROPOSITION SO WE'LL GO
TO HER ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
EITHER ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION SCENE NINE
TELECONFERENCING ERRORS ANY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE- AT&T
OPERATOR MAY OPEN UP LINES FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TO DERIVE THOSE-
THREE THREE FOUR. FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE DOING ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS. C. NOT NEW
MAKE CLOTHES CENTER DIRAJA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE AND I VOTE THANK YOU
TO MEMBERS YES TEACHERS
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. AND S. B. THREE
THREE FOUR BY CENTER DIRECTOR
AT THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER CONSERVE OUR LACKEY.
LACKEY NOW OF OUR KEY HAND
THERAPY CAN I BELIEVE. COURT HI.
COURT I GAGGLE. C. ARTS CENTER
THEY ARE KNOW WHERE WICKS I. IS
ON CALL ME TO MARCO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS THANK YOU- I
NOW HAVE A QUARTER. TWO TWELVE-
DO YOU WANT. TRY WHAT SOMEONE
SHOWS UP IN THE NEXT MINUTE
OTHERWISE WE'LL RECESS TODAY
FOR LUNCH AND COME BACK WHILE
WE'RE WAITING COULD WE GO
THROUGH- YES GO TO ROADS. I
THANK THE PEOPLE OF MISS.
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA. TO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HANNAH HI WICKS WICKS
I. NUMBER ONE SB TWO BY SENATOR
BRADFORD POWER CAN BARRICADE
CAN I. FOR ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX THIS MEASURE
WITH ON CALL LACKEY LACKEY NO
LEE. CORK CORK I SANTIAGO THAT
MEASURE REMAINS ON CALL IT
NEEDS ONE. I ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB FOUR EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR
ALAN. LEE SANTIAGO THAT MEASURE
REMAINS ON CALL. ADAM NUMBER
FIVE IS ON CONSENT. I ITEM
NUMBER SIX S. B. SEVEN FIVE OH
FOUR BY SENATOR BAKER LEE LEE I.
I AND NUMBER SIX SB SEVEN SEVEN
YOU THINK. THAT'S NOT MEASURE
IT OR TO CANCEL I HAVE NEVER
SIX ON SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE AYE
SENATOR BAKER THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL LEET. LEE AYE SANTIAGO
THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES. I
DON'T NUMBER SEVEN AS BEFORE
SEVENTY WITHOUT CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
WITHOUT CONSENT. I REMEMBER
NINE SB THREE T. FOUR BY
SENATOR TERM DRAWS AT THIS
MEASURE OF A PHONE CALL LEE.
LEE I SAGAR TELL. I'M SORRY
EXCUSE ME IF I. NUMBER OF THAT
MEASURE NABBOUT ITEM TEN AS
BEFORE FOR SIX I THANK CONSENT
ITEM ELEVEN WITHOUT CONSENT AND
WE ALSO TOOK UP ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN SB THREE FIVE SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL LEE. LEE HI CORK CORK
HI THAT MEASURE NOT PASSIVE.
YOU WANT TO GO BACK- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAVES HERE. I REMEMBER
TO AT SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR BRADFORD LEE LEE I
SANTIAGO THAT MEASURE NOW
PASSES. HI TWO ONE. I DON'T
NUMBER THREE SB. FOUR EIGHTY
THREE. I SENATOR ALLEN LEE LEE
HI THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES. AT
A NUMBER FOR WITHOUT CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. FOR THE FIRST
SEMESTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER OKAY
THE BELIEVE FOR THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE ALL CAUGHT UP-
THIS IS A TEMP TO GET CENTER
PORTANTINO HERE HOPEFULLY IN
THE NEXT MINUTE. FOR HIS- THE-
FIRST CREW LAW BILL. SEVEN ONE
FIVE. WITH WITH NO WITH NO
PROPER AND NO SUPPORT FOR
CHICAGO LET'S DIRECTORS OF THE-
IS. ALMOST THAT'S INCORRECT
THERE IS OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
FIFTY AND WE SUBMITTED OUR
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE SEVEN
FIFTEEN. BY OKAY CENTER
PORTANTINO YES OKAY. WELL WE
MAY NOT HEAR IT TO LAUGHTER.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE HAVE
CITED HERE THAT. WE USUALLY
BREAK FOR LUNCH AT NOON AND
WE'RE- WE'RE GETTING
DANGEROUSLY CLOSE TO THAT AND-
AND THEN COME BACK AT ONE SO.
I'M GOING TO MAKE THE EXECUTIVE
ADULT DECISION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BREAK FOR LUNCH NOW AND GET
BACK AT ONE. WELL IN THAT CASE
IS- BEEN A PLEASURE TO BE WITH
YOU AGAIN. ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
BE WITH YOU. YES IT IS. AND
WHAT. WE ARE GOING TO RECESS
UNTIL ONE PM WHEN WE RECONVENE.
AT FINISH OFF THE REMAINING
FIVE ITEMS THAT WE HAVE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY. YEAH YOU CAN YEAR LATER
DELAYS ARE MESSED UP ON YOU IF
YOU DON'T WALK.
WE'RE BACK IN
SESSION ASSEMBLY. PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE- WAITING FOR MEMBERS
AND AUTHORS TO SHOW. IS NOW ONE
O'CLOCK. AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SENATOR HERTZBERG. REDOUND UP
TO WHAT'S LEFT ON THE COMMITTEE
AGENDA IS CENTER HERTZBERG
SENATOR MCGUIRE. SENATOR MEN
CENTER PORTANTINO AND SENATOR
NUMBER AND WE WILL BE. FINISHED
WITH THE. **** AGENDA FOR TODAY.
YEAH THE. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU. OF THE REST OF
THE MEMBERS ARE ON THE WAY BUT
WE ARE RESPECT FOR YOUR TIME.
WE CAN BEGIN. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH. WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. WE SEE VARIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS DISCUSSION
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE
ON MARCH TWENTY FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE UNANIMOUS
DECISION. HELD THAT THE COMMON
PRACTICE OF CONDITIONING
FREEDOM SOLELY ON WHETHER THE
ARRESTEE CAN'T AFFORD BAIL. IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL PERIOD OF CASE
ALL OF THE DISCUSSIONS IN ALL
OF THE DEBATES ABOUT WHETHER
ONE THING SHOULD BE ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER. IS OVER THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT MADE
THAT DETERMINATION AND THAT IS
THE LAW OF OUR LAND AND THE
COURTS MUST CONSIDER. THE
ABILITY OF THE ARRESTEES TO PAY
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE SO THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAVE
ENGAGED IN OVER THE YEARS. THE
VARIOUS ITERATIONS INITIALLY IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN COPPING
THE FEDERAL SYSTEM TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WOULD NOW TURN THE
GENERAL BONTA AND MYSELF IN
THOSE COUPLE OF YEARS OF
DISCUSSIONS. ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
DIFFERENT. THE. THE COURT HELD
BASICALLY IF YOU READ THE CASE
ALMOST VERBATIM WHAT. THEY WHAT
WE TALKED ABOUT OVER THE YEARS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS- WE TALKED
ABOUT THE DISADVANTAGED. TO
CARS RATED IN TERMS OF THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR FAMILIES THE
COURT TALKS ABOUT THE- FORCING
THE STATE TO BEAR COSTS THAT
WERE EXTRAORDINARY WHEN THERE
WAS NO NEED TO BEAR THOSE COSTS
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T FLIGHT
RISK. OR PUBLIC SAFETY RISK YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE UNFAIR IMPACT
ON BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
AND PEOPLE WITHOUT MEANS. COURT
INDICATED THAT THE PURPOSE OF
BAIL IS NOT TO PUNISH IT IS
THREE PURPOSES THREE PURPOSES
WHICH INFORM THE CONSTITUTIONAL
BASIS. FIRST TO ENSURE THE
PEOPLE APPEAR IN THE SIMPLEST
TERMS THE PEOPLE APPEAR IN
COURT THE OLD RULE. YOU HEARD
ME SAY WHEN MY DAD WAS AN OLD
JAILHOUSE LAWYER BECAUSE JEWS
COULDN'T GET LAWYER GETTING
JOBS L. A. COUNTY. IN IN- THE
FORTIES. HE WORKED IN IN BETTER
PRESENTED FOLKS FROM JAIL AND
SOMEBODY WOULD COME IN AND GIVE
A HUNDRED DOLLARS TO THE
BAILIFF AND THEY MADE SURE TO
THE CLERK OF THE COURT. THEY
MADE SURE THEY GOT THE HARD
DOLLARS BACK- THE SECOND WAS TO
PROTECT VICTIMS OF THE THIRD IS
TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. THE
COURT FOUND THAT THE- SYSTEM IS
CURRENTLY CONSTITUTED IN
CALIFORNIA. IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
NO WHAT HAPPENED ALONG THE WAY
THE FORM IF YOU WILL IS JUST
ONCE WHEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA NIGHT NOW ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONSAI CARRIED
LEGISLATION. WHICH BECAME S. B.
TEN. ARE WE HELD UP IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO BE
INFORMED THIS IMPORTANT I THINK
CONTEXTUALLY BECAUSE IT. EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO COORDINATE WITH THE
COURTS. THE ARGUMENTS THAT ARE
MADE BY THE SIDES OR ITS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL OR WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE WE TRIED IN
EVERY INSTANCE TO HARMONIZE
OURSELVES AND SOMETIMES TO A-
AN OX PLAIN THAT THE MINUTE.
WITH THE COURTS. INTO OCTOBER
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. A
COMMITTEE APPOINTED BY THE
CHIEF JUSTICE WROTE THIS REPORT
PRE TRIAL DETENTION REFORM
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE CHIEF
JUSTICE. WE HELD UP OUR BILL WE
BASICALLY INFORMED SP TEN
AROUND THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE COURTS. WHY DO WE DO THAT
WE FELT IF THE CHIEF JUSTICE IN
THE JUDGES FROM ALL DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FELT THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS
CONSTITUTIONAL WE'RE PROBABLY A
PRETTY SOLID GROUND. WHAT THEY
DIDN'T QUITE AMAZING TO ME
WHICH I REALLY WAS QUITE
SURPRISED BY. IS THEY CAME UP
WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL THEORY
THAT SAYS. NO BAIL YOU COULD
HAVE AN APPROPRIATE PRE TRIAL
DETENTION SYSTEM THE TO HAS
BASICALLY ELIMINATES BAIL AS
LONG AS YOU HAD A SYSTEMIC
PROCESS IN PLACE THAT'S A
SYSTEMIC PROCESS WAS THE FORM
THE FOUNDATION OF S. B. TEN HAD
TO DO WITH THESE ASSESSMENT
TOOLS THESE ALGORITHMS FORTY
SEVEN COUNTIES CURRENTLY
CONTINUE TO USE THEM BUT THIS
IDEA WAS THESE ALGORITHMS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEBODY. WOULD
APPEAR WHETHER THEY WERE FOR
THE REST OF THOSE ALGORITHMS
PROVED TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. FOR COMMUNITIES TO
OVER POLICED AND OFTEN WERE
CRITICIZED IN THE LATER YEARS
NOT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
WHERE THEY WERE SUPPORTED BUT
WERE ULTIMATELY CRITICIZES
TOOLS OF PREJUDICE AND- DIDN'T
REALLY GET TO THE ISSUE OF
JUSTICE. AND SO WHEN THIS
MEASURE WAS PASSED AND SB
TELLING THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT.
IN BOTH HOUSES THE BAIL
INDUSTRY SPENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO REFERENDA THE
MEASURE. BUT THE REFERENDUM
WASN'T BASED UPON THE ARGUMENTS
THAT WERE APPEARED THIS
COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY.
THOSE ARGUMENTS WARNED ABOUT.
AT THE ISSUE OF THE BILL AGENTS
BEING REAL COPS IN GOING OUT
AND SAVING MONEY BECAUSE THEY
WERE CHASING DOWN BUT WHAT'S
THE DOG THE BOUNTY HUNTER CAME
AND TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IT WAS CHASING FOLKS
DOWN. IN SAVING FOLKS MONEY NO
THEY HAD TO PUT THE HEAD OF THE
N. DOUBLE ACP. THE TALKED ABOUT
THE UNFAIRNESS OF THESE RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS. THAT THE
ELIMINATION OF BAIL. WAS BIAS.
THAT THESE WERE. BLACK BOXES
HOT IS WHAT SHE SAID IN THE
COMMERCIAL JUST WATCH IT AGAIN
THIS MORNING. IT'S A WITH THE
VOTERS VOTED ON. SB TEN WHICH
WAS PROP TWENTY FIVE AT THE END
OF THE BALLOT. THEY VOTED ON
THE NOT WHETHER OR NOT THEY
BALK THE CURRENT BILL SYSTEM
WAS FAIR OR NOT DID IT PRODUCE
THE OUTCOME BEST THE RESULTS
ARE NOT. THEY VOTED ON THE
SYSTEM OF ALGORITHMS TO REPLACE
BAIL. FAIR CALL WHAT HAVE WE
DONE IN THIS BILL. WE'VE TAKEN
THE FOUNDATION OF HUMPHRIES
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. WE
HAVE YOU HAD BEFORE YOU
SENATOR- SOMEWHERE BONTA THE IN
HIS BODY AT THE EXACT SAME BILL
EXCEPT FOR TWO CHANGES WE ADDED
ALL THE LANGUAGE OF HUMPHRIES
INTO THE VERSION YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU NOW BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO INCORPORATE THAT
THINKING STATUTORILY INTO THE
BILL. AND WE HAD SOME OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT WILL TALK ABOUT
IN A MINUTE THAT THAT- SOME
OTHER GROUPS WANTED US TO
INCLUDE. SO YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
NOW THE BLUEPRINT. OF HOW DO
YOU TAKE THE SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION. IN MAY NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR IN BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF
EDUCATION UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT SAYS SEPARATE BUT EQUAL
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT DIDN'T
TELL FOLKS HOW TO GET TO
SEPARATE BUT EQUAL TO JUST SAID
IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL SET FORTH
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLE.
THAT WAS CRITICAL TO WHO WE ARE
AS A PEOPLE. THIS COURT DID THE
SAME THING WHAT ARE WE DOING
HERE. WE ARE SETTING FORTH A
BLUEPRINT. IN MOST INSTANCES
NOT INCOMPLETE WOULDN'T TOUCH
EVERYTHING THEY DID BUT THE
CORE ISSUE OF THE ABILITY TO
PAY. AND WE SET FORTH A
BLUEPRINT NOW HOW DO WE MAKE
THAT BLUEPRINT. WE DIDN'T WANT
TO GET OUT THERE AND DO
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE COMING UP
WITH A BUNCH OF CRAZY IDEAS. WE
DID THE SAME THING WE DID
BEFORE WE COPY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. NOW WHO'S THE REGIONAL
COUNCIL YOUR COUNCIL HEADED BY
THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S REPORT IT IS THE
BODY THAT. ACTUALLY IS YOU
MINISTRY TO BODY FOR THE COURT
SYSTEM FOR THE THIRD BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT. WE TOOK THE IDEA
THAT THEY USE ZERO BAIL. DURING
THE- PANDEMIC. AND WE JUST USE
THEIR SAME STANDARDS THE ONLY
THING WITH A DIFFERENT. AFTER
DISCUSSING THIS WITH A FEW
FOLKS WE CHANGE SOME OF THE
EXCLUSIONS THAT THEY HAD IN THE
VERY DOT LAW THAT WE CREATED
BECAUSE WE GET. DIDN'T WANT TO
GET OUT THERE ON A LIMB WE
DIDN'T WANT TO GET OUT THERE
AND BE STUPID. AND TELL
EVERYBODY BEAT US UP AND SAY
HERTZBERG YOUR INVENTION THAT
THIS WORLD IT DOESN'T WORK WE
WANT TO SHOW SOMETHING THAT
WORKED. WE ADDED A FEW
PROVISIONS WE SAID. AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OPPOSITION
TALKS ABOUT THESE THINGS WHICH
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN OUT SO. IT
A WEATHER UPDATE WE SAID THE
VIOLATION OF A HATE CRIME IS
EXCLUDED. WE SAID HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS EXCLUDED ELDER
ABUSE CHILD ABUSE ASSAULTS.
WITH THE FORCE SHOULD LIKELY
BECAUSE OF BODILY INJURY AND
ALSO THE DA'S TALKED ABOUT
ANOTHER ISSUE THEY COMPLAINED
ABOUT THAT WE HAD OUT IN THE
EARLY VERSION. WHICH WAS- KAREN
WITH IT WAS- THAT WAS ANOTHER
ISSUE I THINK- WITNESS
INTIMIDATION THAT WAS IT WAS
ALREADY OUT SO WE DEALT WITH
THAT SECONDLY SOME OTHER FOLKS
TALKED ABOUT AND WE THOUGHT IT
WAS APPROPRIATE. TO MODIFY WHAT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL DID. WAS
THIS WHOLE IDEA THE REVOLVING
DOOR. WHAT HAPPENS IN THE CASE
WHERE SOMEBODY HAS A SMALL
PETTY CRIME. THEY GET ARRESTED
THEY GET RELEASED AND A WEEK
LATER THEY DO IT AGAIN. DO YOU
JUST LET HIM GO. SO WE PUT IN A
PROVISION IN THE MODIFICATIONS
THAT'S THE SECOND THING WE DO
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
BONTA HAD BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT SAID- NO REVOLVING DOOR IF
YOU HAVE A FIRST TIME OUT
YOU'RE YOU'RE OUT THERE AND YOU
YOU GET RELEASED A SECOND TIME
YOU GOTTA GO TO THE PROCESS THE
PROCESS IS COURT LOOKS AT YOUR
ABILITY TO PAY IS A LEAST
RESTRICTIVE FACTOR AND THE
FACTORS THAT WERE SET FORTH. IN
THE COURT- SO LOOK YOU KNOW.
WE'RE TRYING. THE OTHER
ARGUMENT THAT WAS MADE I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
ASSEMBLY VERSUS DUKE MAGING
CASE THAT SET STANDARDS AS TO
WHAT THE RULES SHOULD BE
BETWEEN WHEN SOMETHING IS
REFERENDUM AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO DISCUSS
IT AGAIN YOU CAN'T DO THE EXACT
SAME THING WE'RE NOT DOING THE
EXACT SAME THING THE LAST BILL
ELIMINATED BAIL AND SET UP A
STANDARD OF ALGORITHMS TO DO
THE STANDARD THIS. ALLOWS FOR
BAIL IT CREATES A STATE WIDE
STANDARD WHY DO WE HAVE
STATEWIDE STANDARDS BECAUSE IF
YOU GET BUSTED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THINK IT'S IN THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY FOR A CRIME YOU
GET BUSTED IN SAN DIEGO IT'S
FIVE TIMES BIGGER IN SAN DIEGO
FOR THE SAME CRIME THAT
SHOULDN'T BE THE CASE THOSE
STANDARDS SHOULD BE SET BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ACROSS THE
STATE IN FACT. WHAT YOU'LL FIND
IN THE OPPOSITION LETTER WHICH
IS OPPOSITE OF WHAT YOU FOUND
IN THIS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE WAS A BILL MYSTERIES
ARGUING WELL LOCAL JURISDICTION
LOCAL HAVE CONTROL ASSEMBLY-
COOPER HAD A BILL OF STATEWIDE-
MEASURE THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BUY THESE WROTE. WHAT I FOUND
IN THIS FIVE SIX YEAR ENDEAVOR
IS THAT AND I SEE THIS WE'LL
SEE THIS IN OUR LIVES WE SEE
THIS IN OUR BILLS BEFORE THIS
THIS LEGISLATURE IS WHEN
SOMEBODY WANTS TO OPPOSE
SOMETHING THEY'LL THROW
ANYTHING ON THE WALL AND SEE
WHAT STICKS WITH THE COPS WE'RE
SAVING MONEY WE'RE THIS WE'RE
THAT IT'S UNFAIR IT'S THIS IT'S
WHATEVER THE REALITY IS THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS UNBELIEVABLY
UNFAIR TO FOLKS IT DOESN'T WORK
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM WE
CAN GO THROUGH KENTUCKY WE GO
THROUGH THE JERSEY. WE GO TO
NEW YORK WE CAN GO TO A NUMBER
OF OTHER STATES OTHERS COUNTIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN THESE ALTERNATIVES. TO
THE WORKED REASONABLY WELL.
WHAT WE LOOK TO. THE PEOPLE CAN
OTHER WHEN THERE ARE. AND DO
THEY- NEED THEY SHOW UP IN
COURT BECAUSE THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO AND THEY DO. YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TEAR SOMEONE'S LIFE APART
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RUIN THEIR
LIVES YOU CAN ACHIEVE THE
UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE AND
OBJECTIVES THAT YOU NEED TO
ACHIEVE. IN THIS IS JUST AND
FAIR SOCIETY WITHOUT
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM WHICH IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE. YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THE INDUSTRY DOESN'T
LIKE IT I SUSPECT THE
BLOCKBUSTER PEOPLE WERE VERY
HAPPY. WE WENT TO CD'S INSTEAD
OF DVDS WHATEVER WAS. WHATEVER
THOSE THESE VHS IS I SUSPECT
THAT THAT. ALL KINDS OF
INDUSTRIES DIDN'T LIKE IT
WELCOME TO THE CLUB. THE
INDUSTRY WAS CREATED. OUT OF A
COMPLETELY DEAD OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WHAT AREA
HERTZBERG TRYING CASES THERE
WERE NO BIG BAIL INDUSTRY
DIDN'T HAPPEN. I HAVE COLDS
HERE FROM ONE OF THE CEOS OF
THE COMPANY. IS WE HAVE WRITTEN
A CHECK IN SEVENTEEN YEARS WHY.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BECAUSE THEY GO OUT AND THE
ARREST THE PERSON. IT'S
HORRIBLE. SO COUPLE OF THE
PARTS YOU WANT TO MAKE IT ALL
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
PEOPLE. HAVEN'T HEARD OVER THE
WITNESSES. THE OTHER P. IS.
ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY THAT I'VE
LEARNED THROUGH THIS PROCESS IS
ENGAGING THESE LEGAL FICTIONS
WORDEN SURE A COMPANY WHERE THE
HELL THAT IS WE'RE REGULATED BY
PROPOSITION ONE OH THREE WE'RE
REGULATED BY THIS DO YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S THE CASE RIGHT NOW
PENDING IN OAKLAND. WITH THESE
FOLKS ARE SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
A RIGHT TO CHARGE 10% I LOVE TO
DO THAT THE BASE IS GOING TO
TRUST CASE I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
GET THEY'RE GONNA GET BLOWN UP
ON THE CASE. SECONDLY I DON'T
OF THE KITCHEN FROM USERS A
CASES WHERE THE BREEZE. THEY
THINK THAT THEY'RE NOT LIABLE
TO CONSUMER PROTECTION
STANDARDS. THIS BECOME A
PREDATORY LENDING BUSINESS.
THEY DON'T OVER THESE RULES
DON'T APPLY TO US AND SO WHAT
DO WE SAY IN THIS BILL THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT'S GOT
UNDER THEIR SKIN AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY. BUT OUR JOB IS
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC IN A WAY.
THAT MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE SAFE
THE PEOPLE GET TO COURT. AND
THAT LIVES ARE TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN. WE SAY IF YOU PAY. YOUR
FEE. IT'S NOT. A FORFEITURE. IF
A DAY AFTER. IF THE DAY AFTER
YOU. ARE RESTED AND YOU PAID
FIVE THOUSAND BECAUSE THE
SUPREME COURT TALKS ABOUT WHAT
THEY SAID IN A PRE TRIAL
DETENTION REFORM. AND TALK
ABOUT THE CASE. WE'RE FIVE
TIMES HIGHER THAN THE PLACE SO
SPACE FIVE JEEZ GUESS WHAT
YOU'LL GET IT BACK. WHAT WE SAY
HERE JUST LIKE A MORTGAGE OR
CREDIT CARD. YOU PAID
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE AND YOU PAY
THE VALUE OF THAT MONEY FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME. ARE THEY GOING
TO STILL MAKE MONEY OF COURSE
THEY ARE THEY GONNA MAKE LESS
MONEY YOU'RE RIGHT THEY'RE
GONNA LIKE THIS MONEY IS A
COULD BE FAIRNESS IN THE
PROCESS WORK. THE LAW THAT WE
HAVE JUST PROVINCIALLY THAT WE
HAVE CREATED IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE LAST SIXTY YEARS IN TERMS
OF CONSUMER DEBT. GET SERVING
ALL OF THE LAWS THAT WE ENGAGE
TO PROTECT PEOPLE ON BUYING A
CAR BUYING A HOUSE OR- BUYING
CREDIT CARDS DOES APPLY TO THIS
INDUSTRY. YOU'RE RIGHT THEY
SHOULD. AND SO WE'VE JUST THE
BOTTOM LINE OF THIS BILL IS WE
HAVE FOUR IN THE INFORMED BY.
THE COURTS EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HAS SPOKEN AND WE ARE TAKING
THE NEXT STEPS. WE ARE HERE
TODAY INFORMED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND INFORMED BY A LEVEL
OF COULD JURISPRUDENTIAL THEORY
AROUND CONSUMER PROTECTION THAT
IS ESSENTIAL TO EVERYTHING THAT
WE ARE. AS CALIFORNIANS WE
DON'T RIP PEOPLE OFF WE DON'T%
ALLOW FOR THESE THINGS TO
HAPPEN. SO IN MY PASSION ABOUT
THIS YOU'RE RIGHT I AM I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO I'M
EVERY ARGUMENT HAS BEEN THROWN
UP ON THE WALL. HIS IS HOCUS
POCUS AND I'LL GO THROUGH THE
REST OF THEM AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS AND I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT BECAUSE THE BECAUSE ALL THAT
HAVE PARTICIPATED. OUR
SUBSTANTIVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
WORKED HARD. AND TRYING TO
PROTECT FOLKS WHOSE LIVES HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED I HAVE EXAMPLES
OF PEOPLE SIT IN JAILS WHICH I
CAN GIVE YOU AROUND THE STATE
FOR A YEAR TWO YEARS BECAUSE I
COULDN'T AFFORD TO PAY. THEIR
BAIL THE SEVEN JAIL MAN. I MEAN
IS THAT A FAIR WAY TO TREAT
THIS AS A SOCIETY WE TALK ABOUT
WHO WE ARE HELLO. SO I STAND
HERE STRONG SUPPORT WE GOT SOME
WITNESSES I HAVEN'T LOOKED IN
THE PAPER SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
THEY ARE WHAT WE HAVEN'T LOOKED
ANYTHING. JUST TALKING OFF THE
TOP. OF MY HEAD LIKE IT'S WHAT
I USUALLY DO. BUT BUT- WITHOUT
BEING SAID HAPPY DANCING AND-
LISTEN TO THIS IMPORTANT AND NO
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION THIS
ANYWAY SO THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MATURE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGING MY-
PASSION ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU CENTER HURTS BURKE- I HAVE
A ESTEBAN UNIONS ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION VIA
TELEPHONE. AS A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SIX TWO.
OPERATOR YOU MAY BRING HIM IN.
I THANK YOU CARE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BETHANY HAS I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCATES AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION ALSO KNOWN AS A. R.
C. I'M ERIC HE HAD WORKED
TIRELESSLY FOR MANY YEARS
NEARLY FIVE NOW TO REFORM
CALIFORNIA'S PRE TRIAL SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN EQUITY
FAIRNESS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE A STORY OF AN ERROR
SEE MEMBER WHO SADLY IS UNABLE
TO BE WITH US TODAY. RIGHT
BEFORE GRAHAM RAN. AND
IMPLEMENTED A ZERO BILLS GET
YOU'LL FOR PEOPLE BEING CHARGED
WITH LOW LEVEL OFFENSES AND A
R. C. MEMBERS. WITH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ISSUES WAS ARRESTED AND
CHARGED WITH VANDALISM. RATHER
THAN RECEIVING THE HELP AND
SUPPORT SERVICES HE NEEDED THIS
YOUNG MAN RECEIVED A BELL THAT
WAS WELL BEYOND IT MAY. BECAUSE
YOU CANNOT AFFORD A BAIL HE WAS
FORCED TO STAND JAIL AND WAS
MURDERED WITHIN A WEEK. THE
CONSEQUENCES OF INEQUITABLE
BAIL ARE GREAT. NOT ONLY DO
THEY- NOT ONLY DOES COUNTY JAIL
RISK HUMAN LIVES IT TRAUMATIZED
IS AN EXACERBATING UNDERLYING
TRAUMAS AND CONDITIONS
FURTHERMORE IT COST CALIFORNIA
FOUR POINT FIVE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A DAY TO KEEP ROUGHLY
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE LOCKED UP
IN COUNTY JAIL. THE PRETRIAL
JUSTICE INSTITUTE REPORTS THAT
THE COSTS OF SUPERVISING A
PERSON AND THE COMMUNITY WHILE
SPENDING WHILE PENDING TRIAL IS
AOUT 10% OF THE COST OF
KEEPING THEM IN JAIL. THE PRIME
ELIGIBLE FOR ZERO DOLLARS BAIL
UNDER THAT FILL OUR LOW LEVEL
OFFENSES CRIMES OF DESPERATION
AND OUTCRY IF YOU WILL THEY ARE
NOT CRIMES THAT SIGNAL A FUTURE
LIFE OF CRIME OR DANGER TO OUR
SOCIETY. BUT ONE THAT SIGNAL
SOMEONE. BASIC NEEDS ARE NOT
BEING MET. HOW DID YOUR IS NOT
THE SOLUTION FOR THE VENDOR.
IT'S NOT A THAT HE-
REHABILITATE ARE RACE COUNTY
JAIL AS PLACE YOUR COULD
STRIPPED OF YOUR DAY. AND
CONFIDENCE IT'S A NATURAL
DEPRESSIVE RIDDLED WITH THE
STAND. FEAR OF WHAT LIES AHEAD.
LAWYER WILL HIRE PEOPLE OF YOU
FOR NOT SHOWING FOR. SYRIAN
CHILDREN WILL END UP IN THE
SYSTEM HERE THAT YOU MAY BE
FORCED INTO A PLEA BARGAIN
BECAUSE YOU KNOW OUR SYSTEM HAS
STACKED THE ODDS AGAINST YOU
OUR WORST FEAR OF DEATH.
BETWEEN APRIL AND JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTED A
ZERO BALANCE MERCHANTS THE
ORDER BASED ON DIGNITY AND
MEDIUM RISK PRESENTED BY THE
CALL GOOD NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
UNDER THE ORDER WE SAW A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN COUNTY
JAIL POPULATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND WE FOUND NO REAL
SPIKE IN CRIME FOR THOSE
OFFENSES WHICH WERE ZERO. BAIL
ELIGIBLE. THE FTC DATA SHOWS
WHY DECREASE OF 30% IN COUNTY
JAIL POPULATION BETWEEN.
FEBRUARY AND MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. ALTHOUGH CAL EUROPE
SCHEDULE WAS MEANT IN JUNE.
TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY ONE
COUNTIES WHICH ACCOUNT FOR
CLOSE 280% OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION KEPT SOME FORM OF
GERALD DALE IN PLACE. WHY WOULD
THEY DO THAT IF THERE WAS A
SPIKE IN CRIMES ANY I WAS
VOLATILITY. THERE WASN'T A
REPORT PUBLISHED LAST OCTOBER
BY THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
OF CALIFORNIA PROVES THAT THERE
WAS NO MAJOR SPIKE IN CRIME FOR
THOSE OFFENSES WHICH ARE ZERO
BELL ELIGIBLE DURING THE JOB.
ORDER IN FOR MAJOR CALIFORNIA
CITIES. TO OTHER REPORTS BY THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION AND SAFETY AND
JUSTICE CHALLENGE ALSO SUPPORT
THAT ZERO DALE DID NOT LEAD TO
A SPIKE IN CRIME AND ACTUALLY
SHOWED. A DECLINE IN SOME
CRIMES. FURTHERMORE OUT BY KEY.
WHICH ANALYZED BEAR COUNTY
ALAMY. SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE
COSTA SAN MATTEO AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTIES THAT IN THE IME
CALIFORNIA HAD INSTITUTED A-ZERO BILL POLICY. SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 88% 297% OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ALLOWED TO
BAIL OUT FOR FREE. WE'RE NOT
REARRESTED DURING A ROUGHLY ONE
TO TWO MONTH PERIOD WITH DATA
SHOWING THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE RELEASED PRETRIAL DO
NOT BE OFFENDED AND THAT. VERY
LITTLE IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THEY
SHOW UP TO COURT ON TIME THESE
COSTS BOTH HUMAN AND FINANCIAL
ARE UNJUSTIFIABLE. OF THOSE
WITH THIS A RECENT STUDY BY THE
MILLION DOLLAR HOUSE PROJECT AT
UCLA FOUND THAT IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA. THE LAPD LEVIED
OVER THREE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN MONEY BAIL THIS DATA
ONLY CAPTURE THE AMOUNT OF BILL
LEVY AND PAID FOR PRIOR FIFTEEN
A JUDGE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
MOREOVER AN ESTIMATED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN
NONREFUNDABLE BAIL BOND
DEPOSITS WAS PAID TO. BAIL
AGENTS SIMPLY DO NOT FALL
VICTIM TO THE OPPOSITION
SCAREMONGERING TACTICS
EURODOLLAR BELT. DOES NOT LET
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS GROUPS ON
THE STREET BECAUSE- AND VIOLENT
CRIME OR NOT ZERO BELT
ELIGIBLE. WE ALSO TOOK A
MENACING THE SENATE WHICH THE
SENATOR- MOST ELOQUENTLY PUT.
OUT BUT I'LL I'LL JUST
REITERATE BRIEFLY- WE ENSURED
THAT BALLOTS THAT WE CAN READ
INTO SOMEBODY'S ABILITY TO PAY-
WE ALSO PREVENTED. A PERSON
FROM BEING ABLE TO ABUSE
RELEASED UNDER YOUR BELT POSTED
A REVOLVING DOOR- AND ALSO
FURTHER LIMITED THE OFFENSIVE
ELIGIBLE FOR ZERO BELL SO FOR
THESE REASONS. WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT I. NEKI TO SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW
GO TO THE ROMANESQUE- IN ON S.
B. AT SIX TWO SIX OUR IN ROOM
FORTY THREE. FORTY TWO OR
THREE. OTHER ANY WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT. OF COME TO THE- NAME
IN OR- MY NAME PART OF A- WORK
FAMILIES RISE- I BELIEVE GIVE
SUPPORT HAHA THANK YOU I
BELIEVE THEY'LL BE AS NO. I
JUST IN ORDER I YOU. ANY ANYONE
ELSE. NOW WE GO TO. YOU SEE
ANYONE NOPE AND NOW WILL GO TO
THE TELEPHONE- AGENCY OPERATOR
OR NOT BUT LINES FOR S. B. TWO
SIX TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU A LINE
NUMBER AND THEN PLACE IT BACK
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR- ESPYS TWO SIX TWO.
OUR FIRST. PERSON WILL BE LINE.
TWO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE MASCARA
NUMBERS CHRIS RESPONSES POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY THE PART OF PEOPLE
SPONSORS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS AND A DEDUCTION ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. TWO SEVENTY TWO
YOU ARE NOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN SLOAN IN
POLICY INTERN WITH WORKERS AND
ALL MONTEVERDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL S. B. TWO
SIX TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBER CHRIS FORTY DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO THE COURT
THANK YOU. FIND TO SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRANSACTION IF
TRUMP HAPLESS MARC AT THE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. NINE TWO
EIGHTY FOR YOU YOU ARE OPEN.
CANACCORD ARE NOW ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN SUPPORT. LINE TWO
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR FEDERATION OR- THANK
YOU TWO SEVENTY ONE EUROPE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON HOW
THAT WOULD ON WITH WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. TWO FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MARCO
GEORGE OF THE HALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FIND TO SIXTY
YOU ARE ALL BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS LOOKING BACK WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE WILL
LINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO MARCO CAUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BY TWO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HUNDRED DOLLAR
ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA IN
SUPPORT. ONE TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WE NOW
HEAR FROM OPPOSITION WITNESSES
I HAVE A CORD CELLS A LITTLE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION VIA TELEPHONE. AND
MAIL MARK SICKENING AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION ALSO VIA TELEPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORY CELLS ARE LOW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO.
WHEN WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
RISKS TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CRIME VICTIMS. WELL THE BILL
EXEMPTS SPECIFIED OFFENSES FROM
ITS REACH THE ZERO DOLLAR BILL
MANDATE WOULD STILL APPLY TO
OTHER SIGNIFICANT CRIMES. SB
TWO SIXTY TWO WOULD MAKE IT
MUCH MORE LIKELY THAT A PERSON
ARRESTED FOR VARIOUS CRIMES
WILL BE RELEASED PENDING TRIAL.
LAST YEAR WE SAW THE DANGER AND
ZERO DOLLAR BAIL SYSTEM AS
DEFENDANTS IN JURISDICTIONS
AROUND CALIFORNIA. WERE
RELEASED AND SUBSEQUENTLY
REARRESTED SOMETIMES WITHIN
HOURS OF RELEASE ON ZERO DOLLAR
BAIL. MORE RELEASES LIKELY MEAN
MORE PEOPLE COMMITTING NEW
CRIMES OR VIOLATING TERMS OF
RELEASED WHICH LIKELY
TRANSLATES INTO MORE VICTIMS.
SHE AT THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
TO ADDRESS THE CRIMES THAT ARE
COVERED BY THIS BILL- AND THE
ATTEMPT TO- STOP THE REVOLVING
DOOR OF PEOPLE CONTINUOUSLY
BEING RELEASED UNDER A DOLLAR
BILL BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION. COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED PRE TRIAL RELEASE
AN ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY PROGRAMS
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF PERSONS
BEING INCARCERATED DURING
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS. THIS
BILL. DOESN'T FULLY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT HOW THESE PROGRAMS
OPERATE AND MAY RUN COUNTER TO
EVIDENCE BASED DECISIONS BEING
MADE ON A LOCAL LEVEL. FOR
THESE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB TWO
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. O. K.
WHATEVER YOU WANT WITH PAGE
STILL WITH. OKAY OPERATOR.
WE'RE NOW READY TO HEAR FROM
THE- WORK PRAMERICA PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE COMPANY. ALL
RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR. IS
THE ONLINE. LET ME TRY TO FIND
A LINE WHAT WAS IS OUR LAST
NAME PLEASE S. C. K. T. N. I.
N. SEGMENT SECOND MARKS OF.
EIGHT I DO NOT SHOW HIM ONLINE.
OKAY. OKAY WELL WELL HE'S
TRYING TO LOG IN COULD WE GO
AHEAD AND NOT TAKE ANY OTHER
CALLS IT MIGHT BE A IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY ONE MOMENT LET
ME GET BACK TO THE CULINARY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE OUR
WE ARE BACK AND TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
TWO SIX TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD-
ONE TWO EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY LYNCH REPRESENTING THE
GOLDEN STATE BALE'S AGENT. IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE TWO EIGHT THANK YOU.
PLEASE EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY AT
TWO EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARITA MORE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. NINETY TWO
NINETY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID DUNCAN FROM TAE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SECURE. THANK YOU.
NINE TO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JEFF
POLITICAL EXECUTIVE AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
AMERICAN FELL COALITION HERE IN
OPPOSITION HAVE A GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. WHY TO
SIXTY NINE YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SYDNEY
HOFF WITH RESOLUTE ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA BAIL AGENTS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
INSURANCE REFUND PROFESSIONAL
SB THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE TWO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANGELA MAXWELL I'M A CONCERNED
CITIZEN FROM LIVERMORE AND I
STRONGLY STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU. BY TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS GLORIA
MITCHELL FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE BILL TWO SIX TWO.
THANK YOU. ONE TWO EIGHTY SIX
YOUR UP. HELLO MY NAME IS KAREN
AFFAIRS REPRESENTING ASIAN
INDUSTRY BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE ABILITY
SHOULD FEATURE. THANK YOU. HI
MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE PURCHASE THANK YOU IT UP
ONE MOMENT. AND WE WILL ALIGN
TO EIGHTY SIX. BUT USING. THE
LAST PERSON I CUED UP PLEASE
ARE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN. I THEY'RE NOT RE
QUEUEING. ARE THERE THEY GO
I'LL NINE TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
IF I. STE BUT I HAD. YOU ARE
OPEN IT UP. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LAWYER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MARK FACT THAT I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA PROPERTY CATHOLIC
CHURCH OF CERTIFICATION HI
PAULA JONES FOR THE TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL CHALLENGES ATVI NO
POSITION ON THE FIRST SECTION
THE BILL BUT HAS SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT SECTION FOUR OF
THE BILL A BILL LOCATED THE
PENAL CODE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO RE WRITE INSURANCE CONTRACTS
WITHOUT CONSIDERATION OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND CHURCH COMMITTEE.
A BAIL BOND IS A SHORTY POLITIK
GREAT OBLIGATIONS UPON THE
DAILY TO ENSURE IT THIS TYPE OF
BOND LIKE ALL BOGGLES REGULATED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTURE.
LANGUAGEIN THE BILL WOULD MAKE
IT ILLEGAL FOR SURE TO PROVIDE
AVAIL PADA CALIFORNIA SURE THE
COMPANY WOULD BE FINANCIALLY
UNABLE TO POST THE RESERVE
REQUIRED BY STATE LAW IN
ADDITION THE SURETY COMPANY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO COVER AT
THE AGE OF COMMISSION OR OTHER.
UPFRONT COSTS LIKE UNDERWRITING.
THE BILL VIOLATES THE BASIC.
THAN IN. IS ON THE SIMPLE. ALL
THE OLDER BY ALL BY THE
TRANSPORT LIKE A SURE YOU
BOUGHT. IT IF THE INDIVIDUAL
COVERAGE WHEN THE GIRLS COVERED
BY THE POLICY THE INSURANCE
POLICY. PAYS WHAT IS REQUIRED
OF THE POLICY. THE POLICY
HOLDER DOES NOT FILE A CLAIM
THERE'S NO REFUND GIVEN. THIS
WOULD COMPLETELY DESTROY THE
UNDERLYING CONCEPT OF THE LOFT
LARGE NUMBERS. CONCEPT A LOT OF
THE INSURANCE MECHANISM TO
SPREAD THE RISK AMONGST THE
BROADER GROUP OF POLICY
HOLDERS. FOR EXAMPLE A
HOMEOWNER COULD PURCHASE
HOMEOWNER'S. INSURANCE BUT DOES
NOT GET A REFUND. HOUSES NOT
BURNED DOWN PAUL YEAR. EVAN IT
SURE AND WE POLICIES ONE OF.
WAS THE PRICE WE NEED THIS GUY.
DUE TO THE NEED TO COVER THOSE
PEOPLE WHO DID FILE A CLAIM.
THESE REGIONS APK A OPPOSED TO
SUCH A FOR THE BILL. SINCE
SINCE. THANK YOU AND THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTNER DISPENSED
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE THOSE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN FOR SENATOR SEAN RUN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE WEDLOCK
AMERICANS SHOULD ACCOMPANY IN
OPPOSITION AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ON THE SURETIES SIDE OF
THE BUSINESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAUL BAUER ON BEHALF OF
ALL PRO BAIL BONDS. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PARTICULARLY THE SECTION FOR-
PART OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. YES MR BURKE WEBSTER
SO ARM I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL HAS HASN'T
BEEN MOVED YET SO I'LL MOVE IT.
OKAY ARM. THE MAIN QUESTION I
HAVE AND I HOPE YOUR STAFF MY
STAFFER SUPPOSED TO TALK TO
YOUR STAFF TO GET THAT QUESTION
SEE NO IT HAD A TIME. SO ZERO
BAIL FOR MINOR OFFENSES SOME
BAIL FOR LARGER FRANCIS AND I
ASKED THE SAME QUESTION TO.
BONTA WHEN HE BROUGHT THIS-
MEASURE BEFORE HERE SO THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SOME. PEOPLE HAVE
TO PAY BOND. CORRECT OF NOW THE
BAIL BONDS CORPORATION IF THEY
ONLY GET TO KEEP 5% OF THE 10%
SO ANOTHER WORDS- 5% I'M
ASSUMING THAT IF IT'S A HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO GET TO KEEP FIVE.
HELLO THERE FIRST OF ALL THE
WAY IT WORKS IS THAT OKAY TO
KEEP FOR YOU KNOW HOW. TO CUT
CAN JUST WITH ME IS THAT I HAD
YEAH I MEAN THE IDEA JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE IDEA IS
YOU HAVE EXPOSURE FOR YOUR
HOUSE BURNING DOWN FOR THREE
AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS- IF YOU
SOLD YOUR HOUSE ON DAY ONE AND
IT YOU GET A REFUND BECAUSE IF
SOMEBODY ELSE HAS IT AND
THERE'S NO EXPOSURE. IN THIS
MEASURE YOU GET FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON THE FIRST DAY YOU'RE
PAID ON DAY TWO YOU'RE NEVER
CHARGED SO YOU THERE'S NO RISK
THAT'S DETERMINED IT'S JUST TO
GET YOU OUT OF JAIL FOR TWENTY
FOUR HOURS. ON THE ISSUE OF
WHAT THEY GET FOR RATE OF
RETURN. BUT I WANT TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM WELL ONE OF THREE
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED ALSO BY
MARK. IS WHAT YOU GET IS YOU
GET YOUR ADMINISTRATIVE FEE
PLUS YOU GET A RATE OF RETURN.
FOR YOUR MONEY THAT YOU'RE OUT
JUST LIKE. YOUR BANKER YOU LEND
MONEY OUT FOR CERTAIN TIME YOU
HAVE EXPOSURE FOR THAT MONEY.
RIGHT AND YOU GET A RATE OF
RETURN ON THAT MONEY TO THAT'S
IT THERE. YET SO WITH IF YOU
WERE OUT FOR THIRTY OR SIXTY OR
NINETY DAYS JUST LIKE A CREDIT
CARD BILL HOW LONG DID YOU
BORROW THE MONEY FOR. YOU GET
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE PLUS A RATE
OF RETURN. FOR YOUR RISK IT'S A
COMMERCIAL TRANSACTION IT'S
JUST NOT A- PREDATORY LENDING
TRANSACTIONS. THAT I GET
ARRESTED FOR SOMETHING ON DAY
NUMBER ONE. I'M TO HAVE I'M
COMPLEXING SITTING IN JAIL. I
READ FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR CHECK
TO A BOND COMPANY TO GET ME
OUT. THE NEXT DAY THE COURTS AS
WELL THERE WAS MISS IDENTITY.
THERE'S NO RATIONAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CHARGES AND ARRESTS. ALL RIGHT
SO WHAT ON A HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THAT FEATHER BAILS BONDSMEN. UP
JUST TO MAKE THE MATH EASY. AND
IF THE PERSON SAYS OUT FOR FIVE
DAYS WHAT. HOW DO YOU FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE BAIL BONDSMAN GET
WILL BE THE MINISTRY OF FEE AND
FOR PURPOSES OF THE ARGUMENTS
THAT WERE MADE ABOUT ONE OR
THREE THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S JOB IS RICARDO
LARA HAS SUPPORTING THIS. IS
IT'S THE WHOLE UNDERLYING
PURPOSE IF YOU AROUND FOR THE
WON ALL THREE DEBATES IS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS I WAS HERE
YEAH OKAY I HATED IT DOES
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY HOMERS AND
SO AND THEY SET UP RATES AND
WHAT YOUR RATE'S GOING TO BE
AND WHAT THOSE CHARGES WILL BE
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER RATES THAT
ARE DETERMINED THROUGH
INSURANCE WILL BE DETERMINED
AND THEY'LL FIGURE OUT WHAT
THOSE RATES ARE AND WHAT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE. WHAT
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE SHOULD BE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MYSTERY OF
COSTS ARE MAYBE IT'S OUR USE OF
THOUSAND DOLLARS A SIMPLE
EXAMPLE MAYBE MISTER FEES A
HUNDRED FIFTY BUCKS IN THE
INTERESTS ON AND FIFTY BUCKS
AND YOU GET THREE DOLLARS ALL
RIGHT SO. WITH THE TRASH BUT IT
SHOULD BE IN. YOU'RE SAYING
THERE SHOULD BE ENOUGH. SUCH
THAT. BAIL BOND INDUSTRY CAN
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE BOND. YES
YOU JUST CAN'T BE SO.
PROFITABLE AS IT IS NOW. WHEN
WE HAVE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
TESTIFIED. THAT THEY JUST DON'T
PAY IT'S THE- YOU'VE GOT THIS
INTERESTING RELATIONSHIP IF I
COULD JUST TAKE A MOMENT
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
IF YOU HAVE A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR BOUGHT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND UPON THE FEE IS TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WHICH IS
RIGHT UP IN THE AIR. OF THE TEN
THOUSAND THE BOND COMPANY PAYS
THE BONDING COMPANY THE BAIL
BONDS COMPANY PAYS TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO THE SURETY
COMPANY TO GET THE SURETIES. SO
THEY GET 23% RATE OF RETURN SO
THEY GET THE CASH. THE FRONT OF
THE HOUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS IN
THE OLD DAYS YOU KNOW YOU PUT
THE MONEY UP TODAY. NO ONE HAS
A TEN THOUSAND SO IF I GO TO
PUB HOURS COMPANY AND I SAY
WELL I ONLY GOT SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE SALE TAKE THE SIX
THOUSAND THEY PAID THE TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED. THE OTHER THIRTY
SEVEN DOLLARS GOES TO IN THE
POCKET THE BAIL AND THEY SET UP
A PAYMENT PLAN THESE PAYMENT
PLANS IS TO SET YOU UP ON.
COULD LAST YEARS WE'VE SEEN
STORIES WHERE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
PAID FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
BAIL. WHICH IS WHOLE PREDATORY
LENDING INDUSTRY THAT'S GROWN
UP BECAUSE THE COST OF THESE
BONDS. IN BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST
LIKE AN AUTOMOBILE AS WITH
THESE USED CAR DEALERS ARE
FINANCING THESE THINGS AND
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED. SO IT
SHOULD BE A REASONABLE RATE OF
RETURN BANKS TO IT ALL THE
TIME. BANK IT'S A- COMPANY
THAT'S ALREADY ANSWERED THE
QUESTION SO IT'LL BE SET BY THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. AND
SATURATE THAT THE BAIL BONDS
PEOPLE CAN. ACTUALLY DO IT
YEAH. IT WILL PUT THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS OKAY THAT'S THAT'S THE
MAIN QUESTION I HAD BECAUSE IF
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE STILL
PAYING BAIL. YOU NEED TO HAVE A
BAIL BONDS INDUSTRY AND AS
WE'VE TOLD ME THAT YES THE BE
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT. FIVE I'M
HAPPY YOU'VE ANSWERED THE
QUESTION. THE ONE THING I WANT
TO SAY THEY WANT TO MISLEAD YOU
ON THIS IT WILL CHANGE THE
UNDERLYING FINANCIAL- A-
FRAMEWORK OF HOW THESE
COMPANIES WORK. THEY WILL BE
THEY WILL RUN DIFFERENTLY THEY
WILL GET A RATE OF RETURN BANKS
TO IT ALL THE TIME CREDIT CARD
COMPANIES ALL SORTS OF
COMPANIES. GET A RATE OF RETURN
WE AS A GOVERNMENT SAY YOU
CAN'T GET OUT TO PEOPLE. AND
THE LIKE SO WE'LL GIVE A RATE
OF RETURN NO ONE ONCE IN THE
PAST PUT HIM OUT OF BUSINESS IN
THAT SENSE. BUT WHAT'S REALLY
GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE HUMPHRIES CASE WITH
HUMPHREY SAYS. YOU HAVE TO WHEN
YOU SET THE BOND THE FIRST ARE
THE ZERO BONDS FOR THE FOR THE
CHARTER SMALL CRIMES. THEN IF
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BOND. AND
THE COURT DETERMINES THAT THE
COURT HAS TO LOOK AT THE
ABILITY TO PAY. SO WHEN YOU SAY
TO PUT ABOUT A BUSINESS THIS.
COMPANIES CASE LARGELY PUTS
ABOUT IT. JUST BECAUSE- BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IS IF I ONLY COULD
AFFORD THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE COURT'S
GOING TO CHARGE FOR BAIL. AND
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE FOR THE
BILL COMPANIES TO ENGAGE THE
REASON THE BILL COMPANIES ARE
STILL ENGAGING. DURING THE
PANDEMIC IS THEY REALLY WERE
GOING AFTER DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES. WE HAVE A REPORT HERE
THAT SHOWS THAT THEY MADE A TON
OF MONEY. BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES THEY
WERE ABLE TO GET CHARGE PEOPLE
OUT OF MONEY WHEN THEY WERE.
GETTING IN FIGHTS WITH THEIR
SPOUSES. GET OUT OF JAIL. AND
MAKE MONEY ON THE FRONT END.
AND SO THAT'S WHERE THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO IT BUT SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT. IT WOULDN'T BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT BY ME TO SAY
THIS WOULD DRAMATICALLY IMPACT
THE BUSINESS. BUT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS GOING TO BE
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED JUST BY
HUMPHRIES THAT SAYS ABILITY TO
PAY. RIGHT SO YOU BAIL BONDS
ARE ALL ABOUT. LEVERAGING
SOMEBODY. GOING TO THEIR
GRANDMOTHER TO THEIR SISTER TO
THEIR- MOTHER TO ANYBODY TO
GET. BORROW MONEY. TO THAT HAVE
ENOUGH CASH TO PAY THE BAIL.
OUT AT. OKAY JUST ONE MORE
THING IT'S REALLY. NICE AND
THAT IS THE RATE OF THE IDEAS
ONE. STOP DALE. WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF BAIL. APOLOGIZE AND-
VOTE. IT'S TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
SHOW UP IN SANTA CLARA 95% OF
PRE TRIAL APPEARANCES. FOR
DEFENDANTS. OKAY THAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. SO YOU GO
THROUGH J. JERSEY KENTUCKY YOU
TRY TO GET TO GO TO JAIL COME
UP HOW DO YOU DO THAT. TEXT YOU
LITERALLY CAN TEXT PEOPLE. AND
YOU GET THEM TO SHOW UP. SO YES
YOUR POINT YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU
MORE NW ONES ON IT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
I DON'T HONESTLY CHIU THAT SOME
OKAY NO YOU DON'T YOU ANSWER
THE QUESTION THOROUGHLY AND I
PARTICULARLY. APPRECIATE THE
LAST PART WHERE YOU SAID.
BASICALLY SOMEONE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY THEIR OWN BAIL AND
WON'T HAVE TO GO TO THE BALLOT
BOX WENT. FINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SORRY FOR THE LONG ANSWER
QUESTIONS ARE. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR AND THANK YOU MISTER
HERTZBERG FOR YOUR- PASSIONATE
PRESENTATION DAY I THINK WE CAN
ALL SEE HOW MUCH YOU CARE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND CLEARLY WORKED
ON FOR MANY YEARS. AND SO I
WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
THERE'S MANY PARTS OF THIS BILL
THAT I. I REALLY APPRECIATE AND
ONE IS ACTUALLY SECTION FOR.
WHICH ADDRESSES EXACTLY WHAT.
WE JUST HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
WITH WHICH IS THAT IF YOU ARE.
IF AN ACTION IS DISMISSED OR
YOU WERE NEVER CHARGE THE YOU
DO NOT OWE MONEY I MEAN MAKING
MONEY OFF AS WE KNOW. PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE RESTED IN FAR HIGHER
NUMBERS. AND THEN IF THEY'RE
NOT CHARGER CASE THERE'S MISS
THE FACT THAT SOMEBODY IS
PROFITING. OF THOSE ARRESTS IS.
I MEAN I'M JUST WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT SO I THINK THAT
THAT PIECE OF THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO GETTING IT
THE ISSUE WE HAVE. WITH FAILING
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO AM A HUGE.
SUPPORTER OF GETTING RID OF
MONEY BAIL I THINK THAT THE
FACT THAT OUR SYSTEM CURRENTLY
INCARCERATE THOSE WHO ARE
IMPOVERISHED MORE THAN THOSE
WHO ARE ARRESTED SOCIETY IS
ALSO UPSIDE DOWN RIGHT WHAT WE
SHOULD BE. HOLDING THOSE WHO
POSE A SAFETY RISK NOT THOSE
WHO CAN'T PAY. AND I APPRECIATE
YOU TRYING TO GET THAT I THINK
THE ONE THING THAT I CONTINUE
TO STRUGGLE WITH IS THAT. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THE HUMPHRIES
CASE DID A LOT OF THINGS SOME
OF WHICH ARE HERE I THINK IT'S
A WONDERFUL THING TO SEE IF
THERE ARE OTHER MEASURES
BESIDES HOLDING SOMEONE. THAT
CAN PROTECT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
BEFORE WE EVER HOLD SOMEONE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT. WHEN
SOMEONE ISN'T AT HOME TO CARRY
ON THEIR JOB OR PAY THEIR RENTS
THAT THAT AFFECTS THEIR ABILITY
TO STAY. CLEAN AND NOT RUSTED
OF EIGHT. BUT MY CONCERN IS
THAT FOR SOMEONE WHO COMES IN.
ON A LOW LEVEL OFFENSE. BUT FOR
EXAMPLE THE OFFICERS FIND AN
ARSENAL OF WEAPONS RIGHT BUT
THAT'S- FINE. THAT'S NOT A
FELON IN POSSESSION CASE- YOU
KNOW THAT PERSON POSES A PUBLIC
SAFETY THREAT AND UNDER THIS
MODEL THE COURT WOULD HAVE NO
JURISDICTION TO HOLD THAT
INDIVIDUAL EVEN IF THE COURT
AFTER THE HUMPHRIES ANALYSIS.
FOUND CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE A PUBLIC
SAFETY RISK AND THAT CONCERNS
ME IF I JUST WANTED YOU TO
ADDRESS THAT. PAGE NINETEEN OF
THE HUMPHRIES CASE SAYS. THAT
WE IN SIMILARLY INTERPRET THE
CONSTITUTION TO BAR COURT FROM
CAUSING INTERESTED TO BE
DETAINED PRE TRIAL BASED ON-
CONCERNS REGARDING THE SAFETY
OF THE PUBLIC IN VICTIM UNLESS
THE COURT FINDS FIRST FINDS
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THAT NO OTHER CONDITIONS OF
RELEASE COULD MEANS WE PROTECT
THOSE INTERESTS RIGHT GOES ON
THE STATE ON REFLECTION WE
AGREE WITH HUMPHRIES. THE
HOBBIT THAT THE STANDARD OF
PROOF SHOULD LIKEWISE BE CLEAR
CONVINCING THERE'S NO
COMPELLING REASON TO GO TO THE
VERY STANDARD SO THE POINT IS I
THINK THE CASE AND I DON'T WANT
TO GET TO THE DEPRESSION HE
RAISED FOR THE JUDGES JUST GAVE
TO US- JUST. JUST RECENTLY. ON
THIS IS REALLY A STICKY POIN
IN THIS IN THIS WHOLE LARGER
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THERE'S A
SERIES OF DIFFERENT. THOUGHTS
IN THIS WHOLE WORLD RIGHT. ONE
OF THE BIG CHALLENGES IT YOU
KNOW THE IDEA IS THAT. THERE'S
NO DIRECT STATEMENT AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT SAYS THE
COURT HAS THE RIGHT TO DO THIS
IT JUST BUT THERE'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARD THAT'S
IMPLICIT WHAT THE JUDGES TRADE
ASSOCIATION AS OPPOSED TO
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH THE JUDGES OF
SITUATION. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY LOSELY WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THEY HAVE NOT OPPOSE
THIS IT'S REALLY THE JUDGES.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE FEARFUL OF. AN EARLY
ANSWER TO IT TO BE VERY FRANK
BUT IT'S VERY HARD AND I AGREE
WITH- SOME OF THE ADVOCATES ON
THE OTHER SIDE THAT HAVE
OPPOSED PROP TWENTY FIVE AND
THE LIKE. THEY FEEL. THAT
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE BILL
INDUSTRY AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY BAYLOR SO HIGH. IS THE
JUDGE'S ARTIFICIALLY AGREE TO
SETTING THESE THINGS HIGH WE
HAVE EVIDENCE WITH A NO
ATTENTION AT ALL. SO THAT WHAT
THEY DO IS THEY CAN USE THE
EXCUSE OF A HIGH BAIL TO KEEP
SOMEBODY IN JAIL. WHO SHOULDN'T
BE IN JAIL IS NOT A FLIGHT RISK
IS NOT A PUBLIC RACES BUT THAT
MIGHT RESULT IN A- IN A
SITUATION FOR THEM LIKE. THE
WILLIE HORTON CASE OR LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD WE
REPRESENT. YOU KNOW WHERE JUDGE
GETS TAKEN OUT. SO THEY'RE
TRYING TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND SO JUDGES IN THIS HAPPENED
TO US IS ONE OF THE BIG DEBATES
WE HAD WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE.
AND THIS GROUP. TOGETHER WITH
THE ADVOCATES OF THE OF THE
SITE. WAS WHAT'S THE POWER OF
THE COURT THERE'S A FEAR. AMONG
PEOPLE WHO ARE IMPACTED. THE
JUDGES ARE GOING TO BE TOO
EASILY. MANIPULATED THAT REGARD
AND SO WE WERE VERY CAUTIOUS SO
WHAT THE WAY WE WROTE THIS AND
THE REASON WHY WE WORK THIS WAY
AND LEFT A- CONSTITUTIONAL
STANDARD. BASED UPON THAT THE
COURT PURSES. PUTTING A
SPECIFIC PROVISION THAT SAYS IF
THIS IS THE CASE. WE WANT TO GO
THERE WE FELT THAT THE CASE WAS
CLEAR ENOUGHIN THAT REGARD AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER AREAS
IN THE CASE. WHERE WE DID NOT
SPECIFICALLY. REVISED
BLUEPRINTS FOR EXAMPLE WE SAID
WE HAVEN'T CODIFIED THE
CONDITIONS WERE PRE TRIAL.
RELEASE A COURT MUST CONSIDER
WE DID NOT. LOOK AT WHAT A
COURT MUST LOOK FOR REAL LAST
RESTRICTIVE ALTERNATIVES WITHIN
JUST FINE WITH THOSE WHERE WE
DIDN'T DEFINE THE COURT NEEDS
TO CONDUCT A DUE PROCESS EQUAL
PROTECTION. HEARING IN EACH
CASE SO MY POINT TO YOU IS.
WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE THIS IN
A WAY. THAT IS SENSITIVE TO AND
UNDERSTANDS THE ARGUMENTS. BY
PEOPLE THAT FEEL THAT WERE OVER
POLICE THAT WERE IN A SITUATION
WHERE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE.
ARE INAPPROPRIATELY PUT IN JAIL
THAT THEY'RE HELD IN JAIL THAT
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM OFFICE
UNFAIR TO THEM. WHERE WE STILL
HAVE THE GUIDANCE ON THE OTHER
HAND THE CONSTITUTIONAL
GUIDANCE WHICH I THINK IS
CLEAR. BUT JUDGES YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT IS THEY WANT THE
STATUTES SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT MAKING A DECISION.
AND SO LOOK WHAT WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT THAT I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT WE'RE NOT. BUT
I'M NOT A ON SENSITIVE CHIU.
THE ARGUMENTS I'VE HEARD OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN. ABOUT
JUDGES OVER REACTING AND I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THERE'S A
DISTINCTION IN THE PUBLIC GET
KILLED BY A BUNCH OF JUDGES ON
THIS BUT- BETWEEN THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WHICH IS LOOKING TO THE
GOVERNANCE OF THE- JUDICIAL
BRANCH. AND THE JUDGES
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS A TRADE
ASSOCIATION AND THERE'S A SPOT
THERE AND THAT'S WHY THIS LATE
LETTER THE CAME IN FROM A JUDGE
ASSOCIATION I JUST SAW. IS
DIFFERENT FROM ALL THE HOMEWORK
THAT WE'VE DONE TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. I DON'T THAT HELPS BUT
I WANTED TO TRY TO BE SENSITIVE
TO. THE LARGER ARGUMENT INTO
BRICKS PLANE YOU AN HONEST AND
DIRECT WAY. WHY WE'RE DEBATING
THIS THING BUT WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT IT. WILL BE MEETING
WITH THE ADVOCATES DURING THE
BREAK HOPEFULLY IF THIS PASSES.
AND TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT BUT
I AM SENSITIVE TO THEIR POINT
OF VIEW. THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK I
ACTUALLY DID NOTICE THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE JUDGE'S
DECISION WITHIN FOUND THAT
INTERESTING MYSELF- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOU LEAVING BE.
EXEMPTED ACT CRIMES TO. THE
HUMPHREY STANDARD I THINK
THAT'S APPROPRIATE I GUESS I
STILL I JUST REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. THE ONES THAT ARE
COVERED BY THIS LAW FOR WHICH
AND THERE WILL BE ZERO. FAIL
AND THERE'S NO ANALYSIS A
PUBLIC SAFETY THREAT I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT THAT.
AND WE IN THIS COMMITTEE GIVE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. ALL THE
TIME WE DECIDED ON MISS ROLLINS
BILL A FEW MINUTES AGO AND SO.
TO THE EXTENT OF THIS COMMITTEE
OFTEN SAYS THE JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IS APPROPRIATE IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO SAY THAT IN THIS
CONTEXT IT'S NOT. AND SO I
STRUGGLE TO SAY THAT. ON ON
THOSE LOW LEVEL. THERE'S NEVER
AN OPERA. TO SOMEONE IS A
THREAT THE COMMUNITY AND SO. I
DON'T THINK I'M READY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I REALLY
DO LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING
THERE BECAUSE I THINK THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING HERE IS SO
CRITICAL. AND AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE A LOT OF THE NEW
ONES AND STUFF. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
OKAY CENTER YOUR TO YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WANT TO THANK A
STEP. ON KNOWN AS FOR IS ALWAYS
BROUGHT TESTED ON THE MATT
WE'VE- THIRTY ANY OTHER HOUSE
THE MEASURE- AND- BOB THE RE IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S DIFFERENT
WHAT WE SEE BEFORE. IT ISN'T
ONE THESE CLOSE TO THE LONG. IS
FOR. REALLY ISN'T TO PROVIDE A
BLUEPRINT THAT WORKS- BASED
UPON. A BAIL SYSTEM WHERE WE
KEEP BAILING PLACE WE DON'T
MAKE IT ILLEGAL LIKE WE DID
WITH TO ELIMINATE BAIL LIKE WAS
DONE UNDER. S. B. TEN. ARMED
AND WE HAVE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT RELATES TO
EXEMPTING FURTHER CRIMES AND-
DEALING WITH THE REVOLVING DOOR
SITUATION. AND I THINK THE
ARGUMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY REALLY DON'T
HOLD BECAUSE- THE WHOLE PURPOSE
OF AS I SUGGESTED IN MY- LONG
WINDED ANSWER TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK. IS THAT ARMED. THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WHO SUPPORT OF
THIS IS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE WITH RESPECT TO THIS
LIMITATION ON HOW MUCH MONEY-
THESE COMPANIES CAN MAKE AND
AGAIN IT'S A SITUATION WHERE I
WOULD SUSPECT THAT IT WILL BE A
MUCH SMALLER INDUSTRY FOR NO
OTHER REASON THAN JUST PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO PAY VERSUS. YOU KNOW
THE ABILITY TO GO OUT AND
SQUEEZE THEM UP TO GET AS MUCH
MONEY OUT OF THEM AS POSSIBLE
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FROM THIS
ESTEEMED COMMITTEE. OKAY THANK
YOU SENATOR NIGHT I THINK THE
CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING IT TO
PASS. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
CALL FOR THE QUESTION. SB TWO
SIX TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY NO LACKING NO
BARRICADE CAN. BACK BACK HE HAD
NOT VOTING LEE LEE HI CORK.
CORK AND SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
FIGURE TO. THE OUR TURN NOW
WICKS. IT MEASURES LOCAL. BUT
MEASURES UNCLE NEEDS TO MORE
THANK YOU SO MUCH PRESSURE
THANK YOU. OKAY HAVE YOU GUYS
ROCHAMBEAU OUT THERE TO SEE
WHO'S UP NEXT. OKAY ONE OF SIR.
THERE ARE HI DEAR. THE YOU SO
MUCH SO I WILL BE VERY BRIEF-
MISTER CHAIR INTO GOOD
AFTERNOON I'VE NEVER SENT TO
SEE EVERYONE FIRST AND FOREMOST
I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR UP FOR HIS INCREDIBLE
WORK HI HE'S BEEN FANTASTIC
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS MISTER
FLEMING I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT VERY VERY
GRATEFUL IN ALSO TETANUS WICKS
FOR BEING A CO AUTHOR I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF. LONG STORY SHORT-
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONTINUE CONCERNS THAT WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ON
THIS ISSUE. AT BUT THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT JOURNALISTS
ABILITY TO PERFORM THEIR
CRITICAL FIRST AMENDMENT ROLE
OF DOCUMENT HISTORY IN
INFORMING THE PUBLIC DURING.
THAT FIRST AMENDMENT
DEMONSTRATIONS MARCHES PROTESTS
AND RALLIES I CAN ADVANCE ON
OBSTRUCTED AT THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE ACLU.
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS ETHNIC
MEDIA SERVICES IN TWO DAYS.
MISTER CHAIR IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU THAT WE HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIKE TO BE A TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ADAM ROSE FROM THE LA PRESS
CLUB IN KEVIN BAKER FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WHOSE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ACLU AND HAPPY
TO GET ANY DETAILS ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- IF THAT WORKS FOR
YOU MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU SENATOR- AT AND
T. OPERATOR IF WE COULD HAVE A
ADAM ROSE. FROM THE LA PRESS
CLUB. YES AMONG THE ONE. YOU
MAY YOU MAY PROCEED SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS ADAM ROSE
AND I SERVE ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE LOS ANGELES
PRESS CLUB MY ORGANIZATION
JOINT BEEN UNPRECEDENTED
COALITION ACCORDING SB NINETY
EIGHT AND THAT INCLUDES MORE
THAN TWENTY PRESS GROUPS AND
LABOR UNIONS. COLLECTIVELY WE
REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA JOURNALISTS WHO
DON'T TYPICALLY ENDORSE
LEGISLATION. JOURNALISM IS NOT
A CRIME. YEAH IN A RECENT
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD DOZENS OF
JOURNALISTS WERE ARRESTED OR
DETAINED DURING PROTESTS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY WERE JUST DOING
THEIR JOB AS THE EYES AND EARS
OF THE PUBLIC. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR STAFF MAY
HAVE BEEN APPLIED TO WITH PHOTO
AND VIDEO EVIDENCE THAT WAS
GATHERED BY THE JOURNALIST
COALITION. MUCH IT SHOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT ATTEMPTS TO REMOVE
PEOPLE DURING UNLAWFUL
ASSEMBLY- THE SHOULD HAVE
EASILY RECOGNIZED AS CRASS.
PREVENTING THEM FROM BEARING
WITNESS TO THESE IMPORTANT
PUBLIC EVENTS IN CRITICAL
POLICE ACTIVITIES. WHOSE NAME.
I'M SORRY DID YOU LOSE THEIR-
HE FINISHED. OH NO SORRY I
THINK WE I THINK WE A LOT
SIGNAL THERE IS AN AWKWARD
FINISH WHAT I THINK IS AROUND.
NO NO THAT WASN'T WHAT I THINK
IS IT WITH THIS PRESENTATION
MUCH OF IT SHOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT X. TO REMOVE PEOPLE
DURING UNLAWFUL ASSEMBLY. MANY
SHOULD VERY EASILY RECOGNIZED
AS PRESS PREVENTING THEM FROM
BEARING WITNESS TO IMPORTANT
PUBLIC EVENTS. IN CRITICAL
POLICE ACTIVITIES. EVEN A BRIEF
DETAINMENT CAN KILL THE G. DOT
CHILL THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
OF THE PRESS. AND STOP THEM
FROM DOING THEIR JOB. WE'VE
SEEN PLENTY IN HAND BECAUSE IN
THAT TIES. BUT THIS OFTEN GOES
FURTHER. WE SEE OFFICER TO
EXPLICITLY THREATENED TO BREAK
CAMERAS. WE'VE SEEN SEVERAL
ACTUALLY BROKEN. AND WE CAN
OFFICERS MAKE INEXPLICABLE
UNPROVOKED ASSAULT. WE'VE SEEN
INJURIES. ONE REPORTER DO YOU
HAVE THE FEELING. KNOCKED OUT
OF HIS TEACHER. OFTEN WE SEE
PEOPLE. A DISPROPORTIONATE WHO
ARE BLOCKING BROWN JR. WHAT WE
DO NOT. OUR JOURNALISTS. WITH
POLICE TRYING TO ENTER COMMAND
POST OR COMMITTING ANY CRIME.
THE CULPRIT HERE IS NOT
JOURNALISTS BUT A LEGAL GRAY
AREA. SB NINETY EIGHT WILL FIX
IT BUT CLEANING THE MODEST
PROVISIONS- EXPLICIT PERMISSION
THE PRESS CURRENTLY HAS TO BE
PRESENT AT THE DOCTOR. AND
APPLYING THEM TO UNLAWFUL
ASSEMBLY. IT PUT CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE CLEARLY ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE FIRST AMENDMENTBUT
MOST OF ALL IT AFFIRMS THAT
JOURNALISM IS NOT A CRIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR NOW-
HOPING TO HEAR FROM KEVIN BAKER
FROM THE ACLU. YES MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IS NOT REALLY
MUCH I CAN ADD TO THE ELOQUENT
TESTIMONY OF MISTER THOSE. AS
YOU KNOW THE ACLU HAS LONG
ADVOCATED FOR THE RIGHTS OF THE
MEDIA TO REPORT ON ISSUES OF
PUBLIC INTEREST MORE RECENTLY
WE'VE BEEN CALLED ON TO PROVIDE
LEGAL REPRESENTATION TO
REPORTERS WHO HAVE NOT ONLY
BEEN WARMLY PROHIBITED OR
RESTRICTED FROM DOING THEIR
WORK. ASSEMBLY COURTED THE
MISTREATMENT. BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THE PROTEST.
THIS IS A MODEST BILL AND EVEN
NARROWER THAN SIMILAR MEASURE
YOU PASSED LAST YEAR. IT SIMPLY
CLARIFIES BASIC PRESS FREEDOMS
GUARANTEED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND ALREADY
RECOGNIZED BY STATUTE IN
SIMILAR CONTEXTS. YOU MIGHT
THINK THIS BILL SHOULD NOT BE
NECESSARY THAT OUR EXPERIENCE
UNFORTUNATELY HAS SHOWN THAT IT
IS. AND WE ASK CLEARLY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
YOU OF WITNESSES IN THIS ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THAT'S
NOT THE OPERATOR COULD WE GO
TO. THOSE WISH TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT ON THE FALL. FOUR
COMMENT INTO THE PORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. LINE
THREE HUNDRED FOUR YOU'RE MY
KID UP. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
THATCHER BEGINNING A LOT
CHANGES FROM THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE PORTABLE MOBILE
IN TWELVE THANK YOU. NINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARCO GEORGIA MAP FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY. FIVE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. SURE YOU TOMORROW HAPPEN
IN A KITCHEN WORKER AMERICAN
NINETEEN SUPPORT THANK YOU. WHY
TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX. OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BRITNEY
BY SAUDI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SB NINETY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW GO TO JONATHON FELDMAN.
WHO WAS THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBERS- THANK YOU- JOHN
CONSULTING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I LIKE THE FIRST
START BY SAYING THAT- WE DO NOT
CONDONE OR DEFEND ANY OFFICER
MISCONDUCT DIRECTED AT THE
MEDIA. BUT WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED SB NINETY EIGHT WHICH
CONTAINS SOME OF THE SAME FLAWS
WE IDENTIFIED IN THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THIS MEASURE. WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR LAST
YEAR. SB NINETY EIGHT WOULD
ALLOW MEDIA ACCESS TO ANY.
IMMEDIATE AREA SURROUNDING ANY
EMERGENCY FIELD COMMAND POST OR
ANY OTHER COMMAND POST PLEASE
FIND A ROLLING CLOSURE. AND
EMERGENCY FEEL COMMAND POST AND
ANY OTHER COMMAND POSTS ARE NOT
DEFINED SO WHAT BECAUSE BROAD
ACCENTS SB NINETY EIGHT.
CREATES- HE NEW ACCESS TO
CERTAIN AREAS DURING-
OPERATIONS. AND ALSO A NEW
PENAL CODE VIOLATION FOR ANY
OFFICER THAT EITHER INTERFERES
WITH OR OBSTRUCTING MEDIA COULD
GUARD THE TO FIT IN IN THE
COURSE AND SCOPE OF THEIR DUTY.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT THE PENALTY
WOULD BE FOR THE OFFICER IN
THIS CASE BUT OUR LEGAL
INTERPRETATION IS THAT ANY
UNSPECIFIED PENALTY AND PENAL
CODE REVERTS TO A MISDEMEANOR.
BUT BECAUSE IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
THE PENALTY WOULD BE WE HAVE
ASKED THE AUTHORS OFFICE LAST
MONTH FOR A JOINT MEETING WITH
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL TO GET
CLARITY ON THIS MATTER. SB
NINETY EIGHT FURTHER
COMPLICATES AND COMPROMISED THE
OFFICERS BY STATING- NEWS
REPORTERS SHALL NOT BE CITED
FOR THE FAILURE TO DISPERSE A
VIOLATION OF CURFEW OR A
VIOLATION OF PARAGRAPH ONE. OF
SUBDIVISION A OF SECTION ONE
FORTY EIGHT. THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
CODE SECTION ONE FORTY EIGHT AT
THE SECTION. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND OTHER EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PROFESSIONALS USED TO CITE
SOMEONE FOR OBSTRUCTING. AN
OFFICER OR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN IN THE DISCHARGE OF
THEIR DUTIES. THEREFORE SB
NINETY EIGHT IN OUR
INTERPRETATION THOSE TWO THINGS
THAT ARE PROBLEMATIC. IT
POTENTIALLY CRIMINALIZES AN
OFFICER FOR INTERFERING WITH
THE MEDIA. AND IT PREVENTS AN
OFFICER FROM MOVING REMOVING
THE MEDIA FOR OBSTRUCTING THE
OFFICER- THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
AN OFFICER CAN STILL CITE
SOMEONE FOR ANOTHER CODE
SECTION TO REMOVE THEM AT A
CERTAIN POINT BUT IT'S UNCLEAR
WHAT CODE SECTION THAT MIGHT BE
TO US. AND REGARDLESS. REMOVING
PT ONE FORTY EIGHT CREATE CON
IN THE CAN. IN YOUR BILL OF THE
OP. WE CLEAR UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO IMPORTANCE OF ALLOWING
ME ACCESS TO COVER THE
IMPORTANT. BUT AS NINETY EIGHT
PUTS OFF IN A- AND ANTI
POSITION- WE HOPE. WORK TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS BUT THE
ALL. WHICH WE SHARED. WERE BUT
HOPEFULLY CAN SO WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZE THE SAFETY OF THE
OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC.
UNFORTUNATES CURRENT FORM TODAY
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY. OF PERSONS
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WE DO NOT. OKAY OPERATOR TO
READ NOW LISTEN. TO THOSE WHO
WISH TO EXPRESS THEIR-
DISSATISFACTION WITH THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. LINE
THREE HUNDRED THREE YEAR MIKE
IS UP AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS NINE SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE. THE CRIMINAL POLICE
OFFICERS LOCATION CURRENTLY
SPONSORS SENSATION AND THE
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
FROM HOMEOWNER. L. THIRTY
NEWPORT BEACH. AB ONE THEN ANNA
BURBANK LEGAL WORD ARCADIA
RIVERSIDE GEN OVER CITY LOS
ANGELES SCHOOL POLICE AND
CALIFORNIA COALITION HIGH
SCHOOL PRINT- SIXTY. MILES ON
OPPOSITION WE CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM THIS PHONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
HUNDRED FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MAPPERS ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT. JERRY BROWN AND
FORMER PEACE OFFICER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB NINETY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE THREE
HUNDRED ONE. THIS RETURN
MEMBERS CORY CELLS ALONG THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND WAIT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
HE SHARES WE MAY HAVE SOMEBODY.
DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SPEAK THIS BILL AT
ALL SIR OKAY. OKAY WE WILL THEN
NOW COME BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
WISH TO BE SHARE. YES SIR SOME
OF THE COURT. CHAU YOU'VE
NARROWED THE BILL FROM LAST
YEAR SO THAT IT SPECIFIC ABOUT
KIND OF ORGANIZATION HAVE TO BE
A REPORTER FOR HOW WOULD A
POLICE OFFICER- RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE- OUR PEOPLE
IN A RECOGNIZED- REPORTING ARE.
SO I ME AS THEY DO NOW- IS WHEN
THERE IS A MEMBER OF THE PRESS-
THERE THERE WOULD NOT BE ANY
CHANGE IN THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT- PRESS
CREDENTIALS NINE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE IT'S BEEN DEBATED IN THIS
STATE FOR MANY YEARS IN FACT
DECADES I DON'T THINK THERE
WOULD BE ANY AGREEMENT IN
REGARDS TO DOING A UNIVERSAL
PRESS CREDENTIAL WE'RE STARTING
NOW SEE SOME OF THE LARGEST AT
CITIES ACROSS THE NATION DO
AWAY WITH CHRIS PRESS
CREDENTIALS- IN A- HAVE TO SAY
I. THE MISDEMEANOR ISSUE IF
IT'S ALL RIGHT MR QUIRK- AT THE
DIRECTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR WE TOOK OUT THE
LANGUAGE REGARDS THE
MISDEMEANOR. SO WE TOOK THEM AS
AUTHOR AND THEN MINCED LAST
YEAR- AND WE REMOVED THAT
DEFINITION SO- IN THIS IS NOT
DEFAULT TO A MISDEMEANOR AS
WELL- BECAUSE THE BILL DOES NOT
CLARA A VIOLATION- PENAL CODE
NINETY EIGHT HEY SO I'M HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT- OKAY SO IT
MIGHT. BE DIFFICULT. I MEAN I
DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
CHALLENGES NOW AND IN JUST
BEING HONEST AND WE TAKE A LOOK
TOOK A LOOK JUST RECENTLY IN
LOS ANGELES. AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS CLEARLY MARKED AS A OS
ANGELES TIMES REPORTER WAS
STILL ARRESTED. OKAY THEN THE
SECOND PART- OF THIS IS- THERE
SHOULD BE THERE PROBABLY ARE
SOME AREAS WHERE THERE IS
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION GOING
ON- AND THEY SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS IS THAT PERHAPS YOU
SHOULD PUT SOMETHING IN THERE
THAT. I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
WOULD BE THAT THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION AND ANALYSIS ABOUT-
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION REMAIN
CONFIDENTIAL. YEAH I THINK THAT
THERE WOULD BE CONCERN IN
REGARDS TO ENTRY OF COMMAND
POST SO FOR EXAMPLE- IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT A MOBILE COMMAND
POST WE'VE ALL SEEN THOSE
REALLY LARGE- RV LOOKING
VEHICLES- WHERE- THE HEART OF
THE OPERATION WHETHER IT'S UP
TO SIX HUNDRED. SO I THINK FOR
US- FIRST AND FOREMOST THERE IS
NO EXPECTATION WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL WALKS INTO THE LOBBY
OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT. THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL THE PUBLIC OR
MEMBER OF THE PRESS IS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO WALTZ THROUGH THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT- IT'S JUST
WON'T HAPPEN. SAME THING WITH
THIS COMMAND POST- AND-
INDIVIDUALS WHETHER IT'S A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC OR THE
PRESS WILL NOT BE GIVEN
UNFETTERED ACCESS. AND IN FACT-
THE POLICE HAVE THE FULL
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO SAY. THAT
AND NUMBER THE PUBLIC OR THE
PRESS NOT ALLOWED INTO THE
COMMAND POST- SAME THING AS IT
WOULD BE DONE YES IT IS. SO YOU
FEEL THIS IS ALREADY COVERED
AND YOU DON'T NEED TO BE MORE
EXPLICIT ABOUT IT- WELL- THEN
I'M GOING TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK THERE'S A SECOND OKAY
THANK YOU I'LL BE VOTING FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THEY WERE VERY GRATEFUL.
SOMEONE ELSE LIKE TO ON THE
COMMITTEE LIKE TO SPEAK MISTER
SHARAPOVA TWENTY. SO THE ANY
NEW SERVICE. H. AWAY WRITING A
NEWSLETTER DECIDED THEY WANTED
TO GET IN ON SOME OF THIS MAY
GO DOWN THERE AND TELL YOU I'M
I'M A NEWS PERSON FOR THE H.
AWAY. DO THEY GET TO GO IN. I
KNOW THAT WE WANT TO GO DOWN
THE ROAD JUST BEING CANDID
ABOUT HYPOTHETICALS- BUT WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
HYPOTHETICAL SO I'M I'M HAPPY-
AS A MEMBER TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
YOUR POINT- I'VE HEARD THIS
POINT JUST BEING HONEST FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS OF WHAT IF WHAT
IF- BUT IT IS A HYPOTHETICAL AT
THIS POINT LET'S TALK ABOUT IT
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING AND
I'LL GIVE YOU LIKE WHAT WHAT
WHAT TEN TWENTY WITH RIGHT NOW
THAT'S A REAL. IS THAT WE HAVE
JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN DETAINED
OVER SIX HUNDRED JOURNALISTS IN
THE YEAR OF LAST YEAR WERE
EITHER DETAINED. ASSAULTED OR
ATTACKED. SO THAT'S WHERE THE
ISSUE THAT I FEEL THAT WE NEED
TO BE FOCUSING ON IT IS A
HYPOTHETICAL IN THIS STATE THAT
AN INDIVIDUAL BASED OFF OF
PRIOR EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO
FAKE THAT THEY ARE A MEMBER OF
THE MEDIA SO I I'M I'M- HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS OKAY
NINE POINT IS ANYBODY WITH A
CAMERA CAN CLAIM THEY ARE PART
OF A NEWS SERVICE OF SOME SORT.
AND GO INTO AN AREA THAT IS AN
INCIDENT COMMANDER YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. AS AN ELIGIBLE%
FOR THE SAFETY WHEN I'M IN
INCIDENT COMMANDER I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SAFETY. OF
EVERYBODY IN THE AREA. AND IF
I'M TRYING TO CLEAR OUT AN
AREA. BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
TYPE OF DANGER OR ITS
ESCALATING INTO SOMETHING ELSE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE PEOPLE.
IS MY RESPONSIBILITY. AND IF I
HAVE A SOMEBODY WHO SAYS
THEY'RE PART OF A NEW SERVICE
GOING IN. AND USING THAT TO
STAY IN AN AREA AND THEN THEY
GET HURT. WELL GUESS WHO'S NOT
WHO GUESSES ON HOPE FOR THAT.
THE INCIDENT COMMANDER IN THE
AGENCY THAT THEY REPRESENT THE
INCIDENT COMMANDER STILL HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY UNDER THIS BILL
TO BE ABLE TO GO UP AND ASK AN
INDIVIDUAL TO LEAVE RIGHT WELL
I CAN TELL YOU IS AN IN THAT
WHEN YOU'RE IN AN INCIDENT
COMMAND POSITION. YOU DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO THROUGH
A CROWD AND START PICKING OUT
PEOPLE THAT ASKING QUESTIONS
YOU'RE JUST HAVING YOU GIVE THE
ORDER TO GO CLEAR THE AREA. AND
IF THAT AREAS NOT BEING CLEARED
OR PEOPLE ARE BEING INTERVIEWED
AND SO THEY'RE NOT CLEARING
THAT CREATES A PROBLEM SO THERE
IS A RETIRED FIRE CHIEF AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SERVICE SIR-
JUST FYI THIS SIMPLY RESORTS
BACK TO CURRENT LAW SO WHEN
THERE IS A FIRE AND EARTHQUAKE-
I NASH AND NATURAL DISASTER.
THERE IS UNFETTERED ACCESS EVEN
DURING CURFEW FOR PRESS ZERO
READY HAVE THAT THEY THEY DO
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A DURING
THE FIRST AMENDMENT
DEMONSTRATION IN THAT SAME IF
SIMPLY REVERTS BACK TO WHAT'S
ALREADY UNLOCK RIGHT IN FOR IT
THAT'S RIGHT IT IS THE LAW
ALREADY THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
IN SAFE LOCATIONS DETERMINED BY
THE INCIDENT COMMANDER. THIS
CHALLENGES THAT. WHEN YOU'RE IN
THIS IS IT IS NOT A FIRST
AMENDMENT EXERCISE AT THE POINT
WHERE THEY'RE SAYING. YOU MUST
DISBURSE NOW IT IS NOW THEY'RE
TRYING TO PREVENT A RIOT.
SITUATION OR- OR UNCONTROLLED
CROWD. IN AN ADDON CONTROL
CROWD IF IT DOESN'T DISBURSING
IT STARTS. BEING MORE VIOLENT
THAT'S WHEN THEY BREAK OUT THE
OTHER MEASURES THAT EVERYBODY
IS AGAINST. WHICH ARE LIKE
RUBBER BULLETS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT TO DISPERSE THEM. AND THEN
WHEN PEOPLE GET HURT. BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT DISBURSED THEN GET
TO GET BLANKED THE AGENCY THE
OFFICER THAT THE INCIDENT
COMMANDER WHOEVER IT IS. THE
WAY WE HAVE IT NOW. ALREADY HAD
IT HAS FLAWS BUT THIS IS GOING
TO HELP REINFORCE THOSE FLAWS
IN AND THAT'S WHY I'M OPPOSED
TO IT THANK EIGHT EDGY IN JUST
MISTER BASED HERE IT DOESN'T
CHALLENGE THAT THIS SIMPLY
EXTENDS ACCESS OF FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT OF THE PRESS
TWO DEMONSTRATIONS I JUST WANNA
BE VERY CLEAR I KNOW THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION IN REGARDS TO-
UNFETTERED ACCESS- IN DULY
AUTHORIZED BUT- I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
LAW THAT'S CURRENTLY IN PLACE
THIS THIS BILL. AGAIN MISTER
SOME NUMBER I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR YOUR
SERVICE ESPECIALLY IN FIRE
SERVICER. THIS PARKING. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK MR BUYERS CENTER
WIRE FOR THIS WORK I MEAN HE'S
BEEN AT IT FOR AWHILE. REACHING
HEARING THIS BILL THE SECOND
TIME. IN THE REFORM- BUT I
THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE SEE TODAY MORE THAN IN
MY WHOLE LIFE IS JUST THE
QUESTION OF. WHAT IS TRUE AND
WHAT IS HAPPENING OUT THERE AND
WHERE DOES THE TRUTH LIE AND-
THESE AS DEFINED IN THIS BILL
DO WE AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE NEW
SERVICE ARE THERE TO PROVIDE US
WITH THE TRUTH. AND ACCESS TO
INFORMATION OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING. IN AREAS OF
INCIDENTS AND I THINK THAT IS
SUCH A CRITICAL WORK THAT YOUR
EFFORT TO PROTECT IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT INTO YOUR POINT. THE
CONSTITUTION ALREADY PROTECTS
IT. OF AND WITH THIS IS JEFF
TAKE A STEP FURTHER TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE PROTECTIONS ARE
MEANINGFUL SO- I'M EXCITED TO
SUPPORT IT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MOVED SO I WON'T. THANK YOU
SIMILAR. VERY GRATEFUL OKAY I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO. I'M
GLAD THEY'RE- THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR THANK YOU I JUST GUESS
EIGHT I THANK THE SENATOR FOR
TO WORK ON THIS AND HOPEFULLY
THIS TIME IT DOES GET THE
SIGNATURE OF THE GOVERNOR
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND I THINK WHAT
THIS BILL SIGNIFIES. THE
IMPORTANCE OF OPEN AND FREE
MEDIA AND ALSO INTERESTING OF
THE HAVING THE TRUTH IN THE
WORLD I THINK I REALLY INVITE
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE TO REALLY
CONTEMPLATE THIS YOU KNOW THE
THINGS WE ALWAYS CHASTISE OTHER
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD WHEN
THEY WERE THERE POLICE GO BEAT
UP THE MEDIA AND HIDE THINGS
FROM THEM THAT HAPPENED HERE
THAT DOES HAPPEN HERE IN OUR
STATE AND OUR NATION. AND WE
CANNOT HIDE THE TRUTH FROM THE
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY WHEN IT IS
PLEASE RETALIATES SELF WHEN
THEY SCARE OFF JOURNALISTS WITH
TIVIDALE ARREST THEM THAT'S THE
KIND OF THINGS WE SEE IN OTHER
COUNTRIES MORE AUTHORITARIAN
COUNTRIES WE DECRY AND TO HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABILITY IS TO
PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY THAT'S
ARE REALLY CLOSE TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I'M GLAD
FOR YOUR WORK ON IT THANK YOU
THAT A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE TO-
SOME OF THOSE REMARKS THAT WERE
JUST MADE THAT THERE ARE
TACTICALLY SENSITIVE AREAS THAT
NEED TO BE GUARDED AGAINST- FOR
THE SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. AND I
THINK THAT'S BEEN OVER NOT IN.
IT'S NOT A HARPER. SENATOR IF I
GET THIS TO COME BACK UP IN
YOUR BILL. IT DOES STATE FIRST
OF ALL YOUR SECTION. THAT- THE
PRESS WOULD HAVE. UNFETTERED
ACCESS TO EMERGENCY FIELD
COMMAND POST IT SAYS THAT IN
YOUR BILL. AND I FIND THAT TO
BE VERY VERY TROUBLING. BECAUSE
MANY OF THOSE COMMAND POST THEY
TALK ABOUT HIGHLY SENSITIVE
AREAS- THAT ARE PART OF THE
OPERATION PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC. AND ALSO STATES. IN
YOUR- LANGUAGE OF YOUR BILL.
THAT ANY A DULY AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVE ANY NEW SERVICE
ONLINE NEWS SERVICE NEWSPAPER.
OR RADIO OR TELEVISION STATION
OR NETWORK MAKE ENTERED THE
CLOSED AREA. DESCRIBED AND SOLD
IT DOESN'T LIKE THAT EXAMPLE
THAT AT LEAST IT'S BIT
MISLEADING TO SAY THAT WHEN YOU
GO INTO A BUILDING YOU CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO THE- ENTIRE. STATION
HERE IT SAYS YOU CAN ENTER
WITHIN THE CLOSED ACT. SECTION
AND SO. THERE'S NO REGARD FOR
TACTICALLY SENSITIVE AREAS. AND
I THINK THAT. THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED THE
AMBIGUITY ORDER- THE AMBIGUITY
OVER THE OFFICER'S ABILITY TO
RECOGNIZE ON A ORDER TO
DISPERSE. I WISH THAT THE
PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
THOSE ARE ADVOCATING FOR THIS
MEASURE. WOULD ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCE A RIGHT AND
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT AND
HOW CHAOTIC SCENES ARE. AND THE
OBLIGATION OF LAW ENFORCERS IS
TO RESTORE ORDER AND TO TRY TO
MAKE AN AREA SAFE BECAUSE VERY
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE WHO'S
PRESSING WHO'S NOT PRESS WHEN
YOU GIVE AN ORDER TO DISPERSE
AND I FIND THAT TO BE VERY VERY
TROUBLING AND THAT'S REASON I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL. I'LL
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE
IT THERE'S NO ONE ELSE ELECT
SPEAK. YOU MAY CLOSER THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR- I.
AM VERY GRATEFUL IN RESPECT THE
VICE CHAIR HIS PROFESSION IN
LINE OF WORK PRIOR TO BEING- IN
THE LEGISLATURE OBVIOUSLY WAS
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- WITH THE CHP. I'M
THE ONLY NINE POLICE OFFICER MY
FAMILY. THE ONLY ONE- AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THIS
BILL LITERALLY WOULD MIRROR
WHAT'S ALREADY IN EXISTING LAW.
NUMBER TWO UNFETTERED ACCESS
PRESS RIGHT NOW HAVE UNFETTERED
ACCESS TO A POLICE STATION. NOT
BEYOND THE LOBBY LET'S TALK
COMMON SENSE OF COURSE THEY'RE
NOT GONNA GET INTO A
CONFIDENTIAL AREA IN I WANT TO
END IT WITH THE NUMBERS. FORTY
NINE ARRESTS AND DETAINMENT
THUS FAR IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
PRESS THE DEMONSTRATIONS. RIGHT
NINE JOURNALISTS- AND NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBPOENAED. SEVENTY FIVE
JOURNALISTS WERE ASSAULTED IN
TWENTY TWO JOURNALISTS HAD
THEIR EQUIPMENT DAMAGED I'M ALL
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M GOING TO
BE THE FIRST TO SAY THIS IS A
SMALL MINORITY A SMALL MINORITY
OF THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO MAKE
UP THE RANKS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE STATE IN THIS NATION.
AND WE HAVE A CONSTITUTION FOR
A REASON AND ONE OF THE
CORNERSTONES OF THE COURT'S
CONSTITUTION IS THE FREEDOM OF
THE PRESS AND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPHONE. THANK YOU CENTER AND
I BELIEVE THE CHAIR HAS A DO%
PASS RECOMMENDATION. THAT
THERE'S NO FURTHER COMMENT WILL
CALL FOR THE QUESTION. SB
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR REQUIRE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY NO LACKING NO
BARRICADE HALF. PARA QUE HAN HI
LEE. LEE HI CORK BY CORK I SAN
DIEGO. SAN DIEGO I SEE YOUR
ACCOUNT NOW THE R. TEN NOW
WICKS. THAT'S A LONG ONE THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU. PORTANTINO
YOU RIGHT NOW. ADRESS COMMITTEE.
SB SEVEN FIFTEEN I BELIEVE YES
SIR. SECOND. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUICK MOTION
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN THE BILL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SEEN BEFORE IN
VARIOUS FORMS- WERE ACQUIRED A
DEPARTMENT JUST TO VERIFY THE
VALIDITY OF HUNTING LICENSE
WHEN A PERSON UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE IS USING THE LICENSE
TO PURCHASE FIREARMS UNDER
CURRENT LAW AND TRANSFERRING OR
PURCHASING A FIREARM WITHOUT A
HUNTING LICENSE THERE'S NO
VERIFICATION PROCESS WE
RECENTLY SAW HOW THAT BREAK
DOWN IN COMMUNICATION- LED TO
THE HOW A SYNAGOGUE SHOOTING
WHERE A TEENAGER WAS ABLE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM EVEN THOUGH
THAT TEENAGER HAD AND- INVALID
HUNTING LICENSE THIS BILL SEEKS
TO CORRECT THAT SITUATION. IT
ALSO DEALS WITH AN EXPANSION OF
THE GOOD WORK OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS WHEN POLICE
SHOOT AN UNARMED IT SHOULDN'T
KILL AN UNARMED PERSON
UNFORTUNATELY THAT BILL- DID
NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
THERE'S A DISPUTE OVER WHETHER
THERE IS A WEAPON AND THAT
RECENTLY HAPPENED IN PASADENA
WHERE GERMAN GOT OUT OF A CAR
WAS SHOT AND BOTH THE FAMILY
AND THE POLICE ARE ARGUING
ABOUT WHETHER THERE WAS A
PRESENCE OF A WEAPON THIS BILL
WOULD LET THERE BE AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION IF
THERE'S A CREDIBLE REASONABLE
ARGUMENT OR DISCUSSION OR
DISPUTE. OVER THE PRESENCE OF A
WEAPON SO WITH THOSE TWO PIECES
OF IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. CAN WE DO. SEVENTY
SUPPORT WINDOWS I DON'T THINK
WE ARE WHEN IS HERE IF ANYBODY
HAS TO NEED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OKAY AND I KNOW HOW
MUCH THIS COMMITTEE VALUES ARE
ONCE PRESENCE SO WE WANTED TO
BRING HIM BACK JUST FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OUR K. AND. AS
ANYBODY. ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THIS
ISSUE- OR NEAR WELCOME TO
ENLIGHTEN US IF YOU SO WISH OR
HOW MY GOD. CAN'T THE NOVICES
OF CANTON I WANT TO- WENT HERE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE YEAH I
JUST WANNA MAKE A POINT BECAUSE
THE CONTROVERSY ON THIS BILL IS
ABOUT MINORS. THE WAR ON THIS
AS TO LONG GUNS IS A MAX AND
THERE ARE DIFFERING OPINIONS.
ON WHAT AND IS WHAT IS AND WHAT
IS NOT ALLOWED WHAT THIS BILL
TRIES TO DO IS BASED ON WHAT
THE BEST UNDERSTANDING THE LAW
IS. TO MAKE THE STATUTES
CONSISTENT. WITHOUT ATTACKING
C. R. PA IT'S PRESENT IN HIS
BOOK WHICH- IS THERE BY. MAKE
CERTAIN ASSERTIONS WHICH- ARE
MUCH MORE RESTRICTIVE OF
CURRENT LAW THEN THE GIFFORDS
CAMPAIGN IN ITS BOOKS. SAYS AND
AS A RESULT OF THAT TRYING TO
GET TO AN EQUAL POINT WHERE
MINORS CAN. HAUNT THAN DO THOSE
OTHER THINGS WITHOUT HAVING
UNRESTRICTED ON TRACTABLE
SITUATIONS INVOLVING LONG GUNS
AND MINERS IS WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THE CAME UP BECAUSE OF
THE HUNTING LICENCES ISSUE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WHERE IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT THIS AREA OF
THE LAW WAS A MASS AND WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO. DO WHAT WE
THINK IS COMMON SENSE AND WE
WORK WITH THE VARIOUS HUNTING
GROUPS ON THIS AND THEY ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL OKAY THANK
YOU SIR. OKAY TO THE OPERATOR
IF WE HAVE ANYBODY LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THIS IS THEIR OPPORTUNITY
PLEASE.
THE SUSPENSE IS A
SIGNIFICANT THERE ARE YOU THERE.
AT&T OPERATOR ARE YOU READY TO
YES WE ARE READY AND WE ARE
HERE- FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WILL BEGIN
FLYING TO NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S KATHERINE
JONES I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
ONE FIVE THANK YOU. NINE THREE
NAME IS STEVE WALSH ON THE
TERMINAL B. ALAMEDA COUNTY GOT
ORDERS ON. ASSOCIATION OF THE-
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN ONE
FIVE THANK YOU. ONE THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
LOCAL AUTO VOLUNTEER LEADER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE THE COURT. NINETY THREE
FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DARREN BUT
WELL I'M A MEMBER OF THE NRA
AND CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL TO
THE STATION CALLING IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN ONE FIVE
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER-
TO SHOW SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR
SB. THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL LINE THREE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE'S GOT A
GOOD AFTERNOONS CHAIRMAN BURST
RANCHERA 3% SURE SOLICITATION
MORE COURT THANKS ARE
PORTANTINO'S MEASURE THAT
ADDRESSING THE- QUESTION ABOUT
WEAPONS AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS THE- POLICE
OFFICERS. FROM THE FOLLOWING
SERIES CLAREMONT CORONA
HOMEOWNERS CULTURE YOU THE EACH
OF ONE OF ANNA BURBANK
INGLEWOOD ARCADIA RIVERSIDE
FULLERTON. COVERT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LOCATION COALITION.
FIFTY PROFESSIONALS AND ALSO
YEAH TO BE SURE FOR THE THANK
YOU. THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ALEX TO THE
BAKER NOT A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THE NRA AND THE
WELL ARMED WOMAN AND AYE
OPPOSED SENATE BILL. SEVEN
FIFTEEN. ONE THREE SIXTEEN
EUROPE. MY NAME STATE ROAD-
MEMORY LIFE MEMBER I'M ALSO
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER CHAIR AND
THE U. S. NAVY VETERAN AND I'M
STRONGLY URGING YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS SPEECH SEVEN FIFTEEN AM
TWO SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CARLENE ELLIS I'M A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL DEFENSIVE PISTOL
SHOOTERS ASSOCIATION I DON'T
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
ONE FIVE THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
DO I SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO IT SB SEVEN ONE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
WE WILL AND WE CAN. GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS REBECCA THANK YOU
ISRAEL AND THE BOARD NUMBER OF
BRADY ORANGE COUNTY AND- THE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION COALITION
OF ORANGE COUNTY AND- I
SUPPORT- BUILD SEVENTEEN AS
WELL AS BUILT TO SIXTY FOUR.
RICH BUSINESSES FIND TWO SIX.
YOU JUST OUTLINED TO SIXTY ONE
YOUR. MY TO SIXTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. YES THIS IS SERVICE
DEMOCRAT I'M REALLY SURE
ABILITY TO SELL STOCK MELT-
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
DISASSOCIATION AND ALREADY
MEMBER AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS FED YOU DID
ON A LIFE MEMBER OF THE NRA AND
THE C. R. NAY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SEVEN ONE FIVE. AND
THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THE SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
FIVE. THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
STANLEY WITH THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION IN
MARIN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND
MR SURE WE HAVE ONE MORE WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE TO FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE SCARY BRIAN WITH THE
SENDING COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION ON THE PRESIDENT
REPRESENTING TWENTY THOUSAND
SAN DIEGANS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THAT SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN THANK YOU. FIND THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
SIGN JAMES WESTPHAL MEMBER OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY GUN OWNERS
ASSOCIATION- CHAPTER OF THE RPA
OF NON MEMBERS IN OUR A AND THE
CALIFORNIA GUN OWNERS WHEN I-
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HI MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. THERE MAY BE SOME
I THINK WE HAVE. A COUPLE
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
AUDIENCE MAY STEP TO THE MIKE.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN ROY GRIFFIN
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
SOLICITATION ARE THIRTY SOME
THOUSAND MEMBERS ROCK
CALIFORNIA MANY OF YOU KNOW I
MEAN OUR THIRTY TWO YEARS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE LAST TEN
YEARS OF MY CAREER MY JOB WAS
REVIEWING LEGISLATION AS IT
IMPACTED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
SO I'VE NEVER PROFESSED TO BE
THE SHARPEST TOOL IN THE SHED
BUT I HAVE REVIEWED LEGISLATION
OVER THE YEARS. AND I'VE NEVER
FACED ANYTHING IS CONVOLUTED
AND JUST TWIST THIS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OUR GOAL AND
INSTALL RESPECT TO THIS DYESS
AND ALL THE FOLKS ON THE DIESS
IS TO MAKE LEGISLATION RULES
THAT PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND AND
FOLLOW THIS ONE MAKE SURE HEAD
SPIN AND STARTED OUT WITH A
GOOD IDEA JUST MAYBE FIGURE OUT
WHAT I NEED A LAWFUL FISHING OR
HUNTING LICENCES. TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OF THE GAME WARDEN I
NEVER NEEDED A DATABASE TO COST
MULTIMILLION. WE CAN APARTMENT
FISHING WILDLIFE. AND APARTMENT
A JUSTICE TO TELL ME WHAT A
VALID HUNTING LICENCES I JUST
WAS ABLE TO. PICK UP A LICENSE
LOOK AT THE ISSUE DATE OR THE
EXPIRATION DATE AND THAT WAS
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME. THIS
TRAGEDY IN SAN DIEGO. WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE SENATOR.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT CHANGE THAT
THANK YOUNG TWISTED INDIVIDUAL
JUST HAD TO IT WHO WAS TOLD SHE
HAD BEEN TOLD THAT LICENSE WAS
NOT VALID. BECAUSE HE BOUGHT
NEXT YEAR'S LICENSE. ONLY HAD
TO DO WAS WALK BACK INTO BIG
FIVE. BY THIS YEAR'S LICENSE GO
BACK INTO A GUN STORE THAT GOT
TWISTED INDIVIDUAL COULD HAVE
DID WHAT HE DID. OR COULD
WAITED TWO WEEKS TOLD LICENSE
WAS VALID AND THEN. PURCHASE
THAT FAR. SO WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT WE STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL LET'S
MAKE LEGISLATION OF X. RULES
THAT ARE. THAT CAN BE
UNDERSTOOD. AND FOLLOWED AND
NOT JUST MAKE THE BOOK EVEN
MORE COMPLICATED THANK. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS APPARATUS- ON
BEHALF OF GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND- THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION. WHAT I HAVE
HERE IN MY HAND IS A- EXPIRED
CALIFORNIA HUNTING LICENSE ON
TAMPER PROOF- MATERIAL THAT IS
ISSUED EVERY TIME SOMEBODY BUYS
A HUNTING LICENSE RIGHT AT THE
TOP IT SAYS VALID. 081-720-2206
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THERE
IS NO NEED AT AND WE AGREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR EVEN THOUGH A-
HIGH GRADE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION HAS BEEN SET FOR
TWO POINT TWENTY FIVE. THERE IS
NO NEED TO SPEND THAT KIND OF
MONEY ANDTHE RESOURCES AND THE
PERSONNEL THE P. WHY YOU'RE
GOING TO BE REQUIRED. TO
OPERATE A SYSTEM SO THAT EVERY
TIME- SOMEONE NEEDS TO VERIFY A
HUNTING LICENSE TO PURCHASE.
FOR PURCHASING A FIREARM
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. IT'S NOT
NECESSARY THAT THAT IS A
MASSIVE WASTE OF GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES ANOTHER PROBLEM WE
HAVE WITH THIS BILL IS THAT IT
ALLOWS. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO CHARGE ADDITIONAL
FEES- ON TOP OF THE- AMMUNITION
AND PRECURSOR PARTS- LAST I SAW
IT WAS OWNED BY THE WAY MR ONE.
THE BIBLE IS MY BIBLE NOT SHOP
WHICH SELLS BOOK SO- WORD
STRONG OPPOSITION OFTENTIMES WE
CALL THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND ASK THEM A
QUESTION ABOUT A STATUTE THAT
WAS PASSED AND SIGNED INTO LAW.
AND WHAT IT MEANS AND HOW IT
AFFECTS PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY TELL US. A 100% OF
THE TIME. CALL YOUR LAWYER.
WELL WE CALLED OUR LAWYERS AND
WE'VE ASKED THEM TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND THEIR EYES ARE SWIMMING
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT EVERYTHING
ALL OF THE NUANCES ALL OF WHAT
OF WHAT THIS MEANS IS HOW THIS
IS GOING TO AFFECT PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS ALREADY
CONFUSING ENOUGH AND THIS IS
GONNA THROW THEM IN THE TERM
ALL WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IT WOULD ANYONE ELSE IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO- IN OPPOSITION
WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. NOT VERY DID OKAY I'M SO
ARE WE NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE I'M ALL CAUGHT UP NOW.
WHO HAS A QUESTION CONCERNED
COMMENT SEEING NONE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I LIKE IT WHEN YOU'RE ALL
CAUGHT UP. IF NOT YOU KNOW.
THIS BILL IS BEEN THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE. I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION.
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA SAFE WE NEED TO
DO EVERYTHING. WE CAN TO KEEP
GUNS OUT OF THE WRONG HANDS-
THIS BODY HAS SUPPORTED THOSE
EFFORTS IN THE PAST- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS
CONVERSATION GETS LOST I MEAN I
FEEL LIKE SOMETIMES IF. THERE
IS A BILL THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T
BRING A BAZOOKA INTO FIRST
GRADE PEOPLE WOULD OPPOSE IT
BECAUSE THEY WOULD SAY IT WAS
AN INFRINGEMENT. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO BE REASONABLE WE HAVE
TO TAKE PRUDENT STEPS AND I
THINK THIS BILL TAKES PRUDENT
STEPS IN BOTH AREAS. BOTH IN
THE CONTINUATION OF ASSEMBLY
MCCARTY SEPARATE AND THEN ALSO
TO KEEP WEAPONS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE FOLKS WHO DON'T
HAVE ALLEN HUNTING LICENCES AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS USER BEEN A MOTION AND
SECOND. OKAY THE JURORS
RECOMMEND HIGH CALL THE ROLL.
AND SB SEVEN FIFTEEN BY CENTER
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER CONSIDER
IRAQI LACKEY NOT VOTING BARRACK
HE HAD BACKING AND I LEVY WE
ARE A CORK HI MARK I SANTIAGO.
C. R. TELL NO THEY ARE TURNOUT
WICKS. BILLS ON CALL NEEDS ONE
MORE THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE WE ONLY HAVE TWO MORE
PILLS AND I WE HAVE WANTED THE
AUTHOR HERE'S SENATOR MA'AM. S.
B. EIGHT SIX TWO FOUR MEN
FIREARMS STATE PROPERTY SIX
PEOPLE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I RISE TO PRESENT TO
U. S. B. TWO SIXTY FOUR WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT THE STATE IS
NOT PROFITING FROM THE SALE OF
FIREARMS AMMUNITION AND FIREARM
PRECURSOR PARTS ALSO KNOWN AS
GHOST GUNS. OF ON STATE
PROPERTY OR BY FACILITATING GUN
SHOWS THAT COULD UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA STRONG FIREARM
REGULATIONS. EARLY LAST YEAR
YOU MAY REMEMBER THE WEEKEND
WHEN WE HAD THE EL PASO
SHOOTINGS- THAT WEEKEND WE HAD
EXPLAINED THAT MY YOUNG
CHILDREN. NOT YET AGAIN ABOUT
THE TRAGEDIES AND DANGERS OF
GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS COUNTRY-
THE NEXT MORNING SUNDAY MORNING
WE WOKE UP TO LEARN THERE'S
BEEN ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING IN
DAYTON OHIO- THIS IS PERSONAL
TO ME BECAUSE MY WIFE HAS
FAMILY IN DAYTON. AND A NUMBER
OF COUSINS WHO ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF DAYTON AND THEN
ACTUALLY FREQUENT IN THE BAR
WHERE THE SHOOTING TOOK PLACE.
WE TO MAKE A NUMBER OF ANXIOUS
PHONE CALLS THAT MORNING TO
FAMILY TO MAKE SURE THAT SURE
THEY'RE ALL OK. LUCKILY FOR US-
THEY WERE. AS IT HAPPENED ON
THAT MORNING THEIR SCHEDULE DO
A FAMILY FUN RUN FIVE K. ON OUR
LOCAL ORANGE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS. AS WE PASSED THE
FINISH LINE ALL OF US INCLUDING
MY THEN EIGHT YEAR OLD SIX YEAR
OLD AND THREE YEAR OLD. WERE
HANDED FLYERS OFFERING US FREE
ADMISSION TO THE GUN SHOWS
HAPPENING THE FOLLOWING
WEEKEND. NOW WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP THE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS WERE
KNOWN FOR BEING FAMILY
FRIENDLY. IN ADDITION TO THE
COUNTY FAIR EACH YEAR THAT HAVE
RODEOS THINGS LIKE FOUR H.
EVENTS CONCERTS CIRCUSES. AND
OTHER FAMILY FRIENDLY FARE. BUT
TODAY GUN SHOWS IN THE CITY CAL
I MEAN SORT COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
KNOWN PRIMARILY FOR GUNSHOWS.
THE AVERAGE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
ACROSS THE STATE HOSTS FIVE GUN
SHOWS A YEAR. MEINE ORANGE
COUNTY TYPICALLY HOSTS EIGHT TO
TWELVE GUN SHOWS EACH YEAR. AND
CONTRARY TO THE CLAIMS OF
PROPONENTS OF THESE GUN SHOWS.
THEY'RE ANYTHING BUT FAMILY
FRIENDLY. IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN
TO ONE OF THESE YOU'LL KNOW
THAT THEIR HOT BEDS OF
EXTREMIST SENTIMENT. IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR T. SHIRTS
EMBLAZONED WITH- A NOT SO
SUBTLE VEILED THREATS AGAINST
POLITICIANS- WITH A LOT OF F.
BOMBS AND OTHER- OBSCENE
LANGUAGE. THIS IS THE PLACE TO
GO. AT THAT TIME I WAS RUNNING
FOR THIS SEAT I NOW HOLD AND IF
I VOWED THAT IF I ENDED UP
BEING ELECTED I WOULD WORK TO
END GUN SHOWS. ON SAY PROPERTY
ORANGE COUNTY AND ACROSS THE
STATE. I PROPONENTS OF THESE
COUNTRIES CLAIM THAT THEY'RE
SAFE AND DON'T SELL ANY ILLEGAL
FIREARMS BUT THIS IS SIMPLY NOT
TRUE. GUN SHOWS ARE SENSUALLY A
FLEA MARKET FOR FIREARMS THEIR
PRIMARY MECHANISM BY WHICH
UNLICENSED UNREGISTERED AND
ILLEGAL FIREARMS. OR TRAFFIC
THROUGH SECONDARY MARKETS. MY
STAFF AND I ATTENDED A GUN SHOW-IN THE DISTRICT A FEW MONTHS
AGO AND WHILE THEY'RE WAITING
IN LINE TO GET IN THEY WERE
INUNDATED WITH OFFERS TO
PURCHASE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
WEAPONS BY PEOPLE WORKING THE
LINES. AND THIS IS NOT UNIQUE
TO MY STAFF ORANGE COUNTY.
ACCORDING TO GIFFORDS LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
GUN SHOWS OFTEN CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CIRCUMVENT GUN
SAFETY LAWS AND ARE COMMON
VENUE FOR STRAW PURCHASES AND
LEGAL GUN TRANSFERS. AN ATF
REPORT ALSO THIS HAS DESCRIBED
GUN SHOWS AS A MAJOR
TRAFFICKING CHANNEL. FOUND THE
GUN SHOWS WERE THE SECOND
LARGEST SOURCE OF ILLEGALLY
TRAFFICKED FIREARMS. IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT WHILE I WISH I
COULD CITE MORE STATISTICS
UNITED STATES SIGNIFICANT
RESTRICTS LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE GUN
CRIMES AND PROSECUTE DO THAT HI
HOW ARE AMENDMENTS. IT IS
WIDELY BELIEVED THOUGH THAT GUN
SHOWS ARE MAJOR CONDUIT PERHAPS
THE MAJOR CONDUIT NOT ONLY FOR
THESE ON LICENSE AND LEGAL GUNS
BUT ALSO FOR THE SALE OF GHOST
GUNS. PRECURSOR GUN PARTS
DESIGNED TO BE ASSEMBLED INTO A
WORKING FIREARM. BECAUSE THESE
GHOST GUNS ARE NOT TECHNICALLY
FIREARMS THEY DON'T HAVE SERIAL
NUMBERS AND ARE NOT REGISTERED
AT THE TIME OF SALE. IN THE
WHEN I VISITED GUN SHOW A FEW
MONTHS AGO THE MOST POPULAR
VENDORS BY FAR WITH ONE SELLING
GHOST GUN KITS. DESIGNED TO
TURN IN A FIREARMS AKIN TO
GLOCK PISTOLS AND A R. FIFTEEN
RIFLES. THEY WERE THEY COULD BE
PURCHASED CASHIN KERRY AND
TAKEN RIGHT OFF OF THE LOT. BUT
I WILL ALSO SUBMIT TO YOU THAT
EVEN IF THEY WERE ZERO SALES OF
ILLEGAL OR UNLICENSED GUNS. OR
GHOST GUNS. WE SHOULD STILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND THAT IS
BECAUSE GUN SHOWS ARE DESIGNED
FOR ONE PURPOSE. TO SELL GUNS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THEY
ARE INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE AT
THAT PURPOSE. AND THIS IS SUCH
A DEADLY DEADLY PROBLEM. AS
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN.
MORE GUNS MEANS MORE GUN
VIOLENCE. YOU CAN LOOK THIS UP
THE HARVARD HARVARD BUREAU OF
INJURY CONTROL- JOURNAL
INTERCOLLEGIATE STUDIES AND
MANY OTHER STUDIES. COUNTRIES
WITH MORE GUNS HAVE MORE GUN
VIOLENCE. STATES WITH MORE GUNS
HAVE MORE GUN VIOLENCE.
HOUSEHOLDS WITH MORE GUNS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE GUN
VIOLENCE. NOW SINCE THAT
WEEKEND WHEN WE HAD THE EL PASO
IN DAYTON SHOOTINGS THAT
WEEKEND WHEN I VOWED TO END GUN
SHOWS. IN THE STATE AND COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS WE'VE HAD HUNDREDS
OF MASS SHOOTINGS. INCLUDING
THE MASS SHOOTING PREVIOUSLY IN
SAN JOSE. THE MASS SHOOTING IN
ORANGE IN MY DISTRICT EARLIER
THIS YEAR. OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
INCLUDING THE NINE VICTIMS OF
THE RECENT MASS SHOOTING IN SAN
JOSE. THE SHOOTINGS OF FOUR
PEOPLE ANYONE SHOOTING I
MENTIONED AND SIX YEAR OLD ETAN
LEOS WHO WAS MURDERED IN MY
DISTRICT BY SOMEONE WHO IS
APPARENTLY HAVING ROAD RAGE ON
THE FIFTY FIVE. EACH OF THESE
VIOLENT DEATHS FOR A MASSIVE
HOLE IN THEIR FAMILIES. IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AMONG THEIR
LOVED ONES. NOW PROPONENTS OF
GUN SHOWS ARGUE THAT ENDING GUN
SHOWS WILL DEPRIVE THEM OF
REVENUE BUT I WILL POINT OUT
THAT THIS IS JUST A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE REVENUE
GENERATED BY THE FAIRGROUNDS.
AND IT IS INDISPUTABLE THAT THE
COSTS OF GUN VIOLENCE ARE
ASTRONOMICALLY HIGHER. IN FACT-
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
ESTIMATED THE COST ANNUAL COSTS
OF GUN VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA
OR SIX POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT IS
EXPONENTIALLY MORE THAN THE
REVENUE THE SMALL AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
THESE GUN SHOWS IN THE STATE.
THE OPPOSITION ALSO CLAIMS THAT
THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR AND THAT
WE SHOULD LEAVE THIS UP TO
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS. AS A MATTER
OF LOCAL CONTROL. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT IF IT AS TRUE BUT IF YOU
TALK TO BOARD MEMBERS OF COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS. THEY WILL TELL YOU
THEY HAVE NO FIDUCIARY DUTIES
TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. THEIR
SOLE FIDUCIARY DUTY LIES WITH
ENSURING THE SOLVENCY THERE
DROUGHT FAIRGROUNDS AND
MAXIMIZING REVENUE. AS THEY
WILL TELL YOU THEY'RE OBLIGATED
TO CONTRACT WITH GUN SHOW
OPERATORS NO MATTER WHAT THE
PREFERENCES OF LOCAL COMMUNITY.
AND THAT THEREFORE THE ONLY
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM IS SAY
REGULATION. I ALSO WANT TO PUSH
BACK ON THIS OR EVEN A LOCAL
CONTROL AS A MATTER OF
PRINCIPLE BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY INSTANCES WHERE WE DECIDE
THERE ARE CERTAIN STATEWIDE
VALUES. THAT WE WANT TO PROMOTE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT LOCALS MAY
THINK. WE REQUIRE THAT CHILDREN
BE VACCINATED REQUIRES THAT
WORKPLACES BE SAFE FROM
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT. REQUIRE
THE CERTAIN HEALTH ND LABOR
STANDARDS BE MET. AND WE DO
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT SOME
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MAY
DISAGREE WITH OUR STATEWIDE
STANDARDS AND MANDATES. WELL I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
VALUE THAT WE'RE MAKING TODAY
VALUE STATEMENT. WHAT WE'RE
SAYING TODAY IS THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE SANCTIONING. AND
ENDORSING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
GUNS INTO OUR COMMUNITIES OUT
OF STATE PROPERTY. NOW A NUMBER
OF FOLKS HAVE ALSO RAISED THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS A CONCERN
AND I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR. I
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE SECOND
AMENDMENT. THIS IS NOT AFFECT
THE RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS BY
INDIVIDUALS- IT MERELY SAYS
THAT THE STATE WILL NOT BE PART
OF THAT DISSEMINATION OF GUNS
IN OUR COMMUNITY. THE SECOND
AMENDMENT EXISTS IN OUR
CONSTITUTION IT ALLOWS FOR THE
REASONABLE REGULATION OF GUNS-
THE RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS. BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE TENTH
AMENDMENT THAT PRESERVES THE
RIGHTS THOSE RIGHTS OF THE
STATES. THAT ARE NOT EXPLICITLY
RESERVE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND CERTAINLY IT IS WITHIN THE
AUSPICES THE TENTH AMENDMENT TO
SAY THAT WE CAN DO WHAT WE WANT
WITH OUR OWN. PROPERTY AND I
THINK THAT THIS THE VIOLENCE
THAT MENTION WHICH IS RAVAGING
OUR STATE WEATHER IN. SANTA
BARBARA SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND
SANTA ANA. SAN DIEGO COMPTON
YUBA CITY STOCKTON ORANGE
CITRUS HEIGHTS. SAN JOSE AND
MANY OTHERS. GIVES US GOOD
REASON TO MAKE THIS WHAT
HAPPENED TO DRAW A LINE IN THE
SAND. AND SAY THAT THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
PROFIT OFF THE SALE OF GUNS. IT
WILL NOT AID IN DISSEMINATING
MORE GUNS AND THE RESULTING GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WITH ME TODAY I'VE STEVE
LANGLEY FORMER CHIEF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S BUREAU FIREARMS. AND
A MEMBER OF BRADY ORANGE COUNTY
AS WELL AS CHARLIE BLACK. WHO
IS PERSONALLY AFFECTED BY GUN
VIOLENCE ALSO MEMBER BRADY
ORANGE COUNTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU JOHN YOU HAVE
OF FIVE MINUTES TOTAL- WHOEVER
MUST BEGIN FIRST. WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHARLES
BLACK. I'M A PAST PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT BOARD MEMBER OF BRADY
ORANGE COUNTY. WHO MY
REPRESENTED. I AM RETIRED
ATTORNEY THANK INTO THIS ISSUE
FOR THE GUN DEATH OF MY SON. WE
WISH TO THANK SATURDAY MAN FOR
HIS PLEDGE TO ADDRESS THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. WHY IN THE
WORLD OR RE SUPPORTING GUN
SHOWS THAT STATE OWNED PROPERTY
THE TAXPAYERS MONEY WELL WE ARE
DEALING WITH THE GRIEF OF GUN
VIOLENCE VICTIMS IN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE PURCHASE OF A FIREARM
IS LITERALLY A GREAT DECISION
AND SHOULD BE DONE IN A MORE
APPROPRIATE SHETTY. PLAN SHOWS
ARE A NOISY WITH OUR NOISY WITH
A CARNIVAL LIKE ATMOSPHERE. THE
MASS. SHOWING A FIREARMS AND
THE PROMOTION OF SAYING THAT
THESE EVENTS AT STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES FOR FAMILY
ENTERTAINMENT OFTEN TAKES PLACE
CREATES THE APPEARANCE THE
STATE GIVES THEM LESS OF THE
PRINCIPAL OF SUCH SALES.
CERTAINLY THE PRE ADMISSION OF
OFTEN OFFERED HER CHILDREN TO
ATTEND WITH A PARENT GIVES ONE
PAUSE. PUBLISHED RESEARCH HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE FOR YEARS AND
BRINGING A FIREARM INTO THE
HOME CONCRETIONS THE RISK OF
SUICIDE HOMICIDE AND
UNINTENTIONAL SHOOTINGS- THAT
HOME. AND YET HERE WE ARE WITH
THE GUN SHOWS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE MASS
SELLING THE FIREARMS AMMUNITION
AND PRECURSOR FIREARMS. THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ADDITIONALLY AND
NOT PARADOXICALLY THE SAME
TAXPAYERS PICK UP THE TAB OF
SIX POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL COSTS OF GUN VIOLENCE
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ENSUES.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THEN THE MASS
SELLING AND PROMOTION OF
FIREARMS PRECURSOR GUN PARTS
AMMUNITION AMMUNITION ON STATE
OWNED PROPERTIES THE STATE
SHOULD NOT BE COMPLICIT WITH
SUCH ACTIVITIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I WILL GO TO ANY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT. SHE NINE WILL GO TO
TELECONFERENCING. C. NONE THANK
YOU SO OPERATOR EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATE COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
SIX FOUR MEN. TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZEROS THE
TIME AND WE WILL ALIGN I TWO
EIGHTY THREE MISTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CAROL RAFA BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SALON A BEACH ACCORDING TO
THE. I AM THRILLED SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE RED
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. JUST ONE
THREE CAN YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS
ABOUT THE TICKET YOUR BROW-
FROM BRADY ORANGE COUNTY AND
THE VIOLENCE PREVENTION
COMMISSION ORANGE COUNTY AND
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS ISSUE THERE ARE
SOME OF THE PRESIDENT KENNEDY
FOR A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. WINE TO SIXTY
YOU ARE OPEN. I. TO SIXTY. I'M
MORE TRYLINE TO SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIVING A LONG LINE THREE
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NEEDED KAREN LAWCENTER AND I'M
WITH THE WOMEN FOR AMERICAN
VALUES AND ETHICS AND THE
CONCERNED CITIZEN IN ORANGE
COUNTY I LIVE IN YOUR BLENDER I
SUPPORT SB TWO SIX FOUR. AND MR
SURE- YES MORE PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FOR ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B.
TWO SIX FOUR. AND AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO SIX FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. THIS
AND WE WILL GO TO. LINE THREE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE
ELEVEN. ELEVEN CAN YOU HEAR US.
NINE THREE ELEVEN COMMUTERS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M MOVING
ALONG WE WILL GO TO. I'M SO
SORRY IT'S- A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
QUEUING UP. YES HELLO THIS IS
JILL COOPER FROM NEVER AGAIN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU THREE
ELEVEN WE WILL GO TO LINE THREE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS AMY CAPELLI WHEN
WOMEN ARE FOR AMERICAN VALUES
AND ETHICS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. ONE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M MOVING ON WITH A LINE THREE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S MICHAEL MAYER AND
CONCERNED CITIZEN OF ORANGE
COUNTY. AND- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THAT B. TWO SIX FOUR. NINE
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS PAULETTE
STUDEBAKER AMADOR COUNTY AND I
AM A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE PISTOL ASSOCIATION THE
NRA AND THE WELL ARMED WOMAN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE TWO SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TWO
NINETY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
THANK YOU THIS IS SUSAN MILLER
CALLING FROM ASIAN AMERICANS IN
ACTION IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT SB TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU. NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
PAPER BENHAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIREARMS STRATEGY
GROUP. AND WOMEN KERR MERICAN
VALUABLE I THINK THE COURT
EVENT BE TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FIVE THREE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
SIXTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. R. ONE
MORE TRY THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD TO SHOW SUPPORT. HELLO
YES YOUR OFFICER. YOU MAY BEGIN.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. MOVING
ALONG WITH A LINE THREE
THIRTEEN PLEASE FOLLOW AT. I'M
IRISH SHARP WITH NEVER AGAIN CA
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I'M
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO SIX FOUR. ONE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS DEBBIE WILDER I'M
WHERE I NEED TO BE TITLE AND
WOMEN CLOSELY. ENOUGH SEPARATE
DEALINGS COUNTY CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THREE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THREE THIRTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. ONE MORE TRY IN
LINE NOW THREE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ALONG
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS AND GORDINIER AND I'M
WITH WOMEN FOR AMERICAN VALUES
AND ETHICS AND I'M CONCERNED
CITIZENS FROM NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB SIX
TO SIXTY FOUR VERY STRONGLY.
WOW MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY WE NOW TO HEAR
FROM OPPOSITION WITNESSES. IN
THE INNER IN THE ROOM- RIGHT
GRIFFIN'S CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION IN PERSON
AND SAMPRAS GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH IN PERSON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SAMPRAS-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF GUN
OWNERS OF CALIFORNIAN ALSO
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
TO START FIRST OF ALL THE
SENATOR- SHOULD I THINK REALIZE
THAT THE- FAIRGROUNDS ARE NOT
OWNED BY THE STATE THEY ARE
OWNED BY ALL THE TAXPAYERS NOT
JUST THE LOCAL TAXPAYERS BUT
ALL THE TAXPAYERS OF UNITED OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO IF
WE GO ALONG THE LINE THAT
YOU'RE GOING WE SHOULD BE
BANNING CAR SHOWS SINCE THEY
ARE THE NUMBER ONE- THE MIRRORS
OF GOAL OF GLOBAL WARMING WE
SHOULD BE BANNING CONCERTS THAT
HAVE OFFENSIVE LANGUAGE THAT
HAVE- THAT ARE ARE ARE. ARE AT
HELD AT THE SHOWS. THE ONLY
FRIENDLY TO SOMEONE IT IS TO
SOMEONE IT ISN'T- WITH REGARDS
TO GUN SHOWS GUN SHOWS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
BEEN PRESENTED. AND TESTIFY TO
IN THIS COMMITTEE MANY TIMES
FOR MANY YEARS. ARE THE SAFEST
GUN SHOWS IN THE ENTIRE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WOULD COME HERE IN THE
PAST AND TESTIFIED. THAT THEY
HAVE HAD AGENTS AT GUN SHOWS
AND WE HAVEN'T HAD A CRIME
COMMITTED IN A GUN SHOW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN A VERY
LONG TIME ALL OF THE STUDIES
THAT YOU THAT YOU MENTION NONE
OF THEM REFER TO CALIFORNIA ANY
INCIDENCES IN CALIFORNIA. NOT A
SINGLE ONE AND THEY ARE. THEY
ARE A FOR LACK OF BETTER TERMS
EPIDEMIOLOGY LOGICAL. IN THE
SENSE THAT THEY SHOW A
CORRELATION OR ASSOCIATION BUT
THEY DO NOT SHOW CAUSATION
THAT'S LIKE SAYING THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO INVESTIGATE
FIREFIGHTERS BECAUSE THEY SHOW
UP EVERY TIME THERE'S A FIRE
THERE'S A FIREFIGHTER AROUND
YES THERE'S A CORRELATION BUT
THAT ISN'T THE COST THE SAME IS
TRUE WITH THIS. ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE BOUGHT NEW
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PURCHASE FIREARMS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO NOT
BECAUSE THEY WERE FORCED TO
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO EVERY
SALE AT A GUN SHOW GOES THROUGH
EXACTLY THE SAME PROCESS THAT
THEY GO THROUGH A BRICK AND
MORTAR STORE. WHETHER IT'S FOR
PRECURSOR PARTS AMMUNITION OR
FIREARMS. THIS IS WAY TOO LONG
WE HAVE SIGNIFICAN NIGHT- I
THINK THE ANALYSIS DOES A
PRETTY GOOD JOB OF POINTING
OUT. SOME OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES THAT YOU HAVEN'T IF YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD OF MCDONALD
VERSUS CHICAGO THAT'S A CASE
THAT INCORPORATED THE SECOND
AMENDMENT. AGAINST CITIES AND
STATES WHICH IN ESSENCE TOOK IT
OUT OF THE PURVIEW OF THE TENTH
AMENDMENT. SO THAT'S A THAT'S A
RULE FROM THE SUPREME COURT OF
THE UNITED STATES- MAYBE SOME
CIVICS LESSONS ARE IN ORDER
THANK YOU WE SIX. SINCERELY
ASK- FOR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROY GROUP IS
SPEAKING ON THE UP THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- I'D MISTER CHAIRMAN
I KNOW WE DON'T ALWAYS SEE EYE
TO EYE IN AND MANY OF US ON.
THAT ON THE DIETS DON'T SEE EYE
TO EYE WITH WITH RELIEF I THINK
ONE THING WE CAN ALL AGREE ON.
IS FOR THIS TO WORK WE HAVE TO
SPEAK THE TRUTH AND THIS BILL
HAS BEEN GOING ON IN VARIOUS
FORMS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND THE TESTIMONY. THAT IS
BEING SHARED IS NOT TRUTHFUL
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS VERY
QUICKLY WITHOUT GOING INTO
DETAILS. I HAVE OVER TWENTY
FIVE PUBLIC RECORD
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUEST THAT WE
SEE RPA HAVE. DELIVERED I'M
JUST READ THE ENTITIES THAT WE
DELIVER THESE REQUEST TO OVER
THE SPAN OF THE LAST- FIVE
SEVEN PLUS YEARS. NONE OF WHICH
RETURNED ANY INFORMATION OF ONE
VIOLATION OF ONE OF THESE
NEFARIOUS ACTS OF AN ILLEGAL
GUN SALE OR ON ACT INVOLVING A
FIREARM AT A GUN SHOW. NOTHING
CAME BACK WE SOME REQUEST TO.
THE DOJ ORANGE COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS ORANGE COUNTY FAIR
BOARD DELMARK BILLBOARD DEL MAR
FAIR BOARD AGAIN IN AND THIS
IS- IN JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE COW PALACE. IN JUNE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
PART OF AGRICULTURE. IN AUGUST
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN ATTORNEY
GENERAL BECERRA IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DEL MAR BOARD.
THE END SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DEL MAR BORED AGAIN
AND OCTOBER OF EIGHTEEN.
GOVERNOR BROWN IN OCTOBER AND
AUGUST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. IN OCTOBER IN-
AUGUST OFTWENTY TWENTY ONE
VENTURA FAIR BOARD. IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN SAN MATTEO
SHERIFF. SAN DIEGO COUNTY SURE
ORANGE. CITY COUNCIL IN- MARCH
OF TWENTY NINETEEN COW PALACE
IN APRIL OF TWENTY NINETEEN SAN
DIEGO SHERIFF IN JUNE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE COW PALACE AGAIN.
IN JULY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
ORANGE COUNTY FAIR BOARD JULY
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. NOW ALL THE
WAY BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
ALL THESE INFORMATION REQUEST
YIELDED NOT ONE. RECORD OF AYE
ILLEGAL GUN SALE GOING ON ON
THE SHOWS I WOULD WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO CENTER. AND HIS
STAND OF NOT MAKING ANY MONEY
IN CALIFORNIA OFF GUN SALES.
THEN WHY ARE WE AS GUN OWNERS
PAYMENT TWENTY SOME PERCENT IN
SALES TAX RIGHT NOW ON A FARM.
AND WISER MEMBER IN THIS
BUILDING ONE AN ADDITIONAL 11%
SALE ON FARMS. IF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T WANT TO MAKE
ANY MONEY OFF NADIE GUN
PERFORMERS SO. THIS THIS THE
COST OF THESE LIES ANGERSTEIN A
WIN AND IT'S IF WE COULD JUST
TESTIFIED TO THE TRUTH I THINK
WE COULD ALL. COME TO
UNDERSTAND WE ALL WANT IN GUN
VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT ON
THE BACKS OF LAWFUL GUN. OWNERS
WHO GO TO THE SHOWS. THEN THEY
FAMILY FRIENDLY OF THE- I AS A
P. OFFICER I WORK THE
CALIFORNIA EXPOSED FOR MANY
YEARS. AND PEOPLE HAVE A GREAT
TIME THERE. GONSALES ARE
BLESSED AND 20% AND AMMUNITION
GUNS AND AMMUNITION COMBINED IS
LESS THAN 20% BUSHELS PEOPLE
GOING TO BUY CLIMAX. TO GET
INFORMATION ON CAMPING THREE
INFORMATION ON FISHING
EQUIPMENT SO ON. THIS IS SPEAK
THE TRUTH LET'S JUST TEST BY
THE TRUTH AND LET'S FIND SOME
COMMON GROUND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. A DIRT ANY OTHERS
WITHIN THEIR IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. TO LIKE TO DO ME TO.
SEEING NONE- TO TELECONFERENCE.
SHE NONE YOU MAY OPEN UP THE
LINE- IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THE EXPRESS OPPOSITION- FOR- S.
B. TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE
WILL START WITH ONLINE THREE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS TIFFANY CHEVRON
I'M WITH THE SECOND AMENDMENT
LAWCENTER AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. TWO SIXTY FOUR. TWO
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS GARY BRENNAN I
REPRESENT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND WHICH
REPRESENTS THE ALABAMA ST
ATHLETIC CLUB. HE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE DISASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION DUCKS UNLIMITED SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER CALIFORNIA YOUTH
ADVENTURES ESCONDIDO FISHING
GAME ASSOCIATION IN A GERMAN
SHORTHAIR POINTERS CLUB THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY LEMON GROVE ROD
AND GUN CLUB. THE NATIONAL WILD
TURKEY FEDERATION SAN DIEGO
CHAPTER THE NORTH AMERICAN
VERSATILE HUNTING DOG
ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO CHAPTER
PALOMAR SPORTSMAN'S CLUB
PHEASANTS FOREVER IMPERIAL
COUNTIES PROJECT TWO THOUSAND
RANGE IN SAN DIEGO- QUAIL
FOREVER SAN DIEGO CHAPTER
SAFARI CLUB INTERNATIONAL SEND
US OF SAN DIEGO CHAPTER. AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY GUN OWNERS-
SAN DIEGO COUNTY VARMINT
CALLERS WHO SAN DIEGO SPORTING
DAHLE CLUB THE SAN DIEGO
RETRIEVER IN FIELD TRIAL CLUB
SAN DIEGO SPORTS DOG TRACKERS
ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO JUNIOR
PHEASANT HAN. OF SOUTH BAY ROD
AND GUN CLUB AND THE TRIPLE B.
ADVENTURES ACTIVE VALOR AND MY
COUNTRY CLUB AND WE ALL TWENTY
THOUSAND A LIST OPPOSE SB. TWO
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE WILL TO PAY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
IT'S A MEMBERS OF THE TO MY
NAME IS BILL REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BOWMAN HUNTERS HE
CAL OR WETLANDS AND WATERFOWL
COUNCIL THE TULARE BASIN
WETLANDS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSE MEANT FOR CON.
THE BLACK PLANT GROUPS AND ARE
PART OF THE NATIONAL CENSUS GO
BAY AREA CHAPTER AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEER ASSOCIATION ALL
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. P.
TO SIXTY FOUR. YOU. THANK YOU
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIFTY FUTURE STOMACH MAN I'M
NOT SURE OF THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND AN ARMY MEMBER
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TWO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOOR ROSE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
COULDN'T GET THROUGH ON THE
INITIAL- LINE WE ARE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER THAT'S B. TWO
SIXTY FOUR WE THANK SENATOR MAN
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU. TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR OP ED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REALLY BLACK YEAH I HAVE
A MESSAGEFROM STEVE LINDLEY
THAT HE'S TRYING TO GET THROUGH
EACH HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND HE IS A
WITNESS FOR THIS BILL AND I
THINK HE HE NEEDS TO BE HEARD
WE ONLY HEARD FROM ONE OF MY
TWO WITNESSES. OF. CAN YOU.
TAKE WELL WHAT LINE IS THE ON
DUTY TODAY. HE SAID HE'S JUST
ON HOLD AND FOR SOME REASON
HE'S NOT BEING- HE'S JUST ON
HOLD WHEN HE HAS BEEN FOR SOME
TIME OKAY LET'S GO THROUGH WITH
THE ME TOOS AND THEY WILL TRY
TO FIND HIM. AT THE SAME TIME
ALL RIGHT HANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE HE HAS THE CORRECT
NUMBER RIGHT NOW- I BELIEVE
YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN. HE HAS THAT-
HE AGREED YOU RECIEVE THE MATH
OKAY SO- BECAUSE WE HAVE LIKE
THIRTY PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MARK AND IT WOULD
HELP ME WATER EIGHT IN OUR
OFFICE. IS GONNA NEGATIVE
IMPACT FRONT BRAKE PADS ON OCT.
MEANWHILE BY TRANSPORTATION.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE
THREE NINE TWO GO AHEAD. THREE
OH NINE YOU ARE OPEN. YOU'RE
NOT WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
OPEN WHILE WE WILL NINE THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN
BUT WELL I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS INTER
INTER A MEMBER AND I AM VERY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO
SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE THREE SIXTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE ALLOW AT.
HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU. SO YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES NAY
MINERALIZATION PLEASE. HI MY
NAME IS STEVE RODDA I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL NRA NRA
LIFE MEMBER AND- US NAVY
VETERAN AND I'M STRONGLY URGING
YOU TO OPPOSE SB TWO SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE ZERO NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
ZERO NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. YES I BELIEVE THAT
STATE THIS IS MICHAEL FINLEY
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
REPRESENTING RETAILERS
MANUFACTURERS AND RANGES TODAY
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE THREE
NINETEEN YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
GARY YES WE AREA. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CARLENE ELLIS BY
MY COMPETITION SHOOTER AND I AM
A CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ON A
VOTER I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND THE GUN OWNERS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'M JAMES WESTFALL- MEMBER
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY GUN
OWNERS CHAPTER OF C. R. PA THE
NRA SECOND AMENDMENT FOUNDATION
ON THE GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
ONE YOU ARE OPEN. THREE TWENTY
ONE. CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO
HELLO HELLO NEIGHBOR
NORMALIZATION HELLO. YES MY
NAME IS HEADED THERE ARE NONE
LEFT MEMBER OF THE NRA AND THIS.
THE RPA. AND I EXPLAINED THE
OPPOSED SB TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU. TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS PATTERSON AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE- TO HIM A
COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE COUNCIL
OF THE CALIFORNIA RECKON PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I'M A LIFE MEMBER
OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION. AND RETIRED
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
SERGEANT IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JONATHAN I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE NEVADA COUNTY
GUN OWNERS A CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKSHOPS AND CAL
POLY RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION- THE MEMBERSHIP OF
NEVADA COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSES
THIS BILL ON ALSO IN OUR ELECT
MEMBERS DON'T SHALL APPOINT
MEMBERS SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF BURKE FARMS. ALSO
PUBLISHING. YEAH CHARLIE PAPA
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. ONE
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN HI
MIKE BRANKO OF A RESIDENT OF
SENATOR MEANS DISTRICT AND THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND I'M
OPPOSING SB TWO SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY A
ZERO FOR SB TWO SIXTY FOUR TO
SHOW OPPOSITION AND WE WERE
LIKE- THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AT THREE TWENTY SIX I
THINK YOU TOOK YOURSELF
BARBECUE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
REACH YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THEIR OWN LOCAL
LINE. THREE FORTY ONE. HI MY
NAME IS MELANIE HIT I AM A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER I'M ALSO A
LIFETIME MEMBER OF THE NRA AND-
GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEN THE SHOOTING SPORT TRACTOR
FOR USE IN THE FOR H. I. TRONG
LEE OPPOSE. SB. THREE SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
MIKE BLANCO I'M A RESIDENT OF
SENTIMENTS DISTRICT AND A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I'M OPPOSED
TO SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY. THREE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT ARE YOU CAN
YOU HARRIS. ONE MORE TRY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
MOVING LINE THREE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LISAGAFFNEY I'M A MEMBER OF
WOMEN FOR AMERICAN VALUES AND
ETHICS AND MY MOTHER MY FAMILY
OWNS ABOUT FORTY GUNS AND WE
ALL THE COURT SB TWO SIXTY FIVE
BECAUSE WE DON'T BELIEVE IN-
AND WITHOUT LICENSES. THANK YOU.
ONE THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. HELLO. WELL NEXT
YOUR- WHY IS HE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I'M STILL
YOUNG I'M NOT AND I'M STILL
YOUNG UNLIKE A NUMBER OF THE
NRA CAN SECURE A AND- I OPPOSE
WHEN I WHEN I ANSWERED. THE NEW
YORK. YES THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE ONE MORE WITH AN OPERATOR.
NOBODY OUTSIDE TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO SIX FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
OKAY AND- WE WILL GO TO WINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. HI MY NAME IS JULIA DOWN
LOW AND I'M A LICENSED GUN
OWNER ENGAGEMENT'S DISTRICT AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT. SB TWO
SIXTY FOUR I'M AGAINST TO GO TO
GUNS BEING SOLD ON FAIRGROUND
PROPERTY. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES. NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
MY NAME IS PETER STEIN I'M A
LIFE MEMBER OF WAYS WOMEN FOR
AMERICAN VALUES AND ETHICS AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. UP WITH YOU
ABOUT. TODAY I HEARD YOU ARE
MISSING ON NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE YEAH. THREE FIFTEEN ARE
OPEN. HELLO DAMON PLEASE. HI MY
NAME'S TELL HIM- I'M A MEMBER
OF THE NRA AND THE **** AND AYE
OPPOSED-SB SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU ARE ARE WE CLOSE. ARE WE
NEAR THE END PRETTY OUT. YEAH
NOT MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE-
EXHAUSTED THE OPPOSITION YOU
OKAY ONLINE. TWO FOUR SEVEN IS
SUPPOSED TO BE STEVE. LAIDLEY.
STEVE LYNN A FROM THE BRADY
ORANGE COUNTY HE'S SUPPOSED TO
BE ON THE ONLINE. TWO FOUR
SEVEN. HI I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YOU HAVE TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES. OKAY THESE ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEVE ONLY I
HAVE TWENTY YEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE I WAS
THE CHIEF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT JUST AFTER FIREARMS
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND NINE TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF AND IN LIMITATION
FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY CHAPTER
BRADY. IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CALIFORNIA NOT TO THE NATION'S
BROADEST WAS A LEGISLATION TO
ENSURE REASONABLE BUSINESS
PRACTICES AGAIN SHOWS THE
SEMINAL TWO NINETY FIVE. THE
CALIFORNIA ALL CHOIR AND
TRANSFER THEGUN SHOWS MUST BE
PROCESSED THROUGH A LICENSED
FIREARM DEALER. IN LICENSE I AM
PETER COOPER NOT A GUN SHOW OF
COMPILING ALL APPLICABLE LAWS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA'S WAITING
PERIOD THE OTHER CULTURE LAWS
GOVERNING THE TRANSFER OF
FIREARMS BY DEALERS. LOCAL
ORDINANCES REGULATIONS AND FEES
HOWEVER IF YOUR FEDERAL BUREAU
OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND FIREARMS
IN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JESTER FIREARMS. INVESTIGATIONS
AGAINST DOES HAVE RESULT IN
ARRESTS FOR SURE SECOND
INCLUDING PROPERTY SHOULD. STOP
ARMS TO PEOPLE CONVICTED OF
FELONIES AND OTHER PROHIBITIONS
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS BY
PROHIBITED PEOPLE IMPOSITION OF
ASSAULT WEAPONS AND MACHINE
GUNS. LIKE PIRATES PRODUCER
BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITIES
FIRES PRODUCE A GUN SHOW SHOW
UP A CALIFORNIA CRIMES YOU CAN
ADD TO THAT BECAUSE THEY SHOULD
OUR COMMUNITY. SPECIFICALLY IT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR LAST YEAR IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICES
AND YOUR PORCH TO THE
LEGISLATORS ON THERE ARE
PARTICULAR PERSON SYSTEM
REPORTER EFFORTS. HE TURNED
GENERAL STATED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS STOPPED THE
LEGISLATIVE I'M SORRY ASSEMBLY
MANDATED AND FUNDED
ENFORCEMENT. OF GUN SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA. HELLO HAS LEAST
LEVINE AND- IN PRO LIKE UP TO
TWENTY BASED. TO FARMERS WILL
THEIR VIOLENT TAKING THROUGHOUT
OUR GREAT. CALIFORNIA CONTINUE
TO SEEK A UP TO REDUCE. ARMORY
BROWN. CAL LET'S NOT ALLOW WITH
THE TO PAR. SELLABLE BY YOUR
GUN. THAT ACCOUNT. ATTITUDE
COST OF FIRE RELATED. THE
COMPUTER USERS. IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I WANTED TO. LEVEL
GROUP I CALLED BY EXPO AND CAL
DEPARTMENT IS PURIFIER- YOU THE
IS A OFFER. WILL NOT MAKE THE
ARREST OF THE GUY. WE WILL
FOLLOW THE SUSPECT IS A AWAY
FROM THIS IN THE TO. BORROW
MORE FOR ME MORE PRESS- WE- AND
COULD NOT PREVENT YOU TYPE OF
THE- I THE GUN SHOW IT'S- WILL
WOULD NOT BE. DURING A PUBLIC
REQUEST ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
TO ASK FOR A REST MEET AGAIN
CHAU. AND THEY'RE NOT THERE
THESE INVESTIGATIONS TAKE TIME
THEY COULD TAKE HOURS DAYS TO
WEEKS AFTER FOUR CALIFORNIA.
APARTMENT JUST ACTUALLY- MIXER
CASE AND MAKE YOUR LAST. I
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TODAY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AND I ASK HER. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU- I BELIEVE
WE'VE HEARD SOME AND I. NOW
WILL BRING IT TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTION COMMON. MISTER CLARK.
MY FIRM BELIEF IS THAT A GUN IS
THE MOST DANGEROUS THING YOU
CAN HAVE IN YOUR HOUSE- THE
MOST LIKELY USE OF A GUN IS TO
pBY SUICIDE- OR ACCIDENT OR-
THROUGH. AN ARGUMENT FOR
EXAMPLE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED TO
MARVIN GAYE'S FATHER SHOT HIM
IN THE HEART. AT ANY RATE SO I
I'M DEFINITELY NOT PRO GUN BUT
MY CONCERN ABOUT THIS BILL IS
ALL YOU'RE DOINGIS MOVING THEM
OFF THE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS TO
SOMEWHERE ELSE- I WOULD BE MUCH
MORE IN FAVOR OF A BILL THAT
SIMPLY. IF YOU FEEL THERE'S
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY GOING ON THAT
EITHER DOES SOMETHING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN
AT STATE FAIRGROUNDS OUR DOES
NOT HAPPEN IN THE STATE AS A
WHOLE. I JUST DON'T SEE WHERE
THIS MOVES THE BOOK THE BALL
FORWARD IN TERMS OF MAKING
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFE. IS THAT
A QUESTION ARE. YOU CAN
ANSWERED IN YOUR CLOTHES. OKAY
ARE YOU COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CENA
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU SHARE
AND I JUST WANTED TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION- I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE TRUTHFUL
AS THEY REPEATEDLY STATED- BUT
I IT IS NOT TRUTHFUL TO STATE
THAT THERE ARE NO ILLEGAL
FIREARMS ARE UNLICENSED
FIREARMS SOLD AT GUN SHOWS. AS
YOU HEARD FROM THE FORMER CHIEF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S BUREAU FIREARMS THERE
ARE MANY INSTANCES OF THIS IN
FACT I BELIEVE THAT IN A RECENT
SENATE REPORT I WAS TOLD THIS
ANECDOTALLY- THE SAME
CONCLUSIONS REACH WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY INSTANCES. OF
ILLEGAL AND UNLICENSED FIREARMS
BEING SOLD AT GUN SHOWS- I ALSO
WANT TO DISAGREE RESPECTFULLY
WITH THE- ASSESSMENT ON THE
SEVEN MINUTE WE'VE REFERRED TO
COUNCIL I WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE'S A SECOND AMENDMENT
ISSUE I APPRECIATE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL WHILE LAST NIGHT
WAS A FORMER LAW PROFESSOR BUT
I TAUGHT CONTRACTS SO I'M NOT A
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW EXPERT
MYSELF- BUT THE DECISION THOSE
REFERENCE MCDONALD V. CHICAGO.
SIMPLY STATES AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THAT THE SECOND AMENDMENT
APPLIES TO STATES AND
LOCALITIES THAT'S SIMPLY SAYS
THAT WE HAVE TO RESPECT THE
RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS WITH AS PART
OF A RIGHT WELL REGULATED
MILITIA. IT DOES NOT SAY
ANYWHERE IN THE SECOND
AMENDMENT THE STATE'S MUST USE
THEIR PROPERTY TO SELL GUNS
THAT WE MUST BE COMPLICIT IN
THIS AND THIS GETS ME TO
SOMEONE RECORDS QUESTION. I
BELIEVE RIGHT NOW LOOK HERE'S
AFFECT. GUN SHOWS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A HIGH
PROPORTION.OF GUNS BEING SOLD
IN THE STATE SO THERE'S ALWAYS
THE WHAT IF WILL THAT. BE LIKE
A COMPRESSION WE'RE JUST MOVING
GUNS INTO. LESS REGULATED PARTS
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT-
OTHER THAN RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR INORDINATE
NUMBER OF GUNS I WE DON'T HAVE
STATISTICS I ASKED- IN ORANGE
COUNTY DO WE KNOW WHERE THE GUN
THAT WAS USED TO KILL A LEO'S
THE SIX YEAR OLD BOY WHO WAS
KILLED IN ACT ROAD RAGE CAME
FROM. AND I TOLD ME WE WOULD
GET BACK TO ME. BUT WE KNOW IT
WAS LEGALLY PURCHASED WHICH
MEANS PROBABLY IS A FIFTY FIFTY
CHANCE THAT WAS PURCHASED AT A
GUN SHOW IN ORANGE COUNTY SINCE
I BELIEVE. THAT ROUGHLY 50% OF
GUNS IN MY AREA ARE ARE
PURCHASED AT THE GUN SHOWS.
THAT THAT IS JUST AN
UNACCEPTABLE CROSS TO BEAR AND
WE SOLVE THAT PROBLEM NOW BUT I
ALSO THINK WE ESTABLISH A LINE
IN THE SAND. THAT SAYS THE
STATE SHALL NOT BE COMPLICIT
THAT WERE THE ARGUMENTS BEING
MADE IN FAVOR GUN SHOWS OTHER
THAN I THINK THE- FACTUALLY
WRONG ONCE ABOUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT OR LOCAL CONTROL. OUR
ARGUMENTS AROUND REVENUES
ESSENTIALLY BUT THE REVENUES
THAT THESE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
RECEIVED FROM THESE GUN SHOWS
IS A SMALL FRACTION. OF THE
TERRIFYING COSTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE SO WITH ALL THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MOTIONS SECOND. AB MEDAL
SECTOR CALL THE ROLL. I'M SB
TWO SIX FOUR BY MEN THE MOTION
TO PASS TO THE UPPER COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQ.
BAUER-KAHAN LEAD. COURT NOT
QUICK NOT VOTING SANTA C. R.
TELL NO C. OUR TURN NOW WICKS.
THANK LEVERAGES LOCAL NEEDS
NEEDS FOR MY MEMBERS SHOW.
CENTER NUMBER. THANK FOR YOUR.
WELL THANK YOU THIS FEATURE
MEMBERS- I THINK I'M LAST BILL
YES YOU ALL ALL RIGHT WE'LL SB
THIRTY FIVE OF THE ELECTION WAS
CONDUCTED NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY WAS DONE IN AN EXCELLENT
FASHION HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I THINK MOST PLAYS THE UNITED
STATES THERE SOME PROBLEM
AMERICANS DON'T AGREE BUT WE
HAVE SOME GLITCHES LET ME TALK
ABOUT THE GLITCHES ONE GLITCHES
APPARENTLY SOME PEOPLE THINK
YOU CAN POST A FILE CABINET
FROM YOUR HOUSE SLAPPING
OFFICIAL STICKER ON IT. AND
PEOPLE THINK THAT THEY CAN
DEPOSIT THE BELTS THERE CAN'T
DO IT WE'RE GOING TO CLEAR IT
UP THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
ALSO IF YOU STICK A SIGN ON A
TELEPHONE POLE BY POLLING PLACE
THAT IS ACTUALLY CAMPAIGN
HEADQUARTERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DO THAT CAN'T DO THAT ALSO IF
YOU SURROUND A AN OFFICIAL
BALLOT BOX OFFICIAL PLACE TO
DEPOSIT YOUR BALLOT YOU HARASS
PEOPLE TRYING TO ACTUALLY
DEPOSIT THEIR BALLOT CAN'T DO
THAT. THIS CLEARS THAT UP.
CAN'T HARASS PEOPLE WHO WERE
WAITING IN LINE TO VOTE EITHER
CLEARS THAT UP SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT I WANT TO
THANK UP- YOUR STAFF FOR NIKKI
MORE FOR IMPROVING THE BILL I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL- IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I
HAVE NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK FOR
THIRTY MINUTES OR SO ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF ELECTIONS. WITH
THAT I ASTRONOMICAL. THE I HAD.
HEY GREGORY DST STILL MR ARE A
VOTERS FOR NEVADA COUNTY LONG
OVER THAT'S IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS DíAS
IS ON THE PHONE OKAY. DAN AS
RELATION WE DON'T SKIP A MONTH
IF YOU HAVE- YOU WILL GO TO
ROOM EARLIER ANYONE IN A ROOM
IN. IN FAVOR OF THE BUILD LIKE
TO SPEAK ON A FORTY THREE OH
TWO. SB THIRTY FIVE SEEN NONE.
TO THE MMHM SEEING NONE- YOU
MAY OPEN UP LINE FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
SB THIRTY FIVE I'M BURKE. THANK
YOU TôI TESTIFYING IN FAVOR OF
SB THIRTY FIVE I PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE-
TWO FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO FORTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. ARE
MOVING ON I WILL TRY TO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY
EIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
HERE IN UNDERSTOOD THE NEXT.
ALL RIGHT- ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. TWO FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT AGAIN I. ONE TWO
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T BELIEVE THE RIVER OF THE
CALIFORNIA THINK OF THE LAST
WOMAN STANDING HERE- THE HAS
THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED PETITION
ON SB THIRTY FIVE WE
UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT EXTENDING
THE DISTANCE FOR ELECTION AND-
ALL OF THE ELEMENTS THAT CENTER
ON BOARD MENTIONED ARE
CONCERNED HAS BEEN THAT SOME
PROVISIONS COULD INADVERTENTLY
IMPEDED PUNISH AND THAT'S ABOUT
COLLECTION ACTIVITY DISTINCT
FROM INTENTIONAL. EFFORTS TO
THE TABLE WITH VOTERS WHICH
DISPEL POPULAR ELEVENTH MAY
TAKE A COMMITTEE TODAY GO ALONG
WAY TOWARD RESOLVING THIS
CONCERNS WHILE APPRECIATE
EXPRESSED APPRECIATION TO
SENATOR- BURKE IS STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH US ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE THREE. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SENATOR- BURKE
TONY TO KERO ANOTHER WOMAN LEFT
STANDING WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL. S. B. I'M SORRY
SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE BY A
SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU. NO WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LICENSE YOU
MISTER THANK YOU. WHEN I VOTER
OPPOSITION I'VE HEARD RUTH
WEISS ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT IS SHE ON THE LINE. I
AM ON THE LINE. YOU MAY BEGIN
BUT I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE TO TEN
AFTER THE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE IF IT'S BEEN A
VERY LONG MEETING BUT VERY
INTERESTING- I BEGIN BY
AFFIRMING THAT YEAR PCA IS
SUPPORTIVE OF ANY EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT VOTERS ARE NOT HE-
SAID VOTER PRIVACY IS PROTECTED
AND INTEGRITY PRESERVED. AND
MANY TENANTS OF SB THIRTY FIVE
SEEK THOSE BANDS AND WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT
BUT SB THIRTY FIVE PROPOSED
CHANGE TO SECTION SIX OF
ELECTION CODE EIGHTEEN FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT REGARDING OFFICIAL
VERSUS UNOFFICIAL BALLOT
COLLECTION BOXES THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE A
PREVIOUS WRONG AND GREATLY
INCREASE VOTER PROTECTION. WHEN
AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WITH
PASSED ALLOWING UNRESTRICTED
AND UNREGULATED BALLOT
HARVESTING IT DID MORE THAN
JUST PROVIDE VOTERS WITH ONE
MORE WAY TO SUBMIT THEIR BALLOT
WITHOUT LIFTING A FINGER IT
ALSO UNLEASHED VAST
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VOTERS TO BE
HARASSED CAJOLED PRESSURED
REMUNERATED OR ILLEGALLY HELPED
AND THEIR BALLOTS TO BE
SUBJECTED TO OUTSIDE FILTERING
THROUGH WELL FUNDED DOOR TO
DOOR CAMPAIGNS. YOUR PCA HAS
CLEAR DOCUMENTATION THAT ALL OF
THE ABOVE HAS OCCURRED EACH
ELECTION SINCE AND SO TO LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO ACTUALLY PROSECUTE
IT OUT OF CONTROL BALLOT
COLLECTORS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
PRESENTED AND CONTINUES TO
PRESENT A THREAT NOT ONLY TO
ELECTION INTEGRITY BUT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND CITIZENS
RIGHTS THE CAPTAIN I'M
INFLUENCED VOTE. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE ALSO OBLITERATED
CHAIN OF CUSTODY WHEN BALLOT
FALL OUTSIDE IN THE CUSTODY OF
FEDERAL A U. S. P. S. OFFICIALS
AND COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
LOSING CHAIN OF CUSTODY NAME OF
ALL PROTECTION AND SECURITY
INTERDICTING SERIOUS THE
LEGITIMATE DOUBT INTO ELECTION
RESULTS. LAST WEEK THE
FOOTPRINT PART OF THE UNITED
STATES ISSUED A SIX TO THREE
RULING THEY CONSIDERED THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SESSION BY RELEASING. IT
LAST AND WITH GREAT POMP AND
SAN. WITH RESPECT TO- RIGHT TO
PER. BALLOT HARPER THEY RULED
THAT STATES HAVE A- INTEREST.
IN PREVENTING VOTER AND THAT
THE POLICIES WERE. TO PREVENT
SUCH STRONG. THEY CONTINUE TO
SAY THAT IN. THAT EVERY VOTER
CASTS BREEDING WITHOUT INTENDED
OR UNDUE INFLUENCE IS A VALID
AND IMPORTANT STATE INTERESTS.
CALIFORNIA IS REALLY OUT OF
STEP WITH THE SCOTUS RULING
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONTINUE TO
SEEK TO MAKE IT EASIER IF
POSSIBLE FOR CITIZENS TO
REGISTER AND VOTE. AT THE SAME
TIME PROTECTING BOTH VOTERS AND
THE ABSOLUTE INTEGRITY THOSE
VOTE. IF THE LEGISLATURE HOLD
ELECTION INTEGRITY AND PUBLIC
TRUST IN ANY REGARD IT SHOULD
NOT JUST SPEAK TO PASS A TINY
LEAK IN THE BALLOT HARVESTING
THEN. IT SHOULD AMANDA SB
THIRTY FIVE TO REFORM THE
BALLOT HARVESTING ALL TOGETHER
AND RE INSTITUTE BALLOT CHAIN
OF CUSTODY THEN AFTER THE
THIRTY FIVE WOULD BE A STRONG
VOTER PROTECTION BILL WORTHY OF
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU. NOW
LOOKING TO ROOM FOR ANY WITNESS.
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL
GO TO TELE CONFERENCE A
REDESIGN C. NOT DOLLARS OPEN UP
THE TELEPHONE LINE FOR ONE LAST
TIME FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO IT SB THIRTY
FIVE- BURKE. ONCE AGAIN THOSE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW ONCE AGAIN
ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO WHEN QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER CORK- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL. RIGHT
OKAY- I'LL JUST. IN REGARD TO
THE OPPOSITION. WHAT THAT THE
SUPREME COURT IGNORED. OUR SELF
OUR GREAT CIVIL RIGHTS VOTING
ACT AND THEY SAID OH WELL IT
DOESN'T MATTER THE TWICE AS
MANY- VOTERS OF COLOR WERE
INCONVENIENCED AND BY THIS IS
WHAT REALLY MATTERS IS BLAH
BLAH BLAH THE FACT IS IF THEY
CAN IGNORE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
LEGISLATION ADDING IN
SOMETHING- THIS IS
INSIGNIFICANT EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE THAT IN
THE BILL I'M SORRY THAT'S JUST
NOT VALID LAW. THE SUPREME
COURT IS NOT FINAL BECAUSE IT'S
RIGHT IT'S RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
FINAL AND IT'S BEEN STACKED.
ANYWAY BUT I VERY MUCH SUPPORT
YOUR BILL. NOW I'VE DONE MY
RANT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY OR SEMI
SAID SLAUGHTER THANK YOU ONE
LAST RANT NO I'M JUST KIDDING
IN FACT I'M SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL- I DO RECOGNIZING AND
PREVIOUS ELECTIONS HOW SOME OF
THE- SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES-
KIND AND GOOD GALA COULD CREATE
CONFUSION AMONGST VOTERS ABOUT
THEIR THEIR BALLOT INTEGRITY AT
CENTRAL- BUT I DO FIND IT
IRONIC THAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT
ELECTION HEARING IN WHEN I'M
DOING MY OWN. MY BALLOT MY
POLLING PLACE WHICH IS MY
KITCHEN IF SOMEBODY CAN
ACTUALLY SHOW UP AT MY DOOR AND
LOBBY ME WHILE I'M DOING THAT.
TO DO THAT AND WITH THAT REALLY
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED SOME DAY-
BUT- YOU KNOW I KNOW YOUR BILL
DOESN'T DO THAT BUT IT DOES A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS AND-
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON.
THANK YOU AND IT MEMBERS FOR
COMMENTS CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS.
SENAD YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
AND- MISS MORE FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL I'M
SORRY YOU GET THE SENSE THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR MY
THIRTY MINUTE SPEECH ELECTION
ACTIVITIES ALL JUSTICE REVIVAL.
THAT IS GOOD CENTER BURKE YOU
NEVER WANT TO TALK PASSED YES
NO JONES RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE
YOU MAY. GOOD CALL FOR THE
ROLL. ON SB THIRTY FIVE A
SENATOR. THE MISSION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
BARRICADE HAD. E. CORP HI COURT
AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AND SEE
OUR TO. SEE OUR I WICKS.
MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS MORE
TRY THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'RE
CALLING ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BACK TO INTO A FINAL CALL.
WE
HAVE QUITE A FEW BILLS ON CALL
THAT NEED ABSENT MEMBERS TO
COME TO PUBLIC SAFETY. FORTY
TWO OH TWO. YEAH K. NOT
REQUIRED AT ALL OKAY. YEAH.
WELL SURE WELL. CHAU YEAH.
THAT'S THE ONE WHERE THEY GOES
UP AND GO BACK. TO A LOT OF
TIMES. I DON'T CARE OF NEW IT
IS PRETTY SAFE TO SAY LIKE THIS
YEAH AVAILABLE RIGHT ON THE.
OKAY. RIGHT HERE THE BILL. THE
SECOND SECOND HALF BEEN JUST
WITH I NUMBER TWO HAS AND TO
SENSE WITH ITEM NUMBER SB FIVE
SIX SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I AM
THREE SB FOR EIGHTY SAN.
SANTIAGO I. ADAM NUMBER FOUR IS
THE T. FOR A WITH ON. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AT FIVE FOUR. BY
SENATOR RECORD SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I. NUMBER SIX SB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE AYE SENATOR BAKER
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I DON'T
NUMBER SEVEN AT THE FOUR
SEVENTY TWO WITHOUT CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN WITH A CONSENT.
ITEM NINE SB THREE THREE FOUR
BY CENTER ORONTO SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO HI. ADAM NUMBER TEN FOUR
FOUR SIX IS ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB UNIFORMS ON
CONSENT. BY ADAM NUMBER TWELVE
SB TWO SIX TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG EXCUSE ME HERTZBERG
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI. WICKS.
THAT MEASURE REMAINS ON CALL. I
REMEMBER THIRTEEN SB NINETY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI WICKS
THAT MEASURE NOW PASSAGE. I
DON'T NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B. TWO
SIX FOUR BY SENATOR MEN LACKEY.
BALLOT BLACKIE NO BARRICADE
HANNAH BARRICADE HANNAH HI LI
LI HI SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO HI
WICKS. THAT MEASURE REMAINS ON
CALL. ADAM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB
FOUR NINETY ONE WAS ON CONSENT.
I AM SEVEN EXCUSE ME ITEM
SIXTEEN SB SEVEN FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT WICKS THAT
MEASURE IS THAT MEASURE NOT
HALF THE- ADAM SEVENTEEN SB
FOUR TWENTY WITHOUT CONSENT. I
DON'T NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB THIRTY
FIVE BY SENATOR AMBER LACKEY.
YES ROCKY I OUR CAN BACK HE HAD
HI LEE LEE I WICKES WICKES I.
GOOD TO THE WICKS PARADE. THIS
THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK.
THEY'RE GOING TO GO AGAINST THE
LIST. I DON'T KNOW THE
COMPANY'S OTHER. YEAH
EVERYTHING. AN ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE S. B. TO TWO. WICKS WAIT
I AM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB NINETY
EIGHT WORKS WICKS I REMEMBER
FOURTEEN SB TWO SIX FOUR WITH.
WIXII THAT MEASURE NONPROFIT. I
AM FIFTEEN WITH A CONSENT ITEM
SIXTEEN SB SEVEN FIFTEEN WICKS
WICKS I. THAT MEASURE PASSED.
EVERYONE KEPT. SO THAT
CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. I'D BE THIRTY
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA CHECK
BEFORE I GAVEL THAT. AFTER
DIFFERENT. YEAH. RIGHT NOW WE
GOT YOU FOR DOLLARS. I DON'T
FEEL YEAH YEAH YEAH. FIFTY
THREE K. RIGHT. WE'RE NOT
ASSEMBLY. BOB SAFETY COMMITTEE
IS NOW ADJOURNED.